[Music]
so
hello and welcome to
the thirteenth and final round uh of
this year's tata steel chess tournament
my name is fiona style anthony and i'm
delighted to be joined i'm not sure how
delighted he is it is early in the
states but grand master daniel
naraditsky dania how are you
well i am extremely delighted i will not
make it a secret that i am very tired uh
it's
before six in the morning
uh but it's been an absolutely
phenomenal event and if i'm this tired i
can only imagine how tired the players
are
uh i'm still as excited as ever for the
action and uh there's nothing i would
rather get up in the morning for than
this
that's great to hear well before we have
a look at uh the results and the pairing
and and so on and congratulations once
again to our two winners who won the
event with the round to spare first of
all air
argenti with a simply phenomenal
performance in the challengers
tournament
and of course congratulations to world
champion
magnus carlsen who won an eighth title
here in vikenzi absolutely
incredible uh but we still have some
other podium places to be decided first
of all let's see how did magnus get
there what were the results uh yesterday
yeah i mean it was an incredible day
magnus defeating fabiano caruana with
the black pieces down in exchange
uh and of course that exchange wasn't
lost it was sacrificed in an exquisite
positional effort uh what a way for
magnus to end the tournament
and uh of course mohammed yarov beating
vidit that was a crazy peace blunder sam
shanklin defeating karjakin less than 30
moves uh of course magnus's performance
is amazing as it is uh doesn't fully
overshadow all of these other incredible
performances that we saw yesterday and
even the draws were definitely very
combative as well
absolutely and let's see what uh
an action pack they meant for the
standings
so with one round uh to go and remember
the reason magnus has already won it is
because he will not be playing today
we'll get to that in a second
but uh for second place a few people
still in contention shakira mamidyarov
and richard report currently sharing
second on seven and a half but anish
right behind and there is actually a
direct clash in that group so let's get
to the to the pairings
he let us review the pairings for the
day
we have enforced shankland
we have grendelius against
jkd
oh and we have a report gary that's
going to be a big match up in terms of
determining who is atop the podium
uh
prague is playing isapenko
another marquee matchup between two very
exciting young players carlson dubois of
course is not going to happen that is a
walk over win for magnus and mahmud yara
of carawana fabi is definitely going to
look for some sort of redemption in the
last round karjakin facing off against
vitid both of those players fiona are
going to come in pretty darn angry i
feel like neither of them had a
particularly restful night of sleep
yesterday yeah absolutely and i'm very
curious to see how both of them will
have bounced back
respectively
really i think watching vidit yesterday
after his blunder was one of the most
painful moments of the the tournament
where
really
that blunder i mean the the way he felt
shown true so clearly on camera uh but
those two games very much looking
forward also of course to the clash
between rapport and anishkiri as you
said um the two players uh direct
competitors
for the podium
finish and dania not just the players
but also our viewers at home can get
involved how do they do it
well today is the last round so it's
particularly important for everyone
uh to get involved do not forget to vote
on the results of today's games head on
over to chess.com events navigate to the
tournament select a game click vote and
select your winner you could win a piece
of the one thousand dollar prize pool
for best voters there's also free
diamond memberships but the most
important thing voting ends on the 10th
move so do not procrastinate go on to
chess.com events asap and vote on the
results absolutely as dania said this is
your last chance so go and do it now and
dania we are gonna go
on a very short break and we'll be back
in a couple of minutes here with the
start of the round so don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
[Music]
fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the final round here at
tata steel chess 2022 and dania first
player to arrive at the board he is
ready for that last round clash against
richard report it is anishkiri
yeah as we see him staring off it to the
distance contemplating
the meaning of life he's got the black
pieces today not the tournament that
anish would have hoped for
sort of got off on the wrong foot of the
loss to magnus in round two but magnus
is a runaway train this tournament he's
really not the only one
uh who who got
you know hit and and didn't know what
hit him you know you blink and magnus
has played the catalan and destroyed you
in 25 moves so
what to do such as life magnus it was
interesting to hear magnus's thoughts on
on the catalan yesterday and yeah i mean
he has every reason to be
satisfied who are forbidden on the other
hand who is just arriving there uh he
will be disappointed he was one of the
early leaders he had such a great start
to the event and towards the end um
it
all came falling apart a little bit
yesterday was in great shape uh up to
the moment he allowed uh that f5 move
against mamedyarov
yeah i mean the dominoes really fell in
the wrong direction first he lost to
prague
in in a game that really he shouldn't
have lost uh and a game that he he could
have essentially achieved a risk-free
position
uh but of course all credit to prague
that was an incredible effort
but yesterday another very very inspired
opening
and then that blunder came absolutely
out of nowhere and you know i saw him
playing blitz on chess.com a couple of
hours after after the round very
relatable moment
uh you're just so disgusted with
yourself you want to wipe the slate
clean
and convince yourself that you're still
capable of playing some good chess we'll
see how that uh impacts this play today
but
it probably won't impact it that
negatively i think
yeah no i think i absolutely am with you
it's so important to just shake that
feeling uh that you have after the game
and we'll see he's currently still
waiting
uh for
um
for karjakin to arrive
elsewhere has placed
no play will start in a couple of
minutes i'm over eager but there we see
prague arrive for his clash against
andreas panko dania what do you expect
of this matchup between the two
youngsters well i think andre playing
black he's not going to be going you
know
crazy with the black pieces to produce
winning chance but prague is a very
solid player so
i would make the prediction that we're
going to see at least two quick draws
um and it's hard to say which games
exactly we'll see them in but i would
anticipate that given that first place
is not being contested
uh you know
some of these players are probably going
to come to the board with pretty
peaceful intentions and
uh you know the people playing black
today are not necessarily going to
protest
uh but it's really hard to say you know
what mentality the players are coming
into the board with because some of them
such as nils for example might also want
to
end the tournament on a very positive
note and nils is a very fighting player
uh so one could absolutely imagine that
he for example wants to seize the
opportunity uh to play a full game
against jkd i could see it being one way
or the other for sure and then we see
jordan van ferece arrive for his clash
against them and uh exactly at 12 on the
dot
as sam starts uh the clock this game as
well like i think we could have a fight
here sam he's made his feelings towards
quick drawers uh very clear
yeah he has although obviously once
again sam is the black pieces so he's
not really going to protest
uh if jordan plays something
relatively peaceful and i think the
clocks have been started
and so as we see that the bottom right
corner that board no game will be played
that's where magnus and duboff would
have been i think everyone has arrived
except for sergey karyakin so we still
see
uh
oh and young christophe duda the two
players are still uh missing for visit
i'm curious to see what approach he
takes today because uh he will be
playing in the first run prelag which is
starting uh in only four days
yeah i mean he needs to hit the reset
button uh because he's got a huge
tournament coming up and that's one of
the hardest things to do especially when
you end the tournament like this your
confidence level drops
you you know you start doubting
you just start doubting yourself and
to reset completely recuperate in four
days
and then start a tournament in a
completely new place setting
is is uh it's one of the necessities of
professional chess and yet it's one of
the most difficult aspects of of the
life of a professional chess player that
really isn't often talked about but but
is uh tremendously difficult from not
just an objective chess wise point of
view but also from
if you just an athletic physical
point of view and you're exhausted
and and you just need to find a way to
to gather up the reserves of energy and
pour them into
uh the next tournament because you're
going to be playing people who haven't
played in this tournament and they're
going to be very fresh
yeah i'm very much looking forward the
grand prix of course is going to decide
the last the final two spots for the
candidates tournament as sergey karjakin
he doesn't need to worry about that he
has qualified already through the world
cup he has arrived for his game and he's
uh just opening now with one
e4 and i don't know maybe we can go to
the bird's eye view to get an impression
of
of what these opening stages look like
yeah well we're seeing
a queen's gambit
uh declined in mamidyar of carowana that
is a line which could potentially end in
a quick draw there's one of those famous
you know early repetitions
that starts exactly as they've started
so we'll keep an eye on that now
again i wouldn't be too surprised if
shakira just decides
to end his tournament to end his good
tournament on a solid note but we see
for example that prague
is repeating a line that has uh been a
frequent guess this tournament the same
as schnimzo indian
he goes a3 and that signals his
intentions as being anything but
peaceful
yeah we definitely have a fight on our
hands they're karjakin just deciding
what is it gonna be an italian or every
lopez i guess you're hoping for the real
offense again
yeah always i'm i'm a roy lopez person
or maybe even something else like the
fanciani
uh although that's that's wishful
thinking obviously oh it's gonna be the
floor little scotch would be nice
a little scotch would be nice in
position
grandinas against zuta one of the rare
open sicilians we've had in this event
truly um and i think i want to say we
had a well we had a rosalina yesterday
in in fabiano against carlson and a
rouser that is very infrequent guest at
this level and it's one of the most
underrated openings period
not no no qualifiers one of the most
um people just don't think of the
browser on the same level as the nidorf
but it really is sorry if you want to go
ahead do you want to start there and
tell us why why that is
sure
so it's interesting you know tracing the
the history and level of popularity and
i've talked about this throughout the
tournament a lot of uh subjective
beliefs about openings are shaped by
fashion
rather than actual
objective evaluation and nobody has ever
refuted the rouser it's always been a
full-fledged weapon really since it uh
gained prominence
you know several decades ago
uh and yet it's always been overshadowed
by
you know the night or f and the
svashnikov
and uh you know but more recently the
taimanov
uh but there are players like daniel
dubov
who have really made a career playing
the rouser uh very very successfully and
it's not exactly like the night or if
it's got similarities to the shivanin
again it's got similarities to the night
or sometimes to the dragon uh it's its
own opening
and uh it also has a lot of different
systems within the opening so for
example even in this position black has
the old school system bishop d7 or of
course the modern move is e6 which
almost everybody plays nowadays and
after e6 queen d2 once again there's a
million different systems you can play
bishop d7 bishop e7
uh you could even play a6 and all of
those are
are viable systems that have to be
studied so i'm a big fan of the rouser
and uh i think the fact that duda is is
playing it
means that he's definitely playing for a
win this game of the black pieces
yeah so fighting opening here is some
interesting i think niels will be happy
as well i
i think he has no classical tournament
coming up for a couple of months and for
these players i know it's been a long
event but
they like playing chess and i think some
of the players will for sure give it
their all and let's go back to the the
bird's eye view and danya i'll let you
choose where to go to next
yeah i mean
mamidya of karwana is
very very likely to end in a in a quick
draw let's keep an eye on that game for
now let's see if chakriar
indeed goes for
the repetition or if he's playing this
actually as just a full-fledged weapon
i'm trying to remember exactly how the
repetition goes i know rajab and
nakamura have done this
uh a lot i think it's c takes d5
and then knight takes d5 i want to say
and then i want to say it's a3 knight c6
bishop d3
no i
yeah i can't quite put my finger but
there is some sort of a repetition
within this line i can guarantee that
it's also just a very peaceful and very
positional line that often kind of
fizzles out of black place d4
um but
i guess we'll see and i don't know what
that look means by shotguard does it
mean okay
and the tournament on a solid maybe like
you he's trying to remember where he's
from
again right how do i do this again
what do i play i see that the most
popular move is a3
captured on d5 which uh lends even more
credibility to to your theory and with
you i think this game will be a quick
choice shakia has had a great event
fabiano has had a tournament to forget i
think both of them for different reasons
but we'll be happy to
to end this game peacefully and quite
quickly
yeah i mean i think my memory is not
deceiving this is definitely the drawing
move
marijuana when knight takes d5 there's
going to be a trade
it's going to be a trade and then i feel
like that yeah there is some sort of
repetition there
well let's just keep watching he takes
on d5 we're going to see e takes d5
and bishop and a3 here is a move and
bishop d3 immediately is also a move
there's a3
bad b is going to go knight c6
almost certainly
so after knight c6 that brings us to the
position we had on the board a second
ago right where we were trying to find
uh
yeah the first fabulous gonna have some
tea
and so will i um maybe that'll help you
remember the draw
yeah i was drinking i was reading
yesterday we talked quite a bit about
fabiano's chamomile tea
and people in the church were curious
isn't it aren't you supposed to drink
chamomile tea before you you go to sleep
uh
but
not the case for fabi
yeah not the case for i mean
i've i've had it you know during the day
as well just i think the point is that
it's kind of calming
it has a calming influence and
you know for me it's it's i i would
drink tea during the game if i didn't
have such a need for coffee which
unfortunately i do so
um i can respect
i can respect the t drinker for sure um
this should be so just following the
most popular line in the position bishop
b6 castles
and now d4
e4 but this is definitely not the not
the drawing line this is a different
theoretical line so we'll see
that'd be going knight c6 yeah
we'll find out very shortly
yeah i think maybe here if we if we
blink we might miss the end of the game
but we'll move on uh for now also maybe
the players will prove us wrong but
uh shakia
he is playing quite quickly
bishop d3 is on the board as as
predicted and uh
and yeah we'll come back here if if the
players are still there for now let's go
back to the interview i'm gonna i'm
gonna make a very bold prediction that
this is the first going to be the first
game that ends
uh discounting magnus against stubove of
course
we have we do actually have a a little
scotch a fortnight wow
does he he heard you
uh he heard you and sergey is i mean
he's definitely played it before
but
a little bit of a of a flourish here in
the last round
as he he opts for a
slightly more unconventional weapon so
we go to that game or does anything go
there and i think
that as well indicates to me i don't
know what you make of it
that
sergey too once uh once a game
yeah i mean most of these players do
with the white pieces uh and
four nights scotch so
the reason i say four night scotch the
traditional scotch is d4 in this
position it's a completely different
opening in fact it has very little to do
with
uh the four night sketch the addition of
the moves knight c3 knight f6
uh mean that black generally plays
bishop b4
and that leads to its own set of
positions after knight takes c6 and in
the traditional scotch white plays e5
but here e5 is not good because of the
pin and so white goes bishop d3
d5
and now karjakin refraining from
the very typical e takes d5 and playing
the extremely uncommon move bishop d2
this has only a handful of games in the
database
and that is why vidit is settling into a
think
um first of all it's important to
clarify does this blunder upon well
bishop takes e3 bishop takes c3d takes
e4
i don't think it does because if bishop
takes f6
queen takes f6 and white recovers the
pawn and carjacking's point i think is
well it's a very symmetrical position
with the exception
uh the black has a significantly
inferior structure
on the king's side then
then white so it looks like white's got
a pretty stable
stable edge here but but it's already
thinking and that's a pretty good sign
for kayaking
yeah i don't think he will want to go
down that line uh
once again my question with the tension
in the center bishop d2 just ignored
that so if you're like do you want to
push that point do you want to keep the
tension alive do you just want to castle
and develop how do you go on about it
i seem to remember that bishop g4 is a
move here
um trying to induce f3 and then
returning to e6
i vaguely remember
some sort of a game in this line and i
see that there are two games in the
database
that followed uh this sequence what you
don't normally you don't normally want
to go d4
these positions and and the reason why
is that uh well white's white center is
now completely untouched and you know
this this allows white to start
expanding in the center with a timely e5
and you know black is black is not going
to be able to go c4 here these pawns are
kind of stuck in molasses and you can
play b3
uh creating a blockade on the light
square so this is just not very
appealing even visually
black needs to keep the tension and
there's many ways to do that i mean
black and castle bishop g4 i mentioned
uh and bishop takes c3 and d takes e4 is
still
very much uh a viable option that needs
to be considered
yeah so plenty to think about for vidit
who's just staring us right down
in the camera we'll move on from here
i'm intimidated um and let's check in
maybe with uh richard report and anish
kiwi
sure
grunfeld
we have a grunfeld which also we have
not have we even had a single broomfield
this tournament i feel like the answer
might be no yeah it's crazy
i mean it's wild how this just happens
during a 13-hour tournament you just
don't have sicilians
grunfeld
until now and uh
what line does richard
uh opt for well c takes d5 e4 this is
one of the main lines and now bishop e3
now there are
a thousand different setups in the grunt
field and all of them are very popular
this is one of them
the main line here continues queen a5
uh queen d2
and
you know this tension between the queens
means that there can be an end game
happening really at any moment c takes
d4 c takes d4 and the groom this kind of
groove fell on game sometimes it favors
white sometimes it favors black it
really depends on how the rest of the
pieces are arranged generally black does
not hurry with c takes d4 castles short
um rook c1 is the most popular
continuation and now black sometimes
takes on d4 sometimes flat goes rook t8
which leads to just a tremendously
complex and kind of a very classic
grunfeld style position where black is
applying pressure on the center with his
pieces
and white is trying to develop with an
eye towards solidifying the center as
much as possible
and we see anish has just gone queen a5
i mean as you were saying there are so
many options at every turn here and i
think we're only just at the the start
of the theory
theoretical discussion here between the
two players
this is still you know standard fare
it's hard to
uh hard to put a finger on on the pulse
of the position we'll see who who makes
the first surprise
i have a feeling that it'll be
unusual though richard it's quite rare
for him to go down
uh one of these mainstream lines so
maybe it'll be he who comes up with some
you know something crazy in one of these
positions
he too has gotten himself a nice cup of
tea
okay
during our next break i i have tea but
it's cold it's from yesterday night and
now that i see the the hot tea
i can't drink what i have in front of me
like i need a
piping hot you know class and i need i
need one of these glasses you know the
uh transparent glasses i feel like the
tea tastes better when you drink out of
them yeah it looks quite nice actually
visually very uh very appealing as
richard he's enjoying
clearly he's enjoying it and his eyes
keep writing towards us
yeah i mean it's almost like he senses
that
the commentators lack tea and so
you know their
their days are are simply not complete
it's like he
he's trying to signal to us you know how
much we're missing
and vic is really rubbing it in
oh big also has t
no no i mean with his closing on
oh with the camera work that's well vic
always rubs it so
that goes without saying
okay well uh yeah the start of the
the debate here
uh with richard adopting an interesting
thinking pose not even looking at the
board so
this is who needs that who needs that
exactly
he's trying to remember what he looked
at
before so we'll come back
what haven't we looked at yet
well frog against siestapenko is
is interesting and they're following in
the footsteps of enforced giri
let's go to that game
in fact they're repeating the same line
a3 was featured in that game
and uh yesterday good taking a different
approach to a slightly different
approach to a niche but the same general
plan so if you might remember that anish
played knight c6 here followed by b6 and
piling up on the c4 pawn quickly andre
goes c5 immediately
and but then he does something similar
knight c6 castles b6
and after e4 the knight drops back to e8
this is
actually the most common line this isn't
some sort of outlandish system and the
point of 98 is to take the sting out of
the movie 5. now e5 doesn't really come
with tempo i mean the other point is
that bishop g5 here
has become a pretty serious threat after
e4
what you don't want to do i mean if you
go bishop a6 you potentially allow
bishop g5 and you certainly don't want
to go h6 g5 in one of these positions
this is a massive hook
and white could exploit this with h4 f4
and
black's king is going to be busted open
here
uh so knight e8 is is a common idea in
these positions
and
this is the current position andre's
plan is very very simple if you had a
bishop a6 knight a5 this knight
sometimes comes in through d6 he wants
to win the c4 pawn and he doesn't just
want to win it period he wants to win it
and take that pawn with the bishop in
order to disarm
prague's light squared bishop which is
in the event of e5 going to be white's
main attacker prague wants to get stuff
going on the king side before he loses
the pawn on c4 it's essentially a race
so how do you uh as white how do you
initiate the race how do you want to go
on about your your king side attack well
you castle and then you just start you
know
you're running f4
and if if black ignores if black goes
knight d6
i'm seeing here that the main line goes
knight g3 so here's the pawn sacrifice
you actually give up c4
but the bottom line is after takes takes
you go f5
and uh you can kind of see how quickly
white's pieces are coming into the king
side you don't really need the light
square bishop here
because you already have all of the
other pieces and so
it's very important for black not to
allow this
and and so for that reason the main line
is f5 in this position trying to preempt
white
uh and and slow down white's attack i
see that knight g3 is a move here
g6 i mean just a very very complicated
position and
i've always i've dabbled uh
with the system with the white pieces
and i always end up losing the spawn and
not having anything to show for it but
prague has demonstrated some great
opening preparation this tournament i i
think that has not been his big problem
uh so
we will see if he can manage to carry
that forwards below yeah the opening
prep hasn't been the problem but he has
oh we have a result already wow
richard reports that was wrong aneesh
geary yeah we just came from there but
a draw was agreed just
oh they went oh of course i forgot about
this line this is a famous grenfell try
yes of course of course yeah i should
have predicted after queen a5 uh richard
going knight d2 which essentially leads
to a forced repetition uh castles knight
b3 looks like a blunder uh giving the c3
pawn away with check but no this is a
lion bishop d2 queen b2 and the queen is
perpetually pursued
between c3 and b2 it has no other
squares and a draw is
agreed and understandable results and a
great tournament fiona for
richard report who again people often
sleep on when they think of top super
gms yeah it really has been richard's
report
he finishes on 8 out of 13. he lost the
first round
but then from there on out he got a lot
of wins a lot of decisive
results as well
and he is walking away from vaikansei
with a nice
plus 10 elo points gain
wow i mean at that rating that is a very
very nifty nice nice number and uh yeah
that is the first game to end
now i amend my prediction and i will say
that my media of marijuana will be the
second game to end
also by the way
we can just say that
that also means uh if shaq draws then i
think the podium is decided um
report right he is currently in second
place on eight magnus winning of course
with nine and half
so now it's all down to to shaq
results if he draws he equalizes with
report if he wins uh he will get equal
uh sorry seoul second place
yeah and i mean again judging by shaq's
opening choice
he
has a very vast repertoire so if you
wanted to play
you know
full steam ahead all right please just
offer the draw sorry dania to interrupt
you
is going to accept it there it is okay i
wasn't too wrong
they basically ended at the same time
close but no cigar dania we won't allow
it
no no no i i i hold myself to the
highest standards i was wrong
and very soon we'll hear from anish how
does he rate his performance but yeah
that means that the podium is known uh
magnus carlson the winner of this year's
event and shakira mamidyarov and richard
report
tying for second and third place a great
event uh from from both of them
indeed and again if you put yourself in
their shoes
you what you really don't want to do is
go
crazy you know in the last round take
unnecessary risk and then lose
uh if you've had a good tournament you
would much rather you know play it safe
in the final round make sure that you
don't lose
and uh you know take some rest before
the next tournament and speaking of
which look at karyakane against vidit
um there's not too many pieces left
there either
and there's eight games database in this
in the position they have by the way
that's crazy actually
and black certainly needs to be careful
white has a tiny advantage because of
the control over the b file
but i'm my something tells me that vidit
is still in his preparation even though
he's
he spent 10 minutes in karjakin
displayed instantly so
i would be a little bit concerned
if i'm bidded here not to slip into a
bad position in the end game yeah we can
bring up the board in a second um while
we're we're still
waiting for a niche but
i thought we would have time to make our
point
have an eye on him and yeah so dania
let's i think we have a few seconds
so you're yeah
i'll just very quickly show what
happened
uh anish uh or say
i'm looking at it uh vidit going indeed
for he first he castles and then he
plays bishop c3de and then you just have
a mass liquidation takes takes takes or
create
rook b1 forcing the trade on b1
and most likely black is going to go
rook d8
to which four people have responded
bishop f3 three
i think it took more time for us to set
up the camera than
the game actually lasted um which is
partly your own fault because you set up
the camera way too long yeah let's go on
exactly um okay today like a quick draw
against uh richard's report how would
you sum up your tournament actually
richard made a very good joke which is
maybe not such a joke after all he told
me if i played the griffiths the entire
tournament i would have maybe one is and
there is some point in that because i
lost the two games in the
nimso catalan complex
and i kind of lost it pretty much out of
the opening both of them so in a way
maybe maybe that's where it all went
wrong yeah
yeah so
greenville and greenfield for life
yeah yes greenfield for life and
but like how would you um well how was
your tournament like yeah i think my
preparation was not even very good
i've spent
a lot of effort
given the circumstances that i had i've
did my best to prepare for the
tournament
and
i spent a lot of time
more than i expected
but yeah not really on the the right
things in hindsight and um
just
and maybe that's that was also partly
why my play was not very good and um
there were a couple of highlights midway
i uh
when i got out of the opening with an
okay position i played well against
yasipenko was a good game
and against shankland as well it's a
very straightforward
game but
yeah there were too many um downsides
and uh finally the score is all right
for sure um
but uh yeah not very happy with uh
with how you know the the whole uh the
whole thing went
before the tournament you told me that
you also use this tournament basically
like a little bit to prepare for the
grand prix
a lot of other players here
have exactly the same feeling um do you
think you're warmed up for the grand
prix and um how do you see the grand
prix season yeah for sure i mean every
um
well i wouldn't say a bad term but every
loss and every um
every moment you stumble uh
given that you work hard is very
important because
that shows you you know that um that
things you you improve and this is a
very important feedback
so
i i think i'm
i'm motivated to
do a few few important things and before
the grand prix i've seen
what what can go wrong i've seen what
can go right so i'll try to work on on
that and
well circumstances have to fall my way
to
to win the grand prix series but
i think that um i saw here that there is
hope for sure um
and yeah i have some time now which is
very nice i already know what i um what
i should work on i have some interesting
ideas on
how to improve my play and uh hopefully
uh you know i'll be able to accelerate
into the grand prix
what was the favor what's this your
favorite game of this tournament not not
only yours but just like the game that
you've seen here masters or challengers
good question i mean for me it was very
easy to say that i think against
espnko the shanghai was a little in a
way
there was not that much uh
that many difficult decisions i had to
take
but against this bank was very good from
the other players
magnus is yesterday game i have to say
magnus's games though um
it is incredible how far um into the
game he's prepared um
he doesn't have he didn't have to play
any unfamiliar positions you know like
already by the time he
he starts the game like the character of
the position is crystallized so i mean
yesterday for example it was just um
i've also had this um
this line
where black gets to bishops takes on b3
goes a5 and
already by the time he has to start
playing he's in a familiar position
which is very
clarified so um yeah but still a very
beautiful game i think yesterday of
magnus and surely some others were of
him were good he played a lot of high
quality games i mean just it's just the
preparation goes straight into the
uh conversion you know there's just um
uh not that much creative process but uh
very beautiful games um in hindsight and
uh yeah a lot of good games i'm sure a
challenge oh of course of course
everyone's game um
yesterday was really really good um very
beautiful exchange sacrifice also very
correct and then
yeah very nice concept overall
i have to say i clicked of course
through all the games but
it's not like
i recall arjun's
games many of them were very easy very
straightforward it felt like he's just
class apart at least here
so
didn't see anything
there that caught my eye
yeah i mean many fighting games really
here fabiano was fighting shaq was
fighting everybody richard also had a
lot of interesting games videos games
were
yeah um
just a lot of really a lot of games in
terms of content i think uh only
slightly overshadowed by a couple of
short draws like the one i just did now
with black pieces
um
that's your gesture event you haven't
won yet
will 2023 be your year
uh well i mean it's not at all a given
that i'm fighting for the first place
first of all and then as this tournament
started it seemed like this is
definitely gonna beat it
i had
a little bit of um yeah
weirdly stacked let's say pairings that
the start was really rough the way it
happened so i didn't convert my white
games i got black with magnus which i
ran into trouble
and then i also got a black at some
point guest hobby which also looked bad
at some point
but
eventually i managed to well sort of
fight for the first place i think if i
had
played better in the opening against
duda
because again i was at the time uh
having four in a row of which one was
forfeited still three in a row is not
bad so there i was kind of hopeful and i
had white against dude and uh
i just kind of got into a position from
the opening where i'm just fighting for
a draw so that kinda ruined it a bit if
i had won that game
uh i doubt i would have um
i mean if i won that game i would have
probably
more more energy and uh i would have
done something smarter uh i guess jordan
and i wouldn't have fallen into that
opening thing and then maybe maybe you
know if i'm on a high and i play niels
with white it's it's again a different
story than what it was yesterday so i
think i had chances there to win this
year as well but um
in terms of next year we have to start
from scratch uh again you know it
depends uh how prepared depends uh how
the pairings go and um
yeah just to be honest the fact that i'm
able to compete um into these great
players is already something i don't
take for granted okay thank you so much
[Music]
back to todd steele and it is a great
honor to be joined by anish geary and
yesh congratulations on finishing the
tournament and always a pleasure to have
you in uh the studio providing your
insight thank you so much
thank you thank you for correlating on
finishing the tournament indeed these
days it seems like an accomplishment
well it's a long tournament
yeah for sure for sure
like a lifetime feels like a lifetime
every every year it feels like those
tournaments in the 50s um what does it
feel like i mean does it feel
substantively different than a nine
round tournament do you feel the
exhaustion piling on or is it just like
any other tournament
yeah i think it's definitely definitely
different also
of course a lot depends on how many ups
and downs you have how many emotional
swings you got you know
i guess
certain eventful games they add up to
the
you know emotional um emotional
landscape there and uh yeah 13 rounds is
a special thing as magnus mentioned at
the opening ceremony it's really the
only tournament um you know that is that
long and that makes it really really
special for sure
well we'll get into the games but i have
to disturb you for one more question uh
just to generate some content when fabi
plays rook b6
uh what crosses your mind like what is
the first thought that enters your head
is it disbelief or are you just like
this this just happened and
you know i've been around too late and
over and over again no i've been around
too long to know that this stuff happens
uh it's not the first
nor the last stroke that is blundered in
my games so um
to be honest at that point i was no
longer
i was very happy of course but uh
to say i'm shocked would be honestly a
little bit of an exaggeration and i've
seen i've seen these things happen a lot
um there was a lot of tension in that
game it's already many many many
mistakes clearly have happened i felt
that the game was
completely out of control already uh
it's complete freestyle we had very
little time so
i expected the blunder though frankly
more from myself than him but still
blunder blunder was expected
yeah that makes sense you'd already
already lost the thread
daniel not everyone is like you yeah
playing uh 1000 bullet games without a
single tactical error not everybody's
like you
wait who is like me
i mean nobody nobody is like you because
you are playing these thousand bullet
games in a row without a single tactical
error without a single blunder it's
different it's different for us mortals
you know we blunder stuff
unfortunately when i when i sit down on
the board for a classical tournament um
i seem to lose the magic
i think you still don't plan the rooks
it's just that there's more to to to to
the game maybe then than than just rook
blunders
right but unfortunately that is true
well uh it's the last round and we've
already had two draws it's it's funny
and we were joking that you know all of
the games might be done by the time we
came back to
uh to the broadcast but a couple of them
seem to be heading in a more combative
direction so we have
a quick look at all of the remaining
games which one would you like to start
with then forest shanklin maybe we were
discussing that during the break
yeah so clearly uh let's say the game of
karakian and nvidia is heading towards
the draw as well um
but uh pregnante spence is a fight uh
is definitely a fight ss jordan against
shankland sam shankman
and uh okay let's say you know
some players they've had their reasons
but some others they
they have no reasons to uh to not fight
today and so we do have a few exciting
games for sure uh we can start with um
jordan against shankland uh it's a
pretty clear clear-cut position a
terrible position
clear kind
clear-cut cuddly bad for black
yeah clear cuts not in a good way for
black i i do like e5 in a sense that
it is terrible but at least you see
you see
how black can hold it right like in long
term like lots of suffering but lots of
trades this terrible d5 pawn and you
just stand and stand and stand and maybe
hold in the end so i do like that
transition at least
and i'll just show for the audience if
sam had just developed a bishop d7 after
bishop d3 followed by 95 it's a
nightmare scenario uh literally and
figuratively for black uh with
absolutely no active play and you know
these positions can happen in the
karakan exchange variation
so sam
says
urgency at the moment
it's very well known exactly when you've
got this half open e file
and you've got this knight on f6 and you
don't have knight e4 so the other option
instead of e5 would be 94. um as we
spoke briefly before the game started uh
and then f5 bishop d3 f5 then
i i feel blessed position is very
suspect but at least you've got that
e-file kind of blocked a little bit the
access to e5 square is blocked we should
be five yeah maybe it's good
then you take 95 and f3 and uh it's
going to be very ugly
already i've gone really wrong yeah like
let's we have to really go a few moves
back i think the mistake happened before
like somewhere around here
it's really not surprising it's really
not how you do that cdd maybe you can
play knight h5
and get access to d6 square that would
make some sense but you can't stake and
bishop d6 that's just not it
yeah mixing up ideas it seems either
bishop d6 straight away or if you take
the knight h5
and as a result
you have the dream dream set up so e5
takes takes jordan is thinking here in
knight takes e5 i thought and maybe
knight a3 yeah it seems like one way or
the other
the knight yeah maybe via d2 f3 is a bit
more uh normal let's say uh but eight by
a3 as well is the same thing you
basically
dump that knight on d4
and you start moving around
it could be a could be doable for black
because bishop d7 let's say and then
brings rook to the e file gets some
trades in stands very passive very sad
can hold these positions on a good day
though
yeah well there's no second weakness um
that's a bit of an issue for white in
terms of making progress yeah just put
the queen on d6 maybe not yet the second
weakness but as uh as it is in these
positions they sometimes appear
sometimes
i go a4 a5 later on or in the end game i
go f3 g4
start pushing on the end game obviously
yeah if 3g4 is not something you do with
queens on but
yeah you probably
know very well
how these things can still go really
wrong for black so yeah definitely a
great position for white also very easy
to play completely risk-free so
definitely
a good choice there in the opening
this is one of the things an issue that
impresses me about you super gms is
you're i i feel like i almost never win
these positions against 26 50 plus
players and
for you guys it seems you make it look
easy and sorry i didn't mean to
interrupt you no i'm not sure actually
it's uh
i mean i'm sure you're also very good at
this these things
it depends also you know on the game how
how the opponent plays
i'm sure if it's still within black's
power to defend this if he does his
utmost best but it depends on his mood
like sam what is his mood what does he
feel like is he motivated to hold uh and
grinded out
all these defensive moves or is he tired
of the whole tournament and already very
frustrated
with the fact that he got here in the
first place but it all depends on these
little things
that's interesting so let's uh let's
have a look at some of the other
positions as sam
kind of enters the suffering stage
uh what catches your eye next as we look
yeah of course
i
as people might have realized i'm not an
expert on the
same variation
but but as far as i remember this does
look uh very very similar to some
theoretical uh position that's been
debated like it looks similar to the
sicario hikaru had two games here i
think
with magnus maybe even i'm seeing queen
a4 uh listed
but not okay i mean maybe like the last
few moves have been different but this
pawn structure where uh black has gone
f5
ef eff happened the cbc happened now
like of course long term we see the
bishops yeah imagine it's an end game
the white the white bishops are dead
but currently blacks is a little shaky
like the knight on e8 is a bit passive
the f5 pawn is slightly hanging the
bishop on a6 is a bit loose so maybe
white can jump quickly with his pieces
and do some damage
yeah from that perspective q4 seems to
make sense hitting the bishop straight
away
and the game continued knight c7
um to me bishop b7 looks pretty natural
transition
should be some bishop c6 yeah that's
also the move i
considered maybe rook b1 with the idea
of bishop c6 queen a6 but then i guess
knight c7 is possible
yeah it seems white has to really do
something concrete because if you just
uh
allow black to consolidate
maybe there are some tactical resources
there should be one question two g6 here
you have or 27
instead of rook b1
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure what what
did we have achieved okay group one
first probably better to include rook b1
bishop c6 queen c2 and now g6 are quinte
seven yeah
right
yeah let's say queen d7 maybe
one
i would have loved to bring my bishop
from e3 to h4 that's the only place the
bishop can ever
be active
but it's
not easy because you need to remove the
g3 knight first which is a real pity
right this is where nimzovich would play
knight h1 and win in brilliant fashion
against
unfortunately
uh
well
in brilliant fashion oh because of the
square control yeah yeah no there's i'm
not sure about the screen a4 business um
what we have achieved
bishop on a6 was
not the best piece maybe anyway
so how do we bishop takes f5 is not a
thing
yeah i assume it's because if
bishop takes
or because of knight takes f5 25
so let's say king h8 knight takes f5 and
now is there a move
i'm not losing material immediately
though
there is bishop takes c4 yeah but then
okay then i got rid of my bad pawns and
you got the knight on e8 um maybe this
is the way to go but it's very similar
to some kind of theory bishop takes a 5
yeah if you go bishop c4 which is like
the lazy way in the final position
i i feel white could be slightly better
after queen c4 rook f5 maybe some queen
d3 or something like that and maybe c4
maybe c45 and then the bishop on e3
suddenly gets a lot of scope and the
knight on e8 is very passive this is
like nice risk-free advantage for white
yeah this looks great
so
yeah sticking there search for
alternatives here
you know instead of 97 um
can you check if g6 is not
not played a lot or
the chess.com oh g613 games yeah yeah
yeah that's the line g6 correct correct
main line and then bishop takes f5 yeah
i guess bishop takes a five now but now
after you you've got this dominant
bishop yeah gf-25 for f7
yep and i've got this light switch
the light squares
look at that and now bishop b7 yeah
and then the g4 e4
i mean why could get mated here pretty
fast like g7 yeah so g6 was the way g6
was the way to go it is that's maybe the
kicaru games like i recollect some
hikaru stuff like two games of someone
hikaru or magnus or both of them i don't
know
do you think uh yes panko might have
confused confused the line yeah but he's
also taken a lot of time so he's
definitely out of theory
yeah yeah he confused the line but uh
now prague will will take on the five
because
i don't see
what else you do i don't know if andre
missed it as such maybe underestimate it
but let's continue bishop of five line
knight five knight of 25
uh there is this knight c7 move that
makes a lot of sense
after king h895 knight c7
yeah queen d6 we win the knight on the
phone oh no then the knight hangs and
then i defended so you have to go queen
d3
yeah now
d5 bishop c5
bishop c4
is what
it's continuous you have to win
when h3 queen
better yeah
bishop one bishop of eight so there i'm
upon up
or not 3d no fade
because they three hangs at the end an
a3 in the end yeah
and if you have one g6 then you want f4
yeah so maybe it's still some sort of
equality by force maybe 97 is just
another way to play uh then g6
we'll see we'll see but from that
perspective queen h3 might be a better
idea because if we have the same line
there's knight g7 maybe in the end
like after all the captures
the little internet
here maybe you have those something on
the king side of the queen a3 maybe
because you know i'm currently a little
bit mispositioned
when h3 is active
maybe something active here but i don't
quite see what it is
maybe slide the king to h1 uh without
your opponent noticing and then you can
take a g7
yeah but if he does notice then probably
he'll bring some pieces into the game
rook of eight on queen of eight
should be should be okay for for uh
black
yeah interesting sort of
semi-theoretical battle where the
players are not really remembering stuff
it could very well be an important
theoretical position
that we are looking at here
it seems quite precarious um i had a
quick question for you
on that topic and of course we can look
at the other games but do you feel like
there's been a shift among the younger
generation in terms of how they approach
uh opening theories there may be less of
an emphasis now
on memorization and more on sort of
conceptual understanding and maybe a
different way of working with engines or
is there more emphasis on memorization
and computer work
among the yes the pango generation let's
say that includes prime yeah i i think
we can't speak of a generation as such i
think each individual player is very
very different
um
you know they all seem like the same and
great and all but they are very
different so if you speak about isapenko
is one thing you speak about prague is
another and they're by the way not
exactly the same generation either
um
i mean it's it's
younger everybody is his own men pretty
much you've got those kids who go for
forced lines
um
prague is
well mostly mostly what you see i think
is that they switch approaches from game
to game i think that's really the modern
thing to do
you you don't just stick to one approach
you one day you play a very first line
the other day you play um
much much less force line and that's i
think the the modern thing to do that's
what most uh top players and talented
youngsters do as well just switching
approach from game to game
yeah and it's interesting they do it as
young as you know as young as prague's
age this kind of universality um but
there are two more games uh karjakin
vidit and uh grandelias duda which one
catches your eye first and ish uh well
karaka indeed i think is just sort of um
doomed
draw doomed to end uh
so rook e3 let's say just to to see how
it got bishop e2 i think right
is usually the way
yeah
you don't even you're not even close so
instead of bishop available
it's so drawn rookie four okay four
maybe it's a draw
it's the easiest maybe yeah
it's a big margin no so they're just
both uh
i mean it's much more interesting to to
try to understand why they're doing it
and
then you will sort of understand well
basically it's usually up to white these
things and sergey you just have to see
his last few rounds he's been having a
really really bad finish
he's been having incredible incredible
bad luck um unfortunate circumstances so
he made this draw with um
with magnus then he decided to somehow
invite all of twitter to to bully him
then after he did that um the next day
he mixed up against shankland the
theoretical variation and lost by force
and twitter continued bullying him and
now he's right against widget and
there's nothing to play for and yeah
that was a crazy game yesterday you
don't see someone like sergey losing
like that like ever
um
no but
but
he does mix up his prep a lot just
usually
usually not it's not that critical and
then he continues with a worse position
but there the line was so forced
that if you mix up
it just lights out
lights out right
yeah it was
yeah this is very interesting and i
think
duda is
kind of asking for the why is the bishop
on b3
how did bishop appear on b3
wow that's so unusual why would the
bishop b6 you were a little surprised by
it
it's not the way yeah you're supposed to
go d5 i think in such such kind of
positions supposed to go d5
uh it is even some kind of theory i
think queenie one queen a5 or something
like that during the bell i don't really
play the stuff oh i mixed up no no
bishop before bishop before yeah here
there's yeah be sure before oh there is
a line you know a um
a3 bishop a5 b4 bishop b6 ed knight d5
and there is a queen's queen sack
somewhere maybe it's oh it's not here
yeah
no sorry on
no no not like that not like that can
you go a few more before probably i have
before i have probably bishop c7 no
is it first
the second most common
d2 is the most common
yeah
that's a very cool uh position where you
are queen down but you have a lot of
compensation
dark personal
yeah bishop f6 or c8 25 games yeah some
sort of sort of already
yeah so d5 is definitely the way to go
but of course he didn't want also white
can avoid the queen second played very
safe duda wanted to fight he wanted to
get winning chances he did this move
queen b6 that i've never seen it's such
a weird move
it's in the way of the b pawn as well
it's locks the pawn
it's desperate because he just wants to
protect the d6 pawn at all costs because
now if you take on d6 i guess he has a
point
what is his point
a long castle in 98. it appears it's
long castle yeah 598. yeah okay great
that's his point
yeah but uh if i don't take on this idea
yeah but now i have to just so the
question is do i start
pushing the pawns somehow
or is that not
is that not exciting
yeah well you can always play king b1
that's always a move you can make
and it can't be bad
yeah perhaps black wants to castle
anyway maybe he wants to castle long
exactly
not in v8 castle line
maybe he wants to cast along
and then d5 potentially yeah although
even if you get d5 it's not
but okay so that can be one what is what
punishment for
probably so bishop c4 is actually the
most popular move with 17 games over 17
games
and now
long castle is not the thing
um after no it is actually
it is but uh rook d is extremely
uncommon so i'm seeing
i'm seeing uh 16 games long castle and
only three games with rook d8
is that the base by the way that
chess.com has is that of which games
classical chess or
yeah i have to look at that i think it's
similar to the chess-based online
database uh it's it's classical but i
also think there's world less than rapid
and stuff
like no it's not the chess.com games
uh no no no it's it's classical it's the
classical database
games that are only played on
right
long castle
is the line bishop b3
and then bishop e7 or d5
and
why is that he takes d5
correct
why
it didn't do that it failed it's not i
felt mike fell
why did i do that why did mike do that
okay ed knight d5
not
yeah probably it's not united
yeah
d5 bishop d5
we see three kind of
is attractive
yeah
queen c5 well i mean the worst case here
yeah duda doesn't want it the worst case
i just even take and take but maybe
there's something
more bishop takes i yeah
maybe it's not so bad for black
hmm
yeah so that's that's the whole whole
thing you want rook d8
rook d8 bishop b3 and bishop b7 maybe
now start i mean now it makes sense to
start the problem with g4 uh i love g4
but if you castle then i go h4 g5 of
course i crash but the problem with g4
is that it does soften the f3 pawn and
in case of d5 and trades it is actually
misplaced in case of an end game for
example it's going to be misplaced so
you have to time g4 very well i feel
it's here it's a bit premature still
would it make sense to start with h4
that would be safe for a little less
weakening for sure what about some
bishop e3 queen f2 or is that's not a
good thing
bishop b3 queen c7
and then if you go knight d7 now that d5
is off the table then we start pushing
the pawns
g4 h4 even f4 is probably not another
question here yeah at the moment bishop
is on b3 45 becomes a thing
wow this is this is going to be a game
of very unappetizing for black yeah yeah
the most exciting game of the day here
definitely you guys by the way also
watching the
games of challengers or your elitist
here
we are
we keep an eye
what was that pick
we're definitely
yeah we can definitely throw it up in in
case of
um
in case of a lack of stimulation in the
master section
yeah let's see if there's anything
interesting just
cool but can you could you help me with
that i'm doing my thing man just talk
how and you're you're a magician you're
you're you're literally in three places
at the same time
news is as stunning as ever um
does the cameraman hear you by the way
or not
no
there it is but what do you mean there's
no cameraman but there was this guy who
was zooming in on shah who was that
ah okay
i'm telling you he's literally in three
places at the same time
so he can you want to be my cameraman
for this
uh no no no no
this is funny we've we've had two quick
draws in this section as well uh uh nuen
against ganguly and chavalava against
biere well let's see a game of irvin uh
lammy probably the
greatest dutch player
right
okay so this is a catalan
yeah measure b7 castle castle c6 b3 a5
cool knight c3 there is this b5 thing
b5 which he played b6 knight d2 b5 very
cool take take queen b6 oh and the point
is d4 pawn is
is no longer protected by the queen yeah
i guess you can play it safe with a4 i
think a4 would be kind of safe then you
keep the structure symmetric
i don't think there's much wrong with
that
but then bishop a6
take on b5 and then black is also
or e4 maybe here yeah
knight c4 knight c4 knight c4 also
oh knight c4
sorry
a4 bishop a6 knight c4 the rook hangs if
you take the knight
oh this looks very very good for so
instead of visual basics maybe knight c6
first is the is the thing here
covering the diagonal yeah developing a
piece no not rushing and then bishop
basics next
let's say e3 bishop a6 yeah and black
has no worries actually white maybe
white maybe runs some danger here
because of the weak b3 pawn i don't know
yeah bishop takes b5 queen takes me five
so irwin deciding against a4 going
knight c3
and
jumabayev contemplating queen takes d4
yeah bishop is the idea of bishop b2
i like white's position because i've
developed everything united b8 and
bishop and c8 is still there and i'm
going to go e4 very fast
honestly this looks
kind of terrible for black or am i
exaggerating
like queen b6 e4
yeah that's and then if d4 maybe knight
c4
yeah you cannot start such a fight with
that without the army um there
knight c3 okay you can make a gambit out
of this whole thing you can really just
suck the you can just play like knight
c6 or something e3 and just bishop a6
rook c8 i don't know but that on night
before night before night before also
was in the mix also rookie at first
but yeah this by the way is quite some
quite some compensation because if i
collect uh
your bishop light square bishop i'll be
happy
yeah this is after something like bishop
f1 knight d3
yeah then i sort of have positional
compensation right in the form of two
bishops and light square control and all
that
uh-huh interesting could you tell maybe
the chat i
is erwin is it fair to say that he's
sort of one of the kind of one of the
patriarchs of of dutch chess what is his
role the godfather you know within was
it just the grandfather the god just
said the godfather yes
so it is fair to say that
it's very fair to say nice nice yes
so
that is this game as jumabaiv
contemplates whether or not to take d4
but probably won't
there's warmer dam
it's not worse it's warmer dam
ramadan max farmer
it's really not warmer
it's it's max colder down
yeah
this year
uh
and how impressed have you been with uh
with harry geisse's players i'm gonna
click into his game
yeah i have to say somehow it passed me
by a little bit i haven't seen that i've
seen all the games but somehow i can't
recall much
i i recall some very easy easy wins for
him
and some and some good defensive effort
uh the against jumabayev was a really
really really good defensive effort
there
so yeah seems like he's definitely
a good versatile player this is all some
kind of prep now again yeah he seems to
be very well prepped
yeah he's playing mark uh andrea
mauricio who is a very very young gm i
actually
i i monitor all these young players but
i hadn't heard of him until this
tournament and
didn't realize he was a gm yeah because
he's from the land of europe which for
you is a different planet that's right
of course in the land of europe there
are some uh countries which is like
which is like states you know in the
united states the same concept countries
and we've got this country called france
where they have this bread you know and
stuff
is that where the leaning tower piece is
oh that's italy that's right no no
that's
another one there's also spain and stuff
by the way but okay it's another story
it's actually a fun thing to talk about
there's like a bunch of them
it's like the german
high school
no i'm joking i'm a big fan of your
streams daniel you are probably the
smartest person uh i've watched
streaming
that that means a lot to me thank you so
much yeah i wish a lot of smart people
like an honor
you know what shikara channel
no i i feel like you know that's part of
the reason i
i just try to play blitz on my stream
just uh you know keep it
keep
don't be shy i was at some point
watching you had the first of all you
have some russian stream sometimes
right about
a couple times a month
yep
you've got
also
that stream where you were talking about
some history stuff
right
so yeah
no big yeah i'm big big fan
thank you that's uh that means a lot to
me yeah in terms of history i have uh
some of these old chess books that i
like to go through
and show on stream i feel like that's
one of those underrated content
uh sources that
everybody finds really really cool
but nobody really talks about now chess
history in particular
and uh looking at looking at old stuff
old games old stories
i feel like that's kind of a forgotten
source of chess entertainment
it's good content do you think yeah
i think it's good content you know what
else is good
speedrun and the what is gamma speedrun
and uh
one cloud you drone is great content
yeah good content
you know what else is very good daniel
is the
doing parody of people like gary
kasparov that's also really really good
stuff well you know maybe not as good as
pedro and that's you know decent you
know
i mean you know he is him
and when i watch his chest you know i
get sick to my stomach and so it's you
know i better watch norwich before you
know other stuff you know not just chess
oh i'm you know i'm a part of it
and now i'm part of the
kasparov parody video and i'm even on
the camera in the same frame i'm like
thrilled i'm part of history now
i can just be immortalized i can also do
a gary caspar impression but i i
have a pending invitation to granchester
so i like to keep it that way for now
not even well you can't bring that up
and you know
no no no but are you usually i have too
much to lose you know
i don't have all that that's fair that's
fair how much to us and also i can't do
it as well as you though so i'm a big
fan big fan okay excellent but this
position by the way um
i feel that you know what what's
happening also in the big in the
challenges tournament with arjuna
guessing he's here with the good second
uh srinath
um
but you know it reminds me of my
childhood like
these guys they're just going straight
for what you prepare like they're just
so naive
like you expect what they're gonna do
you check it better than them they fall
for it they can't even equalize with
white sometimes it's like
so easy
when you say you mean players in the
challenger section yeah i mean they're
just
too naive uh many of them and and they
just head straight into his prep
straight into what he looked at the day
before and it's just
it's just not the way to go at the
highest level and i think that in next
year
for
arjuna it's going to be harder because
top players are not
at least not always
as forthcoming and uh you cannot predict
what they're going to do and just
because i see so many games of his you
know i walk by and he just bleeds
everything out and it's clear he just
looked at this line and somehow
this very line yeah somehow people are
they keep going for what they are doing
and they just don't know it very well
and
um yeah again now we see some some
forced line where white is out of book
way too early
and uh already it's double edged
there's a cute move bishop e5 but it
probably doesn't do anything dude
maybe bishop d4 bishop b5 is something
he blundered by the way it's a very
pretty move wow i i also would
and if knight d5 i think there's knight
takes c4 potentially no no the knight c3
knight t7 but
wait why knight c3 bishop c3 and 97 it's
not the end of the line right
yeah it takes h4
very nice for white though
it seemed the evil bar was indicating
that we were missing something here yeah
but it's not that's not knight c3 i
think we're missing knight c6 maybe
this night c6 yeah knight c6 it is just
getting the night out and white has to
sack the exchange in an unfavorable
version
ah so bishop v5 it was your improv yeah
it was not like just
yeah yeah no it was yeah completely
impressed but after knight d5 white
doesn't have to
oh yeah no way it does have to probably
take on you because otherwise the knight
gets into e3 uh so bishop p5 doesn't
work yeah pretend though pretty
uh yeah it appears that way
what are the normal moves i can grab on
e4 i can play h4 i can play e3 yeah
knight c4 as well as an option
yeah knight c4 knight d6 potentially
looks interesting
very weird
hard to wrap one's head around the same
game neither side is developed yeah like
you should take care i mean let's let's
let's just uh stop this nonsense and
think of our f1 bishop for a second
there
the bishop
that would entail e3 yeah let's uh let's
do that
but
what if i go knight d5 yeah and i'll
suck us like that rook be
three or something
oh
yeah
okay yeah i don't know it's not not a
problem for black for sure you are in
the very least fine yeah
yeah f6 g2 is coming
yeah this bishop is a big problem for
white
it's buried right now it surprises me
that the evil bar is
positive for white i don't really see
why white is better
at all the the engine move is h4
yeah i thought about that what if i go
g4 how does it help me
um it's saying
f takes e4 and then it appears bishop
yeah knight c6 oh you've got the bishop
of four e3 thing going oh very nice very
nice right and you get the bishop out
yeah but it's a very long term thinking
you know it's not so obvious i'm not
sure that uh
mauricio uh is
he's ready for her for it right now it's
very deep and he hasn't been in the
greatest form this tournament
to put it mildly
yeah i mean he's one of the lower rated
participants i guess it's just hard you
have so many strong players
not easy
what was your first appearance when did
you first play inside of steel and did
you go straight to the uh top section
no i already started from the bottom now
i'm here kind of guy
i uh wow played first um
a qualifier
to the c group
which was oh i played in that too the
cultural village tournament no no no no
no not that one you printed that
different one no i've been involved yeah
i played that twice online qualifier
i've played on icc
you know icc
i do
i was addicted to it at one point
it was uh your your time as well yes
assist you're still you're this old
1005. oh yeah no i played there for
three four years actually
2005. you're not like three years old
i was i was nine okay i'm
unfortunately quite old
2005 yeah wow no does five is also
when i played no i play i played even a
bit before yeah nice to see uh anyway a
nice you see uh there was what was there
oh yeah that was this qualifier uh and
actually it was really interesting i
played against lopez also italy zaga
played there i think it ruizaka won that
qualifier he was a beast in icc
yeah
for sure for sure and uh yeah this it
was like an it was not an open culture
it was a invited qualifier it was
actually very
special kind of thing to do an online
event and there were arbiters uh in in
the
in the room you know
i remember i was a kid and um i
i was in a must win in the second game
with black against salgado lopez like we
had a long match at some point i was in
a must-win
in a game and we played g4 d5 before i
play c4 c6 the slav and saga lopez he
takes on d5 and arbiter is there but i
started crying yeah
as the guy played exchange stuff and i
realized i'm in a must win just tears
started dropping my uh
my cheeks and you played knight f6
right
and then you played queen
i just went
and i actually got chances in that game
but i didn't manage to win
i got invited nonetheless to the c group
because somebody again mike fell
somebody refused
so i got the spot in the c group anyway
and then i um
became a grandmaster there then i played
the big group next year
and i won the big group and then i
played a group ever since i've had like
all the stages of
of grief and development in my country
that must be a good feeling though just
uh
you know
like the stepping stones
yeah although i mean i didn't qualify
like i didn't actually qualify so uh the
online qualifier i didn't qualify and
also the c group i didn't actually win
it i became grand master but i finished
probably like third or something
so i got kind of a spot into the big
group next year because i just gained a
lot of rating not really
and by directly qualifying also as a
dutch man of course you get some
discounts uh as you can see now there
are more dutch participants
what was the transition like from b to a
group was it
i assume you already had super
tournament experience by then or was
your uh was your
first a group experience one of your
first super tournaments
it's a good question i i did have played
some top players i've played evan
evanchuk
in this um there was a small closer with
hulk having uh also
a little bit of an elite tournament you
could say i also played some good
players in some team competitions but of
course a group would be a different
challenge i was very fortunate though
that i'm at the very start in the second
round i beat magnus with black magnus
was already world number one at the time
he was not a world champion i think but
he was world number one so in like with
such a start you get a bit of a
you know a bit of a head start in terms
of confidence so i survived that a group
pretty well uh immediately i think i
finished on 50 or something
yeah not not bad for
first uh
style us to group a performance we can
go back to the masters by the way see
there have been any develop developments
yeah
well vetted is
taking his sweet time after rook c3 oh
stronger than rook a3
yeah but now i take and take on c7 oh
you can just take on e2 that's right
that's not fun
you know it's the worst i've had that
also this experience that's why today
before the game i've brushed up on all
this nonsense um
because you don't want when your
opponent just wants to make a draw
and then you also want to make a draw
but then your position is your black hat
so especially slightly worse then you
start drifting and you know before you
know it if the guy gets a risk
reposition and he has winning chances
i'm gonna try because why not
yeah i mean this kind of happened in
carlson's game against vidit um it felt
at one point like it was heading for a
sure draw and then all of a sudden max
was winning like two seconds later of
course then it didn't draw overall but
it seems that magnus is one of the
specialists in that regard
yeah and um
because magnus more than others has that
thought like
you know maybe maybe um
and it's very hard for defend defender
because there are basically two things
you want to juggle between like on one
hand
you
don't want to be thinking too long you
want to show confidence right you want
to play fast
on the other hand you don't want to play
too fast and make it an accurate move
because that that will cost you um your
position so you are trying to juggle
between these two and here we see that
vidi is kind of failing a little bit in
that because he's thinking a bit too
long giving sergey that hope that he
doesn't deserve
but
yeah he doesn't he just didn't
do
he just doesn't find the solution and
it's not easy i also don't see a direct
solution just maybe he has to go bite
the bullet goes c5 and that's why then
you've got you've got bishop d5 c4 rook
a5 before you know it you're kind of
lost
right
you already made it
correct that's crazy
it's so it's looks so innocuous like
rookie five activating the rook i think
yeah you just missed rook c3 but you
know what i don't i think bishop a6
already was not it i think bishop of
five was the move
and it was actually very easy bishop of
five
i've actually looked at this rook b2
bishop c2 rook c7 bishop e4 i think it's
a game of matlakov rook a7 bishop f3 gf
and this is a very easy position to hold
because you've got the double pawns
it's a game of thrones
okay one
essentially yeah
anything yeah because like the positions
with three against threes you know with
the a pawn they are holdable but
especially with this ruined pawn
structure is just very comfortable for
black
so it's very easy draw
bishop a6 already is inaccurate
or maybe the next move was a culprit so
bishop a6 he went what rook b3
yeah maybe three bishop now bishop e2
maybe or something again or
ah the immediate bishop and but what if
bishop two rook b seven
can you
brian rook and games i'm never scared uh
even if just takes and some c5 i'm just
not afraid of looking games
rookie five six rookie five five sorry
it's immediate
oh yeah where whichever pawn you take
you go to the other file a7 c5 c7 a5
yeah so in charge position i think the
safest thing to do is to try to trade
the bishops because then even pawn down
you'll hold but bishop v2 of course he
was afraid of some other move like
bishop d5 or something
right and then maybe bishop d1
rook b7
yeah it can get a little uncomfortable
bishop b2 is also not a pretty move so
let's go move back
maybe he maybe he already
yeah the evil bar is showing zeros but
that's
meaningless
so carlson yeah bishop was so carlson uh
that's here right
yep i'm seeing one game it's probably
the one and bishop takes e2
happened
but it seems like bishop d5 is more
testing yeah the thing is that so didn't
want to put any pressure
in that game maybe bishop g4 bishop is
yeah but but uh videt is worried of
course that sergey does no it's bishop
five is more accurate than bishop basics
for sure this is not pleasant
yeah no this is this has gotten very
uncomfortable and ish we're gonna go
uh on on a short break it's uh
we're here with anish giri in the studio
having a great time and watching the
games we hope you're enjoying we're
gonna go on a very quick break and be
back with more action from the last
round of the tata steel don't go
anywhere
i used to read a lot of books i even
wrote once to play in the c group when i
was like very very young so i guess i
was around 13 14 something like this
yeah i think around that time i must
have heard about it
but i finally got the opportunity in
2018 i was already 2700 back then and i
played the big group as the top seed
which i managed to win and then play in
the a group
i came here first as a second of anish
not as a player
and then of course winning the b group
was very very special
that is something
which was kind of a breakthrough
to get elite level tournaments
invitation
if i don't use technology i'll be just
lagging behind against all my colleagues
because you have to use it kind of the
thing is i my thinking is a bit old
school
because it's very slow to do it old
style with the chess board it's possible
but i think you need a team which will
help you
at least somebody has to check with the
engine that's what i feel
in my heart
i like to you know move the pieces and
do it on the board
[Music]
back to the final round of tara steel we
are joined in the studio by anish giri
and anish were just chilling discussing
the games and we were just talking
during the break about the danger the
vivid has found himself in and the fact
that there's nothing worse than losing
the last two rounds of a tournament that
is
that is just a terrible terrible feeling
yeah especially this way when you know
that your opponent doesn't even want to
beat you
um that's that's just really unpleasant
what was also unpleasant is uh
position of
sam shankland
that is as some present as ever still
i don't like 94. i would go can you go
i would like to go passive and try to
just
suffer
between the 66.
but i'm afraid he was afraid of some
c493 business just losing a pawn maybe
he thought
i don't know if it works but yeah maybe
queen before
yeah but he was afraid of this kind of
stuff then cd like the nature position
changes and you've got some
um
dynamic issues maybe knight d2 i don't
know
right no this looks very unpleasant at
the moment the three was actually good
but he was putting some pressure there
uh and then he decided to do knight e4
but 94 is a very shaky move
yeah this whole construction could
topple over
bishop f5 knight c2
it looks obviously looks active but this
is pseudo pseudo activity
yeah exactly and uh there are also some
concrete
issues with this whole construction yeah
there's some kind of potential for some
c4 at some point after some queen d4 um
or knight e3 like the d5 pawn is very
shaky what i would want wanted to do is
bring you have the knight on f6 have
bishop on e6
be super passive
and just defend that d5 pawn you know
because i am worried that i'm just might
lose it at some point that's my main
worry i don't want to lose do i want to
trade queens here
i think it depends on the circumstance
again like if i if i get to defend my
pawn i think black is okay with trading
queens like the dream for black would be
to trade all heavy pieces and bring the
king to d6 and just sit it out
but if you trade queens in a version
where you're losing the d5 pawn then i'm
happy yeah
rook fe-8 just played by sam
yeah normal move and now question is
how to proceed
yeah
so
knight d4 obviously is the
straightforward candidate move queen d4
or you could delay it and try to improve
your position yes the queen d4 maybe
isn't as good as it looks 24 i'll take
and
i was about to say bishop d7 but then c4
yeah maybe
ah should 57 c4 yeah that looks that
looks good so maybe bishop g6 out of but
bishop is uh like i don't want it on
that side it's really out of like it's
not going to defend my d5 pawn anymore
this is very worrying for black rook 81
yeah and i feel like
yeah knight b5 ideas
what did i take on d4 by the way i
didn't have to take myself i could have
let you take
right but how like a neutral move like
h6 i've got okay d1 i have also useful
moves
i mean after h6 i would play rocket d1
yeah with white
oh oh yeah white
right getting the rook in and 24
actually is strong perhaps yeah it's
actually strong
not easy to respond to
no i think sam is not going to hold this
one um
i just think it's it's not going to be
it for sam
yeah sam
sam is very up and down i mean he can
beat karjakin like that and then
i have to say and there he goes
uh i have to say that while obviously
everybody knows how great the player sam
is
and everybody knows all his good games i
have to say some moves he made in this
tournament
they were
so bad
like what comes to mind the okay today
of course ctek's d4 and bishop d6 but
the game with the rapport where he went
e6
i don't know if you recollect that one
um
it would be good to pull it up because
it sort of fits in the context uh i
think it was before some rest day i
think game four maybe
game four let me
bank one report there it is yeah can you
just
look at move 17
there it is yeah yeah i remember this
one e6 just gave away all the advantage
yeah just whereas he just could have
sort of improved his position it's not
just gives away advantage you're also
signing uh signing up for a worse
position for free from a better position
this is insane
right trading queens and now richard
goes roxy five hunting for the all the
queenside fawns which are now weak
yeah because i'm getting cyber bullied
by his coach but frankly i don't know
what the guy is doing i mean
this is ridiculous
whereas instead just a slow improving
move like queen before
we're speaking about this with widgets
in such position black's dream is to
spend 10 moves prepare f6
and hope to get that pawn structure
you cannot do that here because after f6
i will go e6
so he you can go like rook c6 rookie 6
rook f8 triple double and then go f6
hope that i will trade which i never
will uh meanwhile i will hit your d 1
i'll go f4 you will never be in time
sometimes they give up the d5 pawn to go
f6
right
and in fact that's what happened in the
game jordan against uh friedman the guy
simply gave up the d5 pawn went for f6
got this rook end game the same as sam
got without the d5 pawn
and was about to hold it
so this e6 is uh it's a very strange
decision uh and today the same thing
again like he just
goes for a
very very bad position straight from the
opening
yeah and jordan has gone 24 sam quickly
taking it
and it does seem yeah like he's getting
impatient no but i know i know how black
is going to defend it i know what sam is
going to do uh bishop d7 is going to
play f94 and and c4 he's going to give
it go king king of eight that's what sam
do oh
yes yes yes yes and he'll and he'll try
to hold that and actually he has good
that's right he did do the same thing
with you yeah he likes this kind of
defensive strategy yeah probably that's
what it's coach told him you have to
give up a pawn and try to set up a
blockade
yeah
i think
rook 81 is there something to be said
for that
but then you might uh have even less if
i go knight f6 i i do think a pawn is a
pawn uh
so you should probably grab it i mean
it's not like after cd96 white is like
what is still a huge reading has unique
reading chances
right i was just thinking maybe even
rookie 8 and the knight c2 knight e3 but
yeah you can adopt the defensive posture
you indicated previously with like
bishop e6
yeah d8 beautiful
english adopt a defensive posture
i would never come up with that
well
that's you know
rather than training chess i was
spending my time in english classes at
stanford
it's a trade-off
yeah no it's you know it's a thing they
do there
in stanford
oh for sure
my only problem is with the substance of
what i say
i know i know how to craft it but
a bit of a substance issue sometimes
actually sam has done a great thing
there i i'm i think the draw is a
favorite now after this it's a very good
very good defensive idea
it really is allowing c4 and cd it's
just not intuitive at all yeah yeah and
then you said king
like a neutral little move liking f8 but
i thought yes sam is just fantastic
player so many um
so many great decisions in this event
and a lot of and a couple really really
bad decisions but yeah
but okay jokes aside of course you're
suffering here are you still suffering
and
there is no way to
uh to end it quickly
it reminds me of a game i saw in
candidates between wang hao and
maxima shilagraph
it's extremely similar
and here he goes bishop d7
i wonder if jordan sees it for him
he seems a little surprised he seems
quite surprised oh no it but it dawns on
him now
uh-huh he's completely annoyed no but
he's there
hear like h3 and then get the king
around
and the question does black want to
trade
both pairs of rooks probably he does
yeah or maybe maybe just one rook c8 and
counter play on the queen side a5 a4 x4
yeah it's a bit of a bummer for jordan
there i i think he was hoping for more
than this
yeah and bishop doesn't help obviously
let's zoom in nicely on his right ear
correct
wow it's not very red yet but it's
turning redder by by the second
as he's realizing wait a minute now
something
wait a second something oh no no it's
black tomorrow i thought that uh doodle
blunder didn't exchange
but it's it's uh black to move in this
position okay
uh
yeah so you you called it he played
queen f2
queen b8 and bishop b6 not 97 97 is like
the the go-to move
uh duda is being very creative
trying to avoid the natural uh course of
action and just trying to confuse nils
bishop b6 is nice rook c8 i guess
i think it's okay to go g4 now i don't
think i don't think it's
necessary to wait any longer
and i mean still knight c7 kind of asks
to be played in this position but i
guess then bishop d4
yeah i did allow that option of e5 but
i'm not worried with the bishop on b3
opening up
no yeah and if you cast like oh h4 g5
and i think white is just much faster
now
yeah but pawn on h6 the hook
is also not great
it allows the
opening of the files
yeah and g5 h5 there's always g6
maybe b5 though
b5 here g5
yeah it's crushing yeah
why is the bar happy by the way what was
the bar knight c5 it wanted or what
maybe not what was it unhappy about here
it was unhappy about it
yeah you're right knight c5 g5 h5 now oh
there's no g6 anymore
all right because the bishop can be
eliminated at a moment's notice
you see so it's only one still it's
still nuanced so very unclear what will
happen in that game dude i sort of did
some dubious stuff but it's not like
he's in
it's not like he is going to lose
automatically yet
maybe g5 straight away could be
considered
wow composition like this
too much talent
rebecca harris so
rebecca harris nice rebecca harry's
style is also to remove gh now yeah
right
well or or to play significantly more
dirty it's like or to prove to to play
bishop a7 misdirection
yeah i'll see every little way to attack
the queen if you remember my record
against rebecca harris was zero seven
you're right and then you asked who it
was
yes
and then once you found out it's nerd is
key i think you won the next like four
games yes yes yes exactly it was funny i
was the way you played it was so good i
remember you beat me a couple of games
so well then at some point i had a
position which was slightly better but
okay let's make one drawer not to get
adopted by whoever it is and then you
start playing for a win in a slightly
worse position i was completely shocked
you beat me there as well
and then i thought okay this must be
magnus or alireza there's no other way
someone is this good right
but then yeah i heard it was you and
okay that's okay if it's not magnus or
alien maybe i can fight yeah but you
know very very well very well played
there for sure
thanks but yeah that threw me off
because then i knew the mystique was
gone you know now that you know it's not
magnus
uh your the psychology of the match kind
of shifted
yeah no but one day we should play some
hundred games and then see how badly i
lose oh
i'm always down for that
so
rook cage iv
has happened or wait has it yes it has
it has
this seems to be right up niels alley by
the way too
for sure for sure
good thing about uh us sort of
uh predicting moves is that we predict
bad moves but they are also happening
because the other participants are also
looking at the bad moves
so it's in a way the commentators they
do have rights to exist
so this is
going on with g4 we'll keep an eye on it
we were seeing
uh man for shanklin and of course
there's also
what happened
we forgot about spencer oh yeah
let's check in onto that game
i was saying it's not not easy but he
actually got the bishop to h4 how is
that happening he managed how did that
happen so knight g397 here we stopped
we'd have three
knight c7 gets the route
97 97 is really not like a natural move
or something it's
knight might very well go to f6 as well
so maybe
ah queen of 758 is a problem okay
slight
white issue so he prepares queen d7 he
plays it no but i don't like you one c7
i'm sorry
it's a terrible night yes it has no
no prospects no no it's it's a huge i
think it's a huge mistake there this 97
wolf
so you think after queen f3 he should
have
let's think
perhaps
will queen c8
i mean you want to prepare but this
should be some one would think but
maybe not is rook b8 a possibility
rook b8
could we
revert back to
oh
yeah yeah that thing again okay i forgot
about that
but maybe it's not not that impressive
here anymore like first of all knight f5
or bish but probably knight f5 yeah i
guess through the knight
take six queen d5
shade bishop f5
yeah we're gonna have this maybe this is
the lesser evil
they're quite evil though
could we could we avoid um could we not
blunder 95 and not go knight c7 is that
possible
king h8 maybe or something
first let's not blunder uh the pawn
ph8
so let's say
well rook ab1 is kind of the default it
would seem oh also was g6 an option by
the way uh right away or it's not a good
move
on move 16 right here yeah
yeah no it's definitely always
yeah because now i think you're right
knight c7 yeah no it's a very wrong
direction and i should go to f6 i guess
right and i guess rookie one for
instance yeah now knight f6 i think i i
can play
and then i go coming to seven and then
i'm now also the moment the g3 knight
leaves i will go bishop b7 and 94.
uh-huh the knight of c7 is just very far
it has to go back to e8 at some point
because on e6 it's still bad
right no an e6 it can also be targeted
by a queen on e2 and a skewer
potentially yeah and it just has no uh
no next it has no future on e6
and that's why he's in trouble now
sprague rerouted the knight on e3 and
look there's nobody on e4 there's no
knight on e for the black s
could brock consider something drastic
like g4 already or is it for sure
prematurely even calculated for sure uh
the question is what if fg
right knight g4 and c4 and chips
bishop c4 i've got some tricks with text
and rookie eight acquaintance
ooh even there like rook b7 at the end
of that line
okay but and then there's roof takes
proof true but what if not g4 that's
another question what if i prepare it
first with some h bishop h4 or h3 usual
h4 maybe
right complete the rerouting
what is your next move
d5 is that an attempt
d5
the evolve bar for some reason hates it
but i think the evil barbarian hates
everything i propose right i think he
just hates the position to be honest i
don't think it's you
yeah i mean not the positions i don't
see by the way
it would shoot so high uh do you see
what's the problem divine it looks like
a good counter play move well there is
knight takes d5 but tanks takes bishop
d3 and queen takes d5 i didn't think
that was that terrible that's all right
that's all right
um
i mean
there is not any tactic anywhere i don't
think so
yeah no knight takes f5 stuff quincy
and the black looks to be reasonably
protected everywhere i don't know
but let me uh look at how the silicon
fiend rook bd1 ah just like that
and if d4 oh but i thought yeah i didn't
think it was clear d4 cd
cdcd and now bishop c2 that's so clear
cold blooded
that is not obvious i think
wow queen d6 c5
i mean c5 bishop b3 even that is not the
king oh my god king
king g7 knight c2 with the idea of d3
championship f2
oh the bishop reroutes the position
opens up and your king is in trouble
okay but this is a very very difficult
line um
i think right i mean possible of course
possible but this the sequence or the
one bishop c2 is not obvious to me
um
okay let's say he will not go bishop h4
because of that what are his other moves
what if he is h3
h3 still allows d5 and that's still oh
and then d1 is easier yeah maybe h3
actually is possible
now rd1 is more obvious because bishop
f2 is actually right there
supporting the knight and it wants to be
there anyway yeah d4 is no longer a
problem he taken their knight c2 is
pretty obvious yeah yeah or even this
bishop c2 move is stronger there because
right bishop on f2 is better
yeah actually
simply d5 is not an issue
not an issue so is queen a4 an issue
it's very very risky of course ooh
i mean i would be
contemplating knight takes off f5
but
it takes takes it's not so easy so all
my pieces have left but the main problem
with my i mean i liked my other pieces
it's the knight on c7 if it was on f6 it
would be all
doable
uh-huh
i'm trying to make a crazy tactical idea
work but
no
i mean let's say g4
oh
bars hates me in general
at c4 let's say
yeah well now i was thinking at first
knight c5 but then there's knight d2 oh
yeah yeah that's andre for you he likes
this 92 kind of moves
uh-huh
okay what if i just try to break like
what is
i don't i don't feel like calculating
i'm already knighted
already no i think you already that's a
threat
no g4 was premature
also g4 is not exactly a killer right
it's sort of
it's too slow yeah it feels like there
should be something more to say
it's not
easy hmm you could start with bishop c
oh there's not even numbers it was given
a3 here
apparently bishop h4 is the move here
knight 64.
why because of h4
well
[Music]
as usual yeah bishop c2
queen d7
forced of course
it's never going to happen just the
whole line it's also just too strange
should be three
d5 bishops before completing the round
of course uh up here but it's just the
whole sequence is again
no they're not going to go h3 because of
that
h3 is also not not the move
so you think he's going to be worried
about queen a4 and yeah i mean i think
he he has to realize that d5 is not a
threat because of rook bd1
that's one thing he has to realize
then he has to realize that queen a4 is
actually kind of the threat
but tell me bishop h4 with a4
what is uh what is the blow oh is there
here below
um
here there might be knight takes f5 yes
knight takes f5
how exactly though
queen g3 check h8
and now apparently there is rook e7 and
then the bishop takes d6 and maneuvers
to e5 oh
that is also difficult everything is
difficult really nice idea rookie seven
that's beautiful it's hard it's the it's
really hard i mean i don't think he'll
see it just it's just really hard i
don't know it's very hard
but he could maybe sense intuitively
that yeah this position just looks so
promising exactly because there's it's
almost made i mean these positions yes
you know just feel juicy
yeah i mean you you know bishop h4 is in
the right direction so you start queen
a4 and now you have to look for a blow
because you know that you have all the
pieces there already you have to have a
blow because if you don't have it now
he might see bishop e7 here which i
don't know it's good enough you know
also looks interesting yeah
yeah why why is bishop v7 not great
actually maybe because of queen d7
ah i yeah exactly there is nothing
strong enough threats here on queen g5
though
yeah here queen g5 no it's not queen d7
did you find knight e6 also continues
wow bishop f6 check in the starting
position we have now bishop h4 is
probably the strongest move right
according to the
engine it was it was eight it was saying
h3 no yeah now it's saying bishop h4 yep
yeah h4 is the strongest move
not easy not an easy move to
figure out i mean it's the first one
that comes to mind it's just that you
have to refute d5 and you have to repeat
kunai but also
you cannot stop anyway so you might as
well just
you know you have to anyway let's say
start the attack and then see what
happens
bishop h4 is a big favorite i think to
happen
i mean you could you could try to
prevent queen a4 with bishop c2 but now
of course you dropped c4
the moment you start preventing
counterplay you only allow more of it
right right in a different direction i
was thinking this like taking a page out
of that idea but true that's that's
actually nice for white still then just
taken
one
bishop black and also black gets uh time
to breathe a little bit yeah
yeah this doesn't exactly
you know breathe fear into
the black's heart
and black can maybe double on the e file
for example make some surface level
improvements rook
f7 the computer was proposing
interesting but very promising position
for prague and uh definitely that 97
move changed the course of the game i
mean before that i i really liked
black's position
now no longer no longer so white got his
dream i mean i told you that i would
love the bishop to be on h4 back back
then but back then i thought it was not
possible and now he just he just made it
happen so everything is very good
today's world anything is possible let's
check quickly into the
sergey no it looks like vinid actually
is
on his way to
recovering here
i like what happened there i like what
happened uh i think sergey played bishop
b3 i don't like what is bishop b3 i'm
not sure about so rookie seven okay
through rookie six wait a second so yeah
before she sticks though
is that the end of the line c4 c6 c4
i mean no that muscle it has to be
holding vibrate p1
but was there still was there a need to
travel okay
drastically come up with b5 uh-huh
no rb5 this is a mistake yeah let's draw
on the spot
takes takes
and we've already been through some of
these positions rook c5 yeah that moment
where he would be should be three we
have to
pause there for a second
maybe a waiting move maybe a move like
f3 is there but then c6 you get the same
thing but okay but you can get at the
tempo up yeah bishop b3 c5 now you have
an extra tempo
it's nice to have an extra tempo i don't
know why he didn't get a tempo first why
he just played bishop e3 first it makes
no sense to me
well extra tempo yeah you have f3
included in that position which is a
helpful healthy move of course he wanted
to go he wanted to stop bishop d7 i
think i think he was afraid of bishop
seven
after f3 let's say i was a threat in
this position
i think he thought that was a threat
yeah
all right
is that crazy
yeah no
i mean this this is very solid though i
mean this is very little i guess
great
now this this of course i mean slightly
worse but it's very very solid
so that's why
it seems to have been doing a good job
and c5
so c5 is great five is great now so
bishop d5 back yeah
and then c and then c4 yeah you wanna
you must stop or bishop b7 simply again
we should be seven again oh yeah that
idea
yeah white house and then bishop c4
again a6
and it's the thing is there were before
maybe
right
rook before
okay it's down to c4 yeah no dislodge
the bishop from
was very careful here i mean i think he
sensed the danger and you hunkered down
yeah no it's good because you can also
just uh go nuts but he i mean he still
has
good defensive skills and he still
calculates so yeah it's good that he
recovered from that little
little blow earlier where he realized
that he's slightly worse already
i'm sure sir sergey probably is feeling
disappointed because i it seemed like he
was feeling the excitement of
you know sensing that he had the
potential it's like when they tease you
a little bit yeah like the
with the bacon in front of you and
you're like
yeah especially when
yeah somewhere around this moment when
you played right c3
but rookie 7 was very important not not
to go c5 and allow this paralysis or k3
what you what you don't want to allow is
bishop d5 c4 thing that's why you need
your c pawn still on c7 to be able to go
c6 at some point and kick the bishop
away
right right now rook a5 comes and it's
really really bad
so this one is going to end in a draw 99
certainty 95
95. yeah
and uh in the meantime yeah shane flynn
is going down that line with king fade
and grendelius has indeed gotten g4 and
h4 shangri going down that line but he's
not going down yeah
right
no it's like h4 h4 is uh
is all right
by jordan
but now
black also will make a waiting move
so i can't play c8 force the matters i
can also start with move like h6
h4 is kind of a signal to me that white
is not jordan's not exactly seeing a
convincing path forward
well i mean he just yeah um
yes and basically you know you can play
h4 h6 first and then take it it just
doesn't matter much h4 is useful move
did sample h6
king h2 and stuff
yeah he's gone okay by the way yeah
that's that's also normal uh after cd
knight d6 rook takes e8 i can take with
the bishop yeah again i had that thought
that maybe i want to keep rooks and
start bothering you on the c file a
little bit
yeah it seems like white's only real
plan
is is maybe king h
i don't know i was thinking to bring the
king maybe more towards the center like
towards like d3 e3 area and play put
pawn on let's say b3 to prevent knight
c4
and you know i don't want to rush it
i don't have to rush it i'm pulling up
so i will slowly
slowly try to go maybe g4 g5 at some
point um
yeah white is enjoying life and on one
hand you don't have any breakthrough
anytime soon with white but at the same
time with black also i don't see how you
ever can force a draw so you kind of are
doomed to a long game
i'm suffering
right maybe black does black want to put
the king on f6 or is that
asking for trouble related to g4 ideas
i don't really know uh it's a good
question yeah q1f6 is of course more
active
maybe it's okay yeah
i'm not envious of sam's situation a lot
of decision micro decisions to make here
yeah but to be honest um it could be
worse i mean it's not the worst position
to defend because you don't have the
ugly bishop uh you're have you have
pretty pieces
and yeah this knight looks amazing
jordan always tells me that if you
blunder something you get always
something in return
and uh in this case you have sam
definitely got something in return for
the d5 pawn like he's got a better
bishop now
got a nice blockader on d6
so
i don't think it's the ugliest end game
it is slightly worse still but it's not
not very ugly so that's nice
especially given where he came from the
position that he had previously was a
lot more depressing i think yeah i would
estimate this at like 80 20 in terms of
like win win draw win ratio uh
favorite here
given where this game came from also
yep
why is jordan thinking he he can play a
move like he by the way can just ignore
he can play b3 or something
you can keep ignoring it forever
actually that's actually annoying right
then
you have a standoff because black can
never move the night really
yes um
ooh
but how is waking up
tweak
uh-huh
i don't know i'm just trying to now
but it's very dubious yeah
it feels like c1 okc one maybe
probably going to lose that pawn after
all in the worst circuit okay bishop six
is too risky let's try to maintain
status quo but it's hard yeah it's
actually h6
yeah now real quick the one there is
knight c3 probably
and what if i try something like rookie
i mean it's actually very i really just
don't want to play it f5 it's
incorrect the f5 you're going to take on
g5 and
f5 you just you just created the
weakness yeah
actually i didn't realize that white has
b3 yeah so now uh
i like his prospects again
wow
i mean i can lose a lot of time and
force you like i can play knight f6
but
then after rookie eight
uh
rookie hcd the knight is misplaced on f6
and it will have to be rerouted again to
d6 i'm not sure i mean time now 94 back
94 back i may be in time still to come
back knight d6
i'm not sure
bishop c8
is there there's 96 checks oh exactly
exactly yeah that's the kind of thing i
was concerned about
still i will try to hang on bishop takes
e6 bishop b4 bishop d7 and then bring
the king to d6
but you get d6 at some point i think he
should be seven
again i keep clearing clearing stuff off
of that diagonal
yeah no jordan has to uh i really think
he should uh go b3 practically speaking
and keep that
maybe i'll go a5 a4 or something
yeah let's just go ahead and response to
b3
that's not panic so let's say i go
rookie 3 again a4 at least i trade upon
that's nice a b a b
yes and now
now what
it's still on plus what does y want why
once bishop before so yes
this version in no rush i mean i can
start with g3 let's say if i want to but
yeah i want to pick up the pawn like
that and then it's definitely a pawn
can black
consider stupid i was thinking b5 but
that sounds looks like about as well but
i will take on b5
with
um
well both are nice but maybe pawn is
even more ambitious yeah i was going to
go rogue b8
you're you're suffering even if i take
on e4 you're suffering but maybe there
is something more like bishop yeah
that's the worst that's the worst part
about it
this is such a cool idea like not taking
i mean not taking on d5 you know holding
yourself holding yourself down
resisting the temptation
because black cannot force c takes d5 i
didn't notice the first let's take the
pawn
yeah did we know resisting adaptations
is one of the things jordan was good at
but looks like
he might be
yeah he senses the importance of the
moment he hasn't taken on d5 yet which
is a good i like rookie five the look of
rookie five rook c8 somehow
rookie five here yeah oh sorry cd uh no
cd again this knight is oh bishop e4 and
knight e6 ooh yeah yeah cd should be 4k
496 yeah this is just bad that's really
cool
so maybe rookie 7 instead
let's try
that cd i've got knight d6
yes 3d 96 the rookie 3 is what you want
and now
yeah so i can play rook c8
you could also go knight no no maybe not
knight f6
i can go knight f6
yeah i can go knight six and then 98 to
make a circle all the way to
actually it's fine yeah right now i can
do that
yeah take take cd 98
wow and i i made six because and i made
it
full circle
yeah this is by the way
yeah the rook is perfectly placed here
too
and the reason your hesitates now is
because
in that situation if we get that anyway
it's a question if you want your
opponent on b3 probably you do to guard
a c4 square but it does weaken some dark
squares so it's a question if you want
to commit to b3
it just feels like
yeah rookie 7
so black actually is has a positional
threat of knight f6
yeah you could say so just looking g4 a
bit too much yeah
yeah i was thinking exactly the same
direction but
possible i mean i guess you can afford
that why not
wow probably age six or something yeah
just not clear you achieve anything
yeah and i weaken more i make more king
side weaknesses
yeah very very uh
tremendous complexity arising out of
this central tension and we're gonna
take another uh quick break
you're watching the final round of tata
steel chess we've got some really
interesting games going on and we have a
niche gary in the studio don't go
anywhere we'll be back in just a few
minutes
uh lee
yeah robert can you read devretsky's end
game manual to us one more time yeah now
we got to get up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it was you like i was i was going to do
it
that's what i said i told you
let's do it all right
you know what they say though what
happens in salt lake
it stays in salt lake
cheers to my super gm friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
[Applause]
let's do this
[Music]
chug that whole beer
yeah that was that was i was
yeah i'm great
round two
bobby
yes robert
can you read
end game manual to us one more time yeah
you guys have to go with it
okay
okay i just actually didn't expect you
to do it that time but you made it
funnier like i thought he was a one-time
yeah yeah please okay okay i'm just
trying to add live with what feels
natural yeah
of course it feels natural wait so we
should expect that next yeah
what is this
it's legs
i want an omelette with brie just
eat it
you eat it
[Laughter]
wasn't expecting that that wasn't either
it was sour
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
um the uh
faster card and unibrow i just want to
thank my sponsors uh very much for all
they do to to promote chess
sounds like a great future credit card
faster card yeah wasn't it fast or hard
[Laughter]
no no it's that card
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not fast or bobby oh boy i i can't be
with you two anymore
okay
i mean i think it's i think it's
hilarious don't you think people would
would buy this
i don't think anyone's gonna buy that
tank that's the stupidest person in my
life
well okay
i guess that's it
all right that's it that was great
who is that guy who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're gonna be right back
bobby that's robert
can you read deboratsky's end game
manual to us one more time yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
because we all see things in the same
way and the same speed on this show
isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
[Laughter]
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so iphone can give us her
thoughts on the uh on the pet shop go
aheady fun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because i was firstly trying to
yeah danny my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit yeah
you're not supposed to say that
you're not supposed to say if you start
the bet if black's a6 pawn was
transported let's say
good night guys
good night dad i've been fabio
[Laughter]
i said i said it should i not set it
i think it's funny if people say good
night dad i mean bobby but we need to be
in sync
[Music]
back to the final round of tada steel
and ishiguri in the studio with us
looking over the remaining games magnus
carlson of course having clinched
victory after yesterday's win
over fabiano caruana but anish a couple
of interesting
games still remaining and we were
checking out jordan's game
uh against shanklin right before the
break and he decided not to keep the
tension took on d5 what do you make of
that decision
you know probably he saw either rookie
seven or something else that bugged him
there anyway so probably objectively
doesn't matter
and probably sam as well so what he was
supposed to do but still it's a small
relief for black now that you you get
that thing you wanted to get sort of on
the board so yeah the position clarified
after knight d6
i most likely would have gotten this
anyway and now you know the grind starts
i don't think we will see much action
for a while but slowly but surely white
will centralize the king and start
putting pressure i mean i i am convinced
that um i've seen this uh exact piece um
distribution and the pawn structure in
the game between um
maxim and the van gaal and candidates
but that was from the grim field so the
pawn was on g6
and the h pawns were gone
which probably makes blackstrap a little
bit easier
yes and no i mean on one hand you're
happy to have the h pawns going on the
other hand you don't want it stuck on g6
because it's the color of your bishop
i'm not sure um i think it's i think i
like sam's version a bit more maybe i
can play h6
phones on the dark squares i don't mind
them at all
and um
yeah it's hard to say like if it's a
draw or such
i think maxim held it but it was not
easy at some point it was on the verge
of losing
and now to
long term i'm not sure uh i'm not sure
the thing is you can never win the d5
pawn so you just have to defend
passively
uh just wait
right
yeah and again white for why the big
choice is where to bring the king you
were suggesting bringing it toward the
center
uh solidifying the knight
that makes a lot of sense
yeah h2 g3r4 is a bit of a shorter route
but uh i think you are heading towards
e3 you know you're not heading towards
e5
so i expect the king to i think it's a
bit more flexible on like e2 uh around
e2 area
mm-hmm
yeah king f1 is
definitely possibly to be expected he's
played rook d1
yeah uh it's just a matter of what you
start with i guess eventually you get
all your um all your moves in any way
black probably has to wait i'm wondering
you know uh with black
first of all
i think i do want to get bishop d7h6 g5
in
uh and i'm wondering is white going to
play h5 after h6
because he creates sort of a pawn
weakness for himself at the same time he
does keep the g pawn on g7 for for a
while
but i don't know what to make of this h5
move if it's something i like or not
he's an ambitious man right
and let's say black
now i've got the
uh roxy one rook c8 yeah you start
chasing me yeah i was
yeah and let's say i say take at some
point and then we get this position
okay then probably bring your king up to
e7 now black probably should position
the king on f6
uh yeah i would like to to have my pawn
on f4 so i don't know if i can still
achieve that or if i messed up the
version
well i kind of automatically played king
e2 but maybe here
yeah
i'm a bit worried about the 98 knight of
16 d6 that you know you will or 94 like
you will somehow somehow bother my e4
point like 94 now uh and that's some
bishop 3 you have 92 you will trade and
you'll quickly attack my pawn i don't
know i was afraid of this
right or even just matter yeah 92
then you take
taking g6 maybe
yes
actually here i'm going to do this in
time mm-hmm not in time
i had a fight
that's a nice move
and then king d7 yeah so uh it also can
get a little concrete right
yeah for sure
i think white should trade only in a
good version there's no no no rush with
trade of rooks
i'm going bishop d7 yeah but you're
right i mean
the the value of every individual move
here is not very high it's it's
you know the action isn't going to start
until uh
both players make all the improvements
until white makes all the improvements
he wants to make
yeah yeah well anyway that's not the
most exciting position we have the
good candidate is the prague game uh he
did go bishop h4 which which felt wow
right queen g7 oh okay
interesting queen and attacking c3
27 minutes also it's
taking a long time
and you've just dropped bc one let's say
is d5 now a possibility
yeah i oh wait but then there's nothing
no just wins upon 95.
how do you get your
founder play
knight a4 looks way too superficial i
don't believe that
twist
e6
right
ooh
i'm not sure if it's a good three
somehow black is queen takes c6 there's
queen d4 maybe
reminds me of how easy pencils knives
were jumping around in this game against
uh
uh against
nils in this tournament
he seems to be of a philosophy of
not really positioning his knights well
but just sort of uh going for
you know for long trips with the horses
that's the kind of guy he is
interesting
yeah by the way uh duda got that 95 move
which was very important
let's take a look yeah so h4 this
actually happened and
we thought this was just not that good
for white yeah he made my bad moves i
tell you that's the thing about being a
commentator you suggest bad moves but
then they happen
right but i mean they listen they're
very respectful rook hue and b5 but
niels he goes h5
okay he's clearly trying to go g5 and
sac sack the house and open the king's
side but
this does not look appetizing move black
is now kind of first i mean what if b4
and a5 or even a5 here is he first
though let's see a5 g5
are you really first okay i don't know
you if you are first
probably not yeah yeah i don't know it
sticks to the question already i mean
you're about to get mated here i mean
come on first of all just show the chat
g6 h7 and
very pretty geometric sequence
with rook h1 rocket h8
no this is iron first for sure q2 and a5
was too slow maybe you should go before
then a bit more
more dynamic more threatening
but before i go it still goes g5 yeah
that's the question what if i still go
g5
very much a question
bishop takes g5
even you have to consider
rook takes right
like a very desperate and crazy niels
grand daddy's in the house there you
never know
yeah in h6 anyway maybe yeah you never
know i mean even this year it doesn't
feel of course like it's something that
should work
but you have to reckon with that and
also if g5 i have a four yeah much
slower but still very effective
maybe there's some
between sacrifice ideas like bc
fg
and 94 gh you're thinking
right
i don't need gh but uh
i'm not sure that's convincing actually
because no but i can just pull the queen
right
you don't have any much counter play you
just want a bunch of phones but nobody
cares about the pawns right
right the king just even cb king takes
b2 king is perfectly safe now this is
terrible
h5 is cool
because if you go g5 first then there
was h5 that was the issue and position
remains closed
i would have still thought about g6 yeah
and seen what happened what happens
it's possible that black takes and can
but don't i have a two queen h5
yeah
yeah yeah
so maybe it's f5 here
i i don't think it's a move with an f1 i
i think it's something along the lines
of e5
oh it's also not good yeah why was this
bad by the way
the the move here is b4
first and then and then of course of
course 92 and the e5 yeah yeah
from d5 square
this should be three and now just have
to take c6 actually yeah so that's why
neil's played h5 first which is very
cool and here uh
black really is under a lot of pressure
because g5 is coming you have to take a
good good decision
what about the same thing before
ah you didn't even uh
yeah we played g5
okay but let's take on b3 let's say
get rid of the bishop right
and now let's grab
bc
maybe we have the knight okay gh
no it's made okay let's not do that
mate
so e e5
or what
also gh
okay apparently here
no just gh you have to grab on g5 yeah
oh my god bishop takes g5 f4 f6
oh that's very nice cementing the yeah
that's very pretty mm-hmm
yeah very easy to take easy to find of
course yeah
it looks i'm very skeptical here yeah
and uh duda has played before
i think niels will not see this f6 thing
it's not so obvious
you think he'll play g5
yeah i mean that's that's vintage nils
he's down to 25 minutes it sounds like
he he's gonna go
you know
yeah he's gonna go g5 throw the kitchen
sink he's not gonna see that f6 thing
it's not obvious i think g5 bishop
bishop g5
uh
has seen it probably yeah yeah dude has
seen it
because there's no other defense right
you have to defend it somehow
right yeah you have to go for well throw
in knight takes b3 first just to
eliminate obviously the bishops of them
take c6
and f6 this is the key move and wait a
minute if white
o5 moves the knight then you have bishop
take c4 with devastating threats against
c2
[Music]
for instance 92 bishop before it's just
game over
min rook d2 and then there's e5
yeah you're already like really not
attacking the g file is so blocked
and you don't even sacrifice a piece you
regain it later so it's just super super
safe and super good i have to say that
it's not a theme that i've seen a lot of
i've never seen this kind of theme
before but i've also never really seen
h5 g5 happening so it's just a very
unique position
uh here that's such a paradoxical idea
to like it sounds extremely
counterproductive and yet that's what
you have to do
yeah the whole sequence is very unusual
but finally it's good for black
interesting so let's let's quickly check
what's up with it if he's uh
securing safe finish there
all right let's switch on over to that
game
uh maybe not let's see
so sergey
uh
they entered kind of a slower stage of
the game so bishop b3 c5 or k4 is
stopping c4 what if sorry sorry can we
go uh
ah if bishop b5
if this should be five trying to solve
problems by force then you take on a7 i
guess
c4 bishop a4 yeah
right and then if i take take
i play rook b2 i have to suffer for a
long long time yeah
and also you get even h5 kind of things
i don't know g4 or h5
not a good version even of things yeah
the c1 also is nasty okay so this is
nasty he didn't want that
understandable so he went
uh g g6 sergey f3 and rook d6 yeah now
if king f2
then bishop b5
now in the same line i will regain stuff
so rk7
yeah and c4 yeah now on bishop before i
take it and go bishop
check
you shouldn't go king f2 you can go king
h2 maybe instead
and then activate via g3
right
the question is what next or both wait a
minute
[Music]
nice
yeah you know actually vidiq is still
suffering uh he was not able to for he
stabilized something he stabilized
stabilized himself a bit but he doesn't
have a force draw here
and he's suffering
it's very tilting that you're like so
close but you can't quite just one
little half tempo away
and you can't do anything about it you
just got to suffer
yeah it's uh
yeah in chess sometimes you make one
inaccuracy and then you have to suffer
for hours
so
life is inferior as they say
and you know you're in a bad mood
you know after yesterday's game that was
did you find that to be do you think
that's a product of fatigue or was it
you know is it just another thing that
just happens from time to time no in
case
you exactly in case of video is a
product product of fatigue because vidiq
is someone who calculates pretty well
uh it's a combination of fatigue and of
course the time pressure so you know
these two factors
combined
he was definitely tired it's a lot of
rounds everybody's tired and especially
when time pressure adds you start
missing things
the hope is that what you miss is not so
big though but if you miss a full you
know like a piece then it's really bad
well the kinds of positions that it goes
for and you know the cost of a mistake
is extremely high so
normal i mean normal you you know you
basically fight you are exhausted your
opponent is exhausted
and you just hope that he will be the
one who makes a mistake sometimes
you
mm-hmm the h2 is high class i expect
that move from uh sergey
yeah that's a stair game of just
yeah again king f2 walks into tactics
along the second rank and allows
you should be if i first started was i
think oh sorry this should be five first
yeah then and then for k7 c4 with a
check on d2 later after the trade of
bishops
and uh
oh yeah this position is on the board he
seemed to be about to make a move what
he made
he played c4
whoa
i i you know i thought about this move
at some point but i was shy to propose
it because i thought if it's bad i look
really stupid
just like the bishop on b3 i will look
i mean but he has a threat now rook a5
rook c6 bishop a4 yeah the thing is when
i wanted to propose it it didn't work
because king was coming to d6
but now it's not defending the plan
tempo for tempo this works out so i just
want to show you king e7 okay five is
the idea
rook is over-extended bad for black
sorry it's just very strong what he did
he's just winning a pawn no
wow oh this is so bad nothing that black
can do here i don't see it
rook
you're just tied head to i mean head to
toe no it's just that's not it to do you
can't move a piece oh it's so nasty
it's not just such a depress such a
depression why is the bar so low though
why is the bar so low
maybe the bar needs to go to the bar
king e7 rook a5 rook c6 yeah
rook b6
and now rook b4 oh
bishop c4 it's still horrible but okay
king c6 but rook d4
i mean with these pawns as weak as they
like and now bishops
are blessed a5 a5 is coming wait i was
thinking rook a5 instead of rook d5
check by the way
um no move earlier even before you have
king b6 ah okay uh so in this position
but i didn't realize that i didn't
realize my h-bone is hanging
because i thought i'd take and take on
a7 and h1 is hanging okay wow it's so
it's a long line the video will see out
of desperation it's completely forced
but then wait this is a dead draw right
like white plays for k7 and rook f7
very nice not not rook a2 you lose the
pawn but first you bring the king in a2
cannot be defended it's a dead throat
pawn's on the same side of the board
yeah it's a draw chat no i think he
should go
earlier something different mr gay of
course missed the whole thing
with the rook before and so on
it's a very long line
you think he kind of intuitively he just
saw this rook a5 bishop c4id and went
for it video actually it looks pretty
calm i think he sees it
it looks pretty calm
yeah he has to start with e7
yeah it's also normal you have to
improve your kink
there's not much else you can do so
that's that kind of helps
yeah you're either lost or you have this
line so you have this line very nice
instead of c4 by the way king h2 how
much was that instead
um king h2 was let me see it was
comparable point point five
now it's going between point six and
point four but it's saying bishop p2
here
yeah so it's still within
the draw uh it's still within the drawer
yeah so this is a really difficult idea
c4 and rook d2
yeah but uh on the other hand it is
forced so if you see it it's yeah now
you have this uh drone rook and game the
drone rook and game is always nice the
structure 7 take take
take on c4 and take on a4 and it's just
easy easy hold even there should be one
apparently
a3 d3 just drops by force but even if
you would you had to take on a4 it would
still be a draw i think
the pawn structure not desirable for
white hearts that's what black is aiming
for in general such a position once he
already messed up a little bit
yeah so if he did finds and he he has to
find the only on this only moves he he
might still be
within the
within the drawer
and by the way niels has gone g5 yeah
yeah no he missed the f6 thing there
so we're going to see knight b3 bishop
g5 f4 f6 i have to say duda really just
uh
you know just took him to a to a bar
fight and uh had the bar swing his way
incredible right
yeah all sorts of risks in the rouser
huge risks huge risks he played browser
completely cluelessly
got hit by something and then just
improvised his way out of this
wow
yeah i mean duda originally was a
knighter player
when he first became a gm but
i've never seen him play the rouser
before yeah browser is something people
do when they're very desperately playing
for a win
right
yeah i mean other than duba is there any
regular proponent of the rouser yeah
yeah yeah at some point alireza was
playing it a lot
uh also his uh
uh iranian colleague uh
our hamas who played it a lot
at some point grishok was uh
into it a little bit karakin was into it
for for a bit as well shankland was into
it he did a course on chesabo
and magnus had a game with it too at one
point
so a lot of love for rouser and fabi
also played it for a win once or twice
a lot of love there from top players for
the rouser classical sicilian
and if uh duda wins this game then he'll
only add to the reputation anish i i
hate to interrupt you but we know you
have uh press engagements that you have
to go to
um and i just wanted to say how much uh
i appreciate uh you you spending time
with us this was so much fun and i know
everybody enjoyed that in the chat but
unfortunately we have to release you
you are a busy man you have interviews
to get to
and uh you know once again congrats on
finishing the tournament you're of
course playing the grand prix right
yeah i play the second leg though so i
have some time to rest now some time to
see if i have a positive test after the
tournament some time to recover from the
positive test so i'm kind of looking
forward to have some break now
oh good luck good luck on the test anish
uh and thanks again this was a real
honor and uh a lot of fun we will let
you go and we will go on a short break
thank you thank you anish you're
watching the tata steel final round
we'll be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the final
round here of this tata steel chest
tournament 2022
and dania what a pleasure it was to have
a niche in the studio with us for so
long
absolutely it's really a great honor and
uh for him to to volunteer
uh this amount of time after a very long
tournament just uh speaks to his
generosity and uh
you know it's it's always so much fun to
analyze with uh with a player of his
caliber
and his insights into the positions are
are really golden i mean he's just
you know exuding this this energy and
you know the the speed with which he
sees stuff it's i'm always just really
impressed by it i don't know i can call
me a fanboy but yeah i am a fanboy you
know i'm not ashamed of it i i am a
proclaimed self-proclaimed card-carrying
fanboy
i mean it's so impressive he's just
played 13 rounds where does he find the
energy for the inside the trolling the
this the that like he's still got some
the tank isn't empty just yet uh anish
giri tank anyway we see the updated
results here
with at the top everything decided
magnus carlsen we already knew it going
into the round uh he is the sole winner
at the end he won it by a point and a
half
of course that includes the the forfeit
win uh over rough today then shakira
mamidyarov and richard report sharing
second and third place on 8 out of 13
and anish i think we had the feeling
because the end of his tournament was a
little bit slower but let's not forget
that one he had with uh well three
consecutive wins four if you count the
the forfeit uh over
duboff but all in all i'm sure he has
plenty to be satisfied with uh with his
tournament of course he wants to win it
but he'll be back
next year for that for now as he
mentioned all his attention will be
uh going towards uh
the upcoming grand prix series
yeah i mean plus score uh you know he
had a big winning streak of course he's
very hard on himself and the game
against von forest
uh for sure left uh left a bad taste in
his mouth but
uh you know that game aside he had a lot
of a lot of highlights this tournament
and it just felt like he wasn't always
in the best of form and yet he he
managed to surmount that
and and he managed to steer a lot of the
games and into his type of position so
that's an impressive skill in its own
right fourth place could be worse than
that oh that's for sure i'd take fourth
place inside of steel
and danya now well we see we still have
four games going uh i was watching a
little bit uh of
the the dania anish show shall we go
back to niels i saw you had said niels
had just gone g5
and um i think they're going down the
line you guys had looked at
yeah um let me pull up that
uh that game yeah there we go they they
have gone down the line that we looked
at and this spells big trouble for mr
grendelius
uh this move f6 right and this is such
an anish mentioned this is such an
unorthodox
and uncommon uh con amazing defensive
construction really so i mean if niels
moves his night
yes the bishop is trapped but
unfortunately it doesn't matter
because after bishop takes c4 the
pressure on c2 grows unbearable
and therefore you
oh
i think we lost uh the sound to dania
he'll be back
in a second
as he was with sentence there i think
what he was saying uh you
cannot take uh well you know you take
here on g5 you close the g file hitting
the queen on f2 and um you'll recapture
on c3 on the the next move uh dania
right can you can you hear me now yeah
oh i apologize i might have
i think i pulled a chord or something
uh yeah b takes c3 and basically oh
but wait a minute
there is apparently an amazing resource
for white so after b takes c3
white has bishop takes g7 oh my goodness
and after king takes you the rook takes
g5 check and the bar is just skyrocketed
i mean this isn't incredible
why it blows the king to smithereens
here here
queen g6 check
and uh no matter where the king goes i
mean if it goes to d7 you get checkmated
essentially and if you go to d8 well
uh there's actually very simple when
rook takes that f8 rook takes c8 you
simplify and the h pawn is completely
unstoppable in spite of black's extra
bishop which is totally useless
oh my goodness how did this was this
only forest how did this happen well
this where did this come from
in this position
no there is a light at the end of the
tunnel for uh jkd because in this
position
essentially what he needs to do is he
needs to defend against bishop takeshi 7
this is quite simply a threat and he can
do so by playing queen b7 now you might
say wait a second but now the knight can
move but again remember this c2 pawn is
a huge huge weakness so if white goes 92
bishop takes c4 rook d2 black actually
just traps white's queen with rook f3
and if white tries to i mean a better
idea
is probably to go knight a4 but black
can throw in the movie five
further you know forcing awkwardness
among white's pieces
and i mean if you just look at this
position maybe black doesn't have
anything concrete
and the eol bar is giving around minus
two but i mean black's got a bit a bunch
of pawns the idea of going d5 d4
white's pieces are scattered all across
the board uh so if duda finds queen b7
in this critical position i think he's
going to be very much in the driver's
seat i think we're going to see this on
the board i think niels
is very very likely
to take on g5 um he's he's this right
now i can guarantee you he's deciding
between 92 and f takes g5 and uh niels
is absolutely capable of spotting the
bishop hg7 idea but so is duda if you're
in duda's shoes how easy do you think it
is to to see this bishop g7
i mean once the position is reached i
think it's quite easy because
you know you're already primed
to to look at sacrifice it's not like
you know this comes all of a sudden i
mean your king is under attack you're
looking at sacrifices and uh the only
thing that duda has to be careful about
is the temptation to start playing
quickly in nielsen's time pressure
uh but i don't think he's too
experienced for that he's not going to
you know he's not going to
do that yeah
means the same story as we've seen
throughout most of the tournament only
14 minutes on the clock
and still 16 moves to make for now uh
let's move on from here is neil's still
deciding between taking and retreating
the knight where would you like to go
next tanya
well let's briefly stop into the uh yes
panko game
against prague
because this is also entering a very
disquieting time pressure stage for
mysterious benko who's got 14 minutes
for 16 moves
um
and
this is this is i mean anish was i think
hit the nail right on the head in
mentioning that the c7 knight is
complete i mean look at this knight it's
completely out of the gate no squares
it has no squares and this black cannot
afford to play such a position
essentially without a piece and so for
that reason the pressure on black's
position is immense prague has just
played the move a4 fiona this is uh a
very impressive move knight takes a4
uh i think the point is that the knight
no longer controls d5 and now i can
swoop into d5
okay well why is this dangerous well
because if you play rook takes you when
rook takes c1 knight takes d5
white simply takes back and then takes
on d6 and crashes through
so tactically this doesn't work it's
funny because from a distance you think
why knight d5 why would i exchange my
opponent's worst piece right
but um yeah some very very concrete and
convincing reasons here
yeah i mean you just transform your
advantage and let's not forget black's
king ultimately is very very weak you
know once you play the move f5
you know i guess why it has played f4
but it's not equivalent white's got all
these pieces amassed on the king side
and if black doesn't take on a4 then of
course prague wants to push this pawn up
to a5 and then
he still wants to occupy d5 with his
knight probably andre should go rook fv8
and after a5
d7 walks into the very nasty move queen
c6 i mean
with 12 minutes on the clock
this is
incredibly uh concerning this is
incredibly concerning for
friezapenko
yeah would you say uh that prague is a
favorite to win this game at the moment
no
i'd probably give it a 50 50. i mean
because the position is so complex and
you know prague again i want to
reiterate that his opening preparation
and his early middle game play has been
great
but
you know once you know and he had
chances even against magnus
uh and and you know toward the the late
middle game
he's faltered on on several occasions so
he's gonna have to stay confident he's
gonna have to take his time but i think
he's got every shot uh to to deliver a
final round blow to yes panko and what
uh what a result that would be for him i
think regardless prague is going to walk
away here
with so many great memories so much new
experience but to walk away with a full
point in the last round would make it
all even
sweeter as niels as you predicted has
captured on g5
and it occurred to me that the only
other enticing move i mean assuming that
duda sees bishop takes g7 if he misses
it that would be crazy
um he could also play e5 in this
position by the way but the reason this
is not as good is because white is
bishop a7
queen b7 and then the knight comes into
d5
now black can recover the piece black
can play bishop takes d5
and then rokay a and the bishop is
trapped but white can give this bishop
up on his own term so i can play bishop
c5 and say okay i'll give you i'll give
you my bishop but in return you have to
ruin your own pawn structure and give me
a big pass pawn in the center even
though white is down a couple pawns look
you know the fact that there's a passer
here the fact that black has these
weaknesses
actually give white enough play uh to
equalize so a big moment here for jan
kristoff who has to be very accurate
queen b7 is the critical move he has to
find if he wants to preserve a big
advantage
if you see bishop g7 we've just looked
at oh
oh
my goodness he's taken away
oh my god
oh my goodness and neil's like i don't
know
if we look at nielsen's face you can
kind of see the eyes
at least i thought looking to the king
sideway but maybe that's just projection
but oh my goodness
dania let's show the line again that is
possible now
disclaimer i'm not i don't know exactly
what the evaluation the email bar is
swinging hither and there it's saying
white is winning then it's saying it's
equal then it's saying why it's slightly
better
it doesn't it it's very very clear that
after bishop takes g7 if niels finds
this
it it this is clearly a blunder by judah
now it's a separate question of
you know what is the damage can black
somehow
uh manage to get that into a decent
situation but bishop takes g7 a
brilliant tactical idea well what's the
point you just crashed through on the
king's side you sacked the rook on g5 i
can bet a silver dollar that niels is
going to find this and the point is that
white all only needs two pieces fiona in
order to get to this king because the
king is just wide open now it has two
choices if it goes to h7 the mate is
very straightforward check
then you give another check you get the
kink to the g file in comes the rook
in comes the rook
in comes the queen
and here comes checkmate so that's a
pretty straightforward mating sequence
for that reason
uh in this position black has to go the
other way
but now white gives another check on f1
here comes the rook win g6 check and the
point is that the king has no way of
staying attached to the rook and you're
gonna force the king onto the eighth
rank
one way or another after which you're
gonna take the rook on f8 let's also not
forget that white's king is perfectly
safe here so
imagine a situation like this after rook
f8 and bishop b8 why does he even have
to hurry why can play h6 why i can just
promote you a second queen and black has
no
absolutely no counter play
so
this is insane and after bishop takes g7
fiona black does not have to take the
bishop and it appears that the engine
suggests the best line for black is the
incredibly depressing c takes me to
bishop takes b2 and now something like
e5 he has captured the bishop has landed
on g7 wow
this is a extremely uncharacteristic
tactical oversight by duda i'm not
suggesting seven is easy let's see it
with 43 minutes on the clock he played
way too fast way too fast
and that's the reaction of a man who
immediately knows god i actually just
missed this
and now well daniel
you were saying he doesn't have to take
on g7 basically he cannot take on g7
right that would just be no he cannot
game over i think it's losing well the
only other thing i'd say king g7 rook g5
um yeah it's game over king i was
contemplating going king f7 here but no
it's made after rook f1 check it's the
similar kind of
mating patterns here with uh checks on
the g file and the f file
no duda has to play c takes b2
and niels actually can go king b1 here i
think that might be the key move king b1
and
black might have to take on g7 here now
with the pawn sitting on b2 in some of
those lines maybe this is a better
version for black
but i i i mean the computer needs to
reach a higher depth here well for
example
so so let's follow that line i was
talking about previously all right rook
f1 check king yeah we looked at this
right queen g6 check king d7 queen g7
check king d8 rook takes f5 bishop this
is exactly the position that i was
talking about previously with the pawn
sitting on c3 the thing is if white goes
h6 black can try to use this pawn as an
anchor to try to force perpetual check
so queen b4 and if you go h7 queenie one
check king takes b2 and rook takes c2
check and it appears the black insecure
perpetual checker by the skin by the
hair on his chinny chin chin
um
but
i mean this is incredibly tenuous it's
like
you know if this one idea doesn't work
then black loses on the spot
and niels is kind of spoiled for choice
after c takes p2 first of all will duda
even gather together the wits to take on
b2 or is he going to panic and simply
collapse here and take the bishop i mean
it's a tough moment for him he took
risks from the opening did everything
perfectly came here in such a fighting
mood one oversight
and and niels takes the upper hand kudos
two nils for finding bish uh finding
bishop g7 tough moment for duda i'm
hearing that vedic might have uh blonde
well with it
oh my goodness
is collapsing here completely
i mean he didn't find anish and i were
trying to derive the
you know the only drawing sequence i'm
sorry didn't mean to do that uh and and
and in
and and and know in in in you know in
these positions
yeah so basically in
in this position king d a was a big
mistake and we were talking about rook
c6 being the defensive approach so
here's the point you have to induce
bishop a4 why do you have to induce it
because the bishop on b3 protects the c4
pawn you have to
make it so that the bishop doesn't
protect upon why is that important
because now you have this tempo with
rook before the bishop comes back to b3
but the rook's presence on b4 fiona is
crucial you go king d6 rook d5 track
king c6 and white simply cannot keep
this pawn protected uh and black should
be able to draw this quite quite handily
this was the drawing sequence but for
some reason vinit going king d8 i can't
explain this i can't believe that move i
don't get it rook take now he just gives
away the pawn i mean at least he should
have tried
to defend the pawn with rook c6 to me
that was a pretty natural move and he
just goes back to c8
you know trying to set up some something
resembling a defensive construction
but uh
apparently after h5 in order to create
this long-term weakness on h6 now sergey
can go rook a4 sorry not rook a5 i mean
say rook c6
and i think vivid simply might be losing
bishop b6 c5 and you know in the event
of a trade he's going to lose the h6
pawn and he's going to lose the game i
mean vidit is experiencing a total and
complete collapse right now and you feel
for him
but this is just i mean h5 here is
devastating and sergey is going to play
it
and yeah i'm really surprised that when
anish was here like he he knows with it
so well of course he was confident
that it looked calm and had seen the
line but
indeed it is sergey and he we can see on
the camera he senses
his chance now
and danya i just cannot believe it i
remember the first time we saw the
position or the second time we saw the
position in the bird's eye view all the
pieces had come off
i thought this is over but what do you
have
yeah
how do you put in words what uh sergey
koryakin has done which i think is uh
quite impressive
well sergey is a beast and he just and
this is what sergey does for a living
you know this is bread and butter he and
then anisha was also describing this
where sergey wanted to play with minimal
risk he was fine with the draw today but
if you awaken the sleeping giant if you
awaken the beast uh
you know the beast is going to come
after you and one spit it played that
tiny inaccuracy
right at the very start and as my coach
would always tell me when you have these
types of positions
you don't want to procrastinate
with making the draw you want to sit
there at the very beginning and make
that draw because the more you
procrastinate uh and the trick the
trickier the draw becomes and although
you're going to have many many more
chances to draw the game every
subsequent draw gets harder and harder
and harder until in the blink of an eye
you look around and you don't have the
draw anymore and all of a sudden you're
down upon you're losing which is kind of
what happened now where was the initial
draw the initial draw
that vidit had which might have been the
easiest
uh draw that he had was to play bishop
f5 here in this position rather than
bishop basics this was a very very
serious inaccuracy that bishop on a6
ends up being uh a lot more trouble than
it's worth
how does bishop f5 draw well vidit might
have been worried about rook b7
but bishop takes c2 rook takes c7 and as
anish pointed out bishop e4 is the
move now if y takes on e4 this is an
instant drop because h4 is hanging
and if white takes on a7
this is also a dead draw just because of
the incredibly damaged king side pawn
structure white has no way to make
progress
and uh i think vivid just forgot about
bishop b4 i think he didn't see that
move
i mean and it's it's so crazy how
one move it because the position doesn't
look like the kind of position where you
think
okay i have to make a very precise move
but i think it's exactly what you were
saying if you don't uh secure it
immediately and sergey i mean the way
he's put
the pressure on uh in the the remainder
of the gauge game just
yeah very very impressive he still
hasn't played h5 but here it is just as
we talk about it h4h5 is on the board
oh i think we've unfortunately
lost again so
h5 has appeared let me quickly refresh
uh the game h5 played
uh by sergey karjakin who
uh looks like he is full steam ahead
towards that full point against vidic
who
for him really dramatic and to the
tournament i think let's bring back the
bird's eye view
no actually what we are gonna do we are
gonna go on a quick break and then we'll
be back with all the action here from
the final round in just a couple of
minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome back to the final
round of this tata steel chess
tournament and danya we got two quick
draws we thought there might be a lot
more but no
uh players are fighting everywhere and
the games are really coming to life we
see sergey karyakin
has played h5 so he's getting very close
to having a simply winning position
and uh in the duda game
duda has taken me to correct
yeah which was required where do you
want to start
yeah let's start with the duda game um
which it may actually end up being a
draw if duda is tremendously
accurate now we're getting some feedback
here uh some very very interesting
uh variations uh shared to us
um
and i want to share one of those
variations let me just give me a second
to pull it up yeah i want to share
basically why ctxb2 is so important so
there's a deep point
uh c takes me to basically fiona we
analyzed king b1 and i explained how the
pawn on b2 could be used as a decoy and
remember that line with the perpetual
check but
you might ask
what about king takes b2 what if we just
take this pawn well here again after
king takes g7 rook takes g5 we follow
this line take stakes king f7 rook f1
king e8 queen g6
hi king d8
rook takes f8 king c7 rook takes c8
queen takes c8 h6 now remember how
previously i said this is winning for
white because white just promotes the
pawn
now not queen h8 check here because
queen g7 intercepts the pawn is
unstoppable but black is an amazing
defensive resource that saves the game
what bishop takes c4
queen takes c4
queen h8 picking off the pawn
oh goodness oh my lance and that entire
sequence
that would not have been possible queen
hay would not have been a check
uh were it not for the fact that the
king is on b2 very easy line right very
simple to calculate but niels he's got a
big decision he has just taken on
between unbeaten king will they go down
this line will do to see this this is
insanely hard to see fiona i wouldn't be
surprised if he doesn't see it
yeah i mean it's very scary of course to
capture on g7 the problem is what is
your alternative what if you
don't take that no now you're not right
she's winning yeah you have to take
right no and that's honestly very often
what helps uh what helps the cause when
you're defending
uh a position like this is the fact that
your moves are absolutely forced and you
don't even have to care
whether you're winning or you're losing
or you're trying it doesn't matter
because you just have to follow the line
uh you have no other choice
and well if we go down the line again i
just wanted to see until like the whole
line is basically
first right if duda goes down that line
yes
then he will find bishop e4
okay shall we yeah well
sorry yeah we'll keep an eye on we'll
keep an eye on that we'll return to this
game when duda makes a decision in this
position
so uh where do we go back to there's
been a couple of moves in the pragnanda
game
we could also check in with jordan
what's your pick
well prague has a huge initiative i mean
andre is in mortal danger of losing this
game
um let's check into that game first and
then uh from there we could go and check
also on sam shanklin's game which we
haven't looked at
for a while as you said now look at this
position uh andre who's got three
minutes by the way for 15 moves just by
the way
uh deciding on knight takes a four
and as we discussed prague uh slamming
this knight into d5 bishop b7 rook takes
c6
and now oh wait the time just updated it
said he had three minutes but now he has
15. maybe we can zoom in on the cam
because i also thought that he was much
lower
and we zoom into the camera and
find out we'll try and find out
yeah because this is actually a game
changer oh no he now it says he has
three minutes again
okay if he has three minutes here fiona
i mean just look at this position i
think prague is just gonna go rookie one
hit the knight on e6 and if you move the
knight away the rook is going to
infiltrate to e7 with decisive effect
i mean i just don't see andre saving
this game with with three minutes on the
clock i mean maybe even
with more
yeah maybe even with an hour like maybe
it's just not salvageable
um the evol bar is not too concerned
here we go
all right let's work the magic
15. i think it's 15.
it is 15. so that gives him
a sliver of hope at least
okay just making sure it's 15 and not
like 150. yeah it's 15.
it's 15 and that's actually quite a game
changer that gives them a good amount of
cushion it's still time pressure make no
mistake but that means that prague is
also in time pressure
uh and that means that adds quite a bit
of uncertainty to the position rookie
one apparently the move here is g5
counter attacking the bishop on h4 what
an incredible difficult just a crazy
move to make what
you have to open your king voluntarily
and after fg5 knight g5
uh queen g3 looks quite devastating
as well and after 94
i mean you might get some sort of a
liquidation into a bad endgame after
bishop takes c4
no i mean prague is doing a phenomenal
job this game and
practically speaking a single mistake
against the game surely g5 is not likely
to be played what do you think
no but as with the um
as with the duda game uh
andre is helped along by the fact that
he just doesn't have too many moves i
mean i guess uh the other natural move
here is to play rookie eight but that
loses to the simple queen e3 essentially
preparing knight f6 with a fork if you
play knight f6 immediately that actually
loses the game to queen takes f6 and do
not forget that white's queen
is also hanging so you have to get the
queen off of the pin and here's a
beautiful detail if black takes on d5
and says well no problem i'm just going
to bring my knight back to c7 and force
a bunch of trades no you're not white's
going to take on e8
and at the end of the day
white returns back to e7 takes the queen
and emerges up a piece so
lots of tactics here and lots of
landmines that black can very easily
step on
i mean really some of these lines crazy
crazy stuff i think this game is just
probably going to be uh decided within
the next 13 moves here as we see the
time is still incorrect so andre 13
minutes on the clock will come back here
this is the moment of truth i think if
andre plays g5 if he if he finds it
within himself to find that move
you know that is the only way he stays
in the game every other move
seems to go down in flames basically
we'll see
he's probably going to invest actually
quite a bit of his remaining 13 minutes
to try and find
right i saw on the camera that the move
was made was that this game and okay he
didn't find g5 he played queen to d7 oh
but now now he just goes down i don't
understand 97 check
and oh i guess king hate and just queen
g3 with a completely overwhelming attack
i mean knight takes g6 is a potential
sacrifice just look at
just look at all the squares surrounding
black's king
and if you play queen takes c7 then
after bishop takes c7 bishop takes f3
obviously you don't take the bishop you
take the rook
and at the end of the at the end of the
line you have okay not the best pawn
structure but you have an extra exchange
and
this
maybe this is what andre is aiming for
but the problem is that he's going to
lose the a7 whoops
uh he's going to lose the a7 pawn
uh let me just sorry about that let me
repeat that line one more time at 97. we
need seven
should be seven bishop f3 bishop f8
knight f8 gf he is going to lose
a7 and you know he's probably also going
to lose d6 this is uh unsalvageable in
the context of a practical game i think
97 check should
uh win prague the game he can also step
away from the pin with queen f2
preparing 97 as well as knight f6 no
this is very bad for andre
and look at that poor knight on a4
completely out of the game while all the
white pieces are participating
actively and what's going on in the
center on the board and on the king side
and crunch time now for prague will he
play knight e7
um
what do you think dania
i think that he will i i i vote 97. i
think he's going to hunker down because
that's essentially why he even put a
knight on d5 in the first place and
that's why he brought the bishop to h4
it was precisely
in order to take control of these two
squares so if he's not playing 97 then
one might ask you know why did he
initiate this whole campaign in the
first place
we'll keep a close eye here for now
let's bring back the bird's eye view for
a second
as uh i don't know if you want to update
the kayaking
video if we should just go to your then
again well
let's let's take a look at the jordan
game because that that game is kind of
heating up and i think sam has done a
uh sam has performed unimpeachably in uh
in this
pawn down end game
where you know it did appear as an issue
and i were discussing that you know
jordan has essentially free pressure for
the rest of the game and sam is going to
suffer but sam has found a way really in
the span
of 10 moves of less than 10 moves i
think to balance out the game and i
think sam shouldn't lose the game now
let's come back to to where you guys
left it off and see how did sam do that
so basically it was around this moment
okay jordan goes rook t1 and you know i
think jordan probably played a little
over ambitiously here he goes g4 he
tries to occupy as much space as
possible this is an idea that we did
discuss
and then after h6 he goes h5 slightly
weird move i mean he puts his pawns on
the same color as his bishops he saddles
himself uh with weaknesses and he also
creates dark square weaknesses on g5 and
e5
king f16 g3 sam activating his rook with
rook c4 king f4
sam dropping the rook back to c5 and at
this point sam is already cooking up the
idea that i think is going to save him
the game
uh rook d2 now he goes g5 check posing
white with an unenviable dilemma either
you bring your king back and allow
black's king to swoop into e5 or this is
what jordan did simplify the position
and the more pawns have traded the
easier black's task is rook d1 jordan
not really seeing what he can do here
and sam pouncing on the opportunity rook
a5 hitting the pawn and now in comes the
night knight c4
uh moving away from its blockading posts
but doing so for a
for the greater good hitting the pawn on
b2 and if jordan has to play a move like
rook b1 fiona then that means sam is
already not worse he can play rook a4
and x-ray the knight if anybody has to
be careful in one of these types of
positions it might be why why can very
easily lose a piece here yeah i was just
i was looking down at that square on d2
that night suddenly uh looking very very
tricky as you say jordan might have to
be careful but if not rook b1 then how
do we
deal with the defense of the pawn on b2
well
i mean i guess knight b3 is the engine
recommendation but that is a very
strange move it
it seems to fail to the move rook b5 and
the point here is that white has this
brilliant idea actually knight d2
okay well what what the heck is the
point of this well the point is that
if white black takes on d2 then the rook
captures and white defends everything if
black plays knight takes b2 then the
knight activates itself through e4
and then after rook d4 white has this
weird kind of domination all of a sudden
over black snide on b2 which can't
really re-enter society uh through c4
and of course white has
this very strong passport on d5 and now
that the pawn is not blockaded
uh you know this is now a force to be
reckoned with but i don't know if
jordan's gonna find this i mean knight
b3 is
far from obvious as we see jordan deep
in foot 17 minutes on the clock
all the remaining games time could play
some kind of role knight b3 really far
from
obvious um but
there really is no other way do you
think rook b1 is more tempting in a way
or do you feel that's too passive a move
it's so passive and and rook a4 is
pretty scary in response to it i
if i had to guess i would hypothesize
that a draw offer
uh might be on the cards here for jordan
i mean i would start getting a little
bit concerned by what everything seems
to be hanging
and that was my my next question is
there any way if your then wants to bail
out there's not even
any clear bailout options or are there
well i guess he could play
a move like rook h1 maybe
um although no this gets sharp again i
mean knight takes b2 i was going to
propose rook takes h6
but instead of grabbing on a3
immediately black could throw in the
move knight d3 getting the king out of
the way and now rook takes a3
it's quite scary because again there's
this third ranked pressure black's got
connected passers no you're right i
don't actually see a clear
simplificational kind of bailout for
white maybe d6
yeah maybe this is no but again it takes
p2 and again everything seems to be
falling i mean i wonder you were talking
about uh a draw for from jordan i wonder
if it's already too late for that if
some suddenly feels like uh he is in
control we should go back to neil's uh
yes they're playing through that line
here we go
[Music]
buckle your seat belts ladies and
gentlemen
queen g6 check is about to happen
it would be so incredible if we go down
this whole line with bishop e4 in the
end
queen hmm
he of course sees that line no question
about it now here's the very interesting
thing after rook takes f8 king c7 which
has just appeared on the board
niels does not need to rush rook takes
c8 that is not the only move and he's
recognized that he doesn't have a lot of
time
he he can throw in queen g7 check in
fact this is a much more testing move
and
yeah he can throw in pin g7 check which
is a lot more testing now if bishop d7
now and only now you can take and go h6
and win the game
uh of course black is not going to go
bishop d7 black is going to go king b6
at the very minimum
white has queen d4 check
and if you go back to c7
then after rook f7 check the attack rage
is on fiona bishop d7 e5 looks very
scary
this is right up nils's alley and so for
that reason
the king should go back to b7 rather
than c7 in order to be able to cover a
check on f7 with rook c7 but the engine
suggests a very simple idea why don't we
take on c8 now
and why don't we go h6 now
now what's the difference bishop takes
c4 queen takes e4 queen hey well there
is a difference where is that king it's
on b7 and this is now a check
this is what it all comes down to these
this level of nuance is what is required
to play this position accurately it's
insane but it's not so hard to how do
you in your experience if you see this
position from a distance you are a full
piece down but the fact that the pawn is
so far advanced do you immediately
instinctively feel like i'm fine here
yeah i i really do
because you have a corner pawn and
and because you just sort of see that
you're threatening age seven it's not
like
you're going for anything long term
although i guess it's a tiny bit scary
after something like e5
but as long as you have such a monster
by the way bishop takes c4 queen before
check is the point as long as you have
such a monster on h6
um and also let's not forget that niels
was basically losing
so for him
uh he's not even necessarily expecting
to be winning everything that he can do
here to complicate the game is already
exciting it's a win-win for him right
even if he draws he's not going to be
too broken up about it
and he's not coming at this from the
perspective of oh
i only need to find something that's
super convincing he's already happy just
to find a way to complicate the game
given where he came from i don't know if
that makes sense but it's all about the
sort of psychology of which position you
came from and sometimes that can really
help you be more objective if you had a
bad position and now you're able to
complicate it uh you're more satisfied
with that than for example if you were
previously winning and now you screwed
it up well then you don't just want a
complicated position you want something
more clear-cut
i think that makes a lot of sense i
think what niels is going to do if he
has seen the line and maybe we can just
show it one more time with that bishop
takes e4 so if he needs takes on c8 here
oh sorry
and then goes h6 yeah
and then bishop takes
queen takes and queen h1 which we showed
earlier i think
if neil sees this quite quickly this
line then he can evaluate um
if he wants to try and
look for something something better
yeah and and if he rejects rook takes ca
the only two candidate moves in this
position are rook f7 check
which is actually very interesting as
well i mean it forces bishop d7 because
queen b6
uh allows this beautiful check on g1
with what i think is devastating effect
uh but after bishop d7 he could go for
this h6 this is incredibly scary for
black as well so that's one candidate
move
so in that position after bishop d7 we'd
rather push the pawn than take on e6 i
guess so can we take on these to be
honest i completely forgot that you can
take on e6 but uh black can go queen b5
here actually and and if you go c4
then miraculously black has this check
on e5 it's all about these queen checks
at the right moment and positioning the
king on the right square
what a position and what a what a moment
here we'll see what does nils do let's
very quickly go back to the bird's eye
view
and um we see that jordan has gone
knight b3 so that's quite impressive wow
that is really impressive and he's gonna
find knight d2
i am
you know i'm i'm tipping my hat if he
finds this idea
i am tipping my hat if he plays knight
d2 in this position which is very likely
because and he just did he just did wow
that is why jordan but forest won last
year's tata steel
you know and that's something nobody
should forget this guy at his best
is he's a machine
and he just played like one this is
really this uh well i was gonna say
defense he found in a way it's a defense
to keep the edge if that makes sense
wow i mean very impressive and to see
this 94 check followed by rook d4
concept and this breathes new life
into
white's position now it appears that sam
can still draw the game with very
accurate play let's quickly go back to
the jordan game let me just show what
sam needs to do what sam needs to do
here is to throw in the check on g5 of
the pawn that forces the king back to g3
and it appears that knight takes b2
preserves a reasonable position for
black
if you give a check on e4 the king has a
nice hiding spot on g6 that's part of
the reason that you played g5 check the
other was just to get white's king as
far away from the center as possible and
here black should be quite all right
um
but the engine suggests rook h1
now king g7 and then swinging the rook
back to c1 in order to infiltrate to c7
but i'll tell you what here jordan is
not going to be thinking about a draw
for he's still going to be thinking
about how to win the game and sam 10
minutes on the clock not a lot for a
position of this complexity
yeah and i mean this despite the reduced
material somewhat reduced material on
the board this position is still a
hugely complex by the way i don't know
if you saw when we were in bird's eye
view but uh prague did not play knight
e7
yeah he played on
a close cousin of that movie moved his
queen away
apologism just
close cousin but is that cousin i think
we'll we can go back there is it
as effective cousin yeah let's go back
and let's examine that move
[Music]
you know it gives black an extra
opportunity i think and this time andre
actually down to five minutes fiona this
time it's not a lie this time he
actually has five minutes
he has to apparently
take on d5 with the bishop
and let me tell you you have to go for
this position voluntarily
and realize that after queen c8 it's not
so clear how white follows up i mean
the engine's recommendation is just to
play c4 which is an encouraging sign for
black that means that white doesn't have
anything super concrete
man i mean if andre goes for this
that would be incredible but even here
of course white is much better white has
massive pressure uh together with an
attack and the weakness of the pawn on
d6 also makes a lot of end games bad for
black
well i'm still very pessimistic about
andre's chances yeah what if instead of
c4 uh in that line
yes it takes what if i try and bring the
queen immediately so after rookie seven
sorry he by the way has not played uh
bishop takes d5 what was your idea just
out of curiosity just uh i was wondering
if i'm not in time to to bring the queen
uh queen g5 how are you gonna meet my
checkmate
attempt
no i i think this is also very effective
because rook f7 can always be met with
rookie but andre
uh he has played the move rook f7
instead
oh and knight f6 check
what
no but this is just i think he's i mean
he sees it he sacrificed it he wants to
take and go queen f7
uh but here i think he just blundered
bishop takes f5 which ends the game on
the spot
bishop f5 with the knight dropping on e6
on the next move and yeah that's just
that
knight f6 check ends the game
prague might score a brilliant final
round victory
vic is ready with the camera he is
expecting that knight to land on f6
momentarily
and
well i'm actually also curious as to
what prague's face
if he gives anything away i expect him
to be deeply focused
um
is he not at the board
maybe there's someone in front of the
the camera but
yes it panko
he's still looking very very
calm but it could
dawn on him any moment that he has
overlooked bishop takes f5 at the end of
the line
that's definitely what he overlooked i
mean obviously he didn't miss knight f6
there's no way he missed knight f6
uh but bishop takes f5 is easy to miss
because when you look at the move queen
f7 from a distance you think okay i'm
attacking the bishop on f6
and it's easy to forget that bishop
takes f5 creates
a a a much stronger threat against the
knight on e6
season yeah i think prague has seen it
already he is just double checking now
but
um we don't see him so often leaning you
know over the board but this is the last
game
and there was the the look towards ese
panko okay is he gonna give anything
away like
um but no i i expect knight f6 to appear
uh
very very soon
yeah
um he's got seven and a half minutes
plenty of time to
calculate this
relatively simple line and you know
triple check it we're going to see
knight f6 check and this quite possibly
will be our next
um result of of the round although niels
let's swing back to that game has just
taken on c8 so i think that he has
decided to go for that drawing line with
take c8 and h6
and i mean i don't think we can blame
him the other line we didn't find
anything too convincing we found some
ways to to keep the game alive
but
nothing nothing much more than that so i
think we can't blame
and
deals too too harshly
as they are going down at this line here
so now what we expect to happen is h6
which has just been played
i mean i hope judah sees bishop takes c4
i mean i'm sure he does but you know
there's always
especially i think your confidence is a
little bit shaken when you've already
missed something in the game like bishop
takes g7
yeah it really is and the the point is
after bishop before queen e4 when he
nominally black will be up upon
but that is merely nominally because
after queen takes h6 queen c4 check
uh white has perpetual based on the fact
that black uh cannot abandon uh both of
these you know pawns essentially white
keeps targeting them with with these
checks so 99
certainty that the game is going to end
precisely with this kind of perpetual
yeah and i know brick was ready for the
moment but i think maybe
young christoph will
i was going to say maybe he'll take a
while but the hand is itching i think
and there he is
bishop takes did neil's missed this
i wonder if niels might have missed this
i think neil's missing well i don't know
it's hard to say hard to say when we
don't it's hard to say and you know
maybe he decided he has a minute and a
half on the clock white is not out of
the woods if white plays differently
it's not like white can't lose of course
like liz white's down a piece and neil's
deciding okay he was basically lost uh
he doesn't want to rock the boat and a
completely reasonable decision by mr
gwendelius with a beautiful tactic
bishop takes g7 yeah i think you're
right i think neil smith bishop takes c4
because we see him shaking his head a
little bit and yeah
he might have yeah yeah
and he's thinking here because and and
if he was planning all this he would
have probably played a little bit faster
but who knows but he has also seen the
draw now i don't know if you saw but
king a2 was accompanied by that look
at that directed at dude like okay draw
i think he might even have
offered or maybe just looked at him
again but
of course these players see that this is
just a perpetual now and we'll see a
handshake uh
within seconds
yes we will and this will be our next
result not the product game prague is
still thinking about going knight f6 and
he's overthinking it
that's crazy let's wait here for one
second because i think yeah yeah of
course there will be a result in the
second we'll see the handshake
we'd do that just having no no shelter
for his king
uh with the queen too far away on the
other side off the board
and there is the handshake a draw agreed
between niels gwendelus and the ancestor
but that game had a lot of interesting
moments lots of ups and downs done yet
what an incredibly rich game and duda
with a
crazy opening gamble playing the rouser
which he really has never played before
and playing it in a very unique fashion
you know he made this move queen b6
early in the opening
blocking his own beep on so he plays it
in a unique style burns all his bridges
uh but it pays off and he tricks neils
with this beautiful bishop
but uh just as we switched cameras
prague finally played nice
f6
and um what we were saying if you're
just joining us now
maybe
um maybe andre had relied on oh he goes
king f7
um well queen h4
probably is the winning move here
yeah queen h4 let's have a look queen h4
hitting the pawn on h7 well you have to
play h5
and you know even there's even bishop h8
here paving the way for the queen to
come into f6
that's very pretty actually
yeah but there's queen d and you know
these end games can be
if they're winning but but a lot of
technique is sometimes required your
bishop is also stranded believe it or
not on h8 it cannot be one because if
the black king drops back then the
bishop can escape to f6 but
that can be quite disquieting uh so i
wonder how
how prague is going to try to convert
this in the most clinical fashion
uh if not queen h4 what if we
simply drop the bishop bank
yeah you could you could play bishop h4
but then i take c3 i think
although although uh bishop takes up
five in this position once again
g takes f5 queen takes c3 should also be
winning for white
because the knight can't move
because of rookie seven check
very nice so there are a few options for
prague by the way uh we're only on move
30 here
so 10 moves 10 moves still to go 10
minutes for prague andre is the panko
under 3
minutes
yeah i mean
jesus that's
highly unenviable task
what pride goes for i don't think he'll
go for that line we saw with the bishop
hh which i thought looked cute but the
more i looked at it
and the bishop not being able to come
back into the game
um is not really what i would want of
course it might still be winning but i
think prague will look for something
else
yeah and he's
about to make a move and he just looked
up at if i go like
is this all you've got
all right well quinn h4 is essentially
forced i don't
see what else is
well bishop h4 is is also a move as you
mentioned but i don't know i feel like
when h4 is just
like a better version of it because
you're threatening the pawn on h7
essentially he knows there he goes with
ph4h5 is going to be played instantly i
think
i mean nothing has really played
instantly in this game
what if uh
what if i drop my king back
yeah so here i think there's bishop b7
this is actually quite important
and then after okay let's say knight
takes c3 there's queen f6 swooping in
knight e4
bishop before bishop b4 and here a very
instructive moment you can just over
extend
black by playing rookie one now you
might ask well where
where is the rook going it's going to a7
it takes takes queen takes c6 and this
is actually a very pretty mating
sequence queen f6 jack if the king drops
back then queen of fate is made and if
king h6 then check
here
and checkmate so that's just one of many
ways that the game
could end
andre is thinking so maybe he is
considering king g8
but he needs to make uh he needs to make
a move he still has 10 yeah
h5
and now
so now we're back in in this moment
dania
in the end i wasn't
too happy with bishop h8 so what what
alternatives can you offer me
well there's bishop g5 and basically you
want to take on f5 here that this is the
ideal scenario unfortunately you can't
do it immediately because you're going
to blunder the bishop on f6
so the alternative to bishop ha this is
the top engine move and my guess is just
probably the best line is bishop g5 and
again the point is after knight takes e3
now you can play bishop takes f5 now
that you've preserved the dark squared
bishop you can go for this line
and calculating this is very persay
queen g6 check knight g7
and rookie 7 with uh devastating effect
white wins the queen
i think prague sees it
and
yeah he has gun bishop g5
yep i mean this is just merciless he did
that really quickly too
i think andre is going to go queen c6
most likely threatening checkmate
but now i can kill two birds with one so
i can play queen h3
and not only does this defending his
mate this also reinforces
and makes even stronger the threat of
bishop takes f5 because the queen is
going to recapture on f5 now prague is
one or two moves away from winning this
game essentially yeah it looks like
andre and sepango suddenly has a bit
more time on the clock again yeah
it's been jumping a little bit all over
the place but he's the last nine moves
to make
and in this position and no amount of
time would
would help him
with prague really uh
sometimes we've we've been a little bit
critical of him daniel throughout the
tournament
when prague was missing that
the size i don't even know how you
describe it but
when given a chance not
going for the most forward lines but
today here in this final stages he's
been clinical
yeah he really has been and i think he
senses the moment this is the last round
if he oh sorry my
i keep doing that my phone falls on my
keyboard and it actually refreshes the
screen that's hilarious
um but basically
he senses okay this is the last round if
he wins this game he gains a lot of
rating this is huge this is a huge huge
game for him
and uh you know he knows that he can't
screw this up and then he needs to play
decisively there's queen c6 and then
really the last difficult well not even
a difficult move but if you're comparing
queen g3 and queen h3 obviously queen h3
is better because it aims at the f5 pawn
and sorry just look at prague like he
senses but it's so weird to see him so
animated
like i think he's not even doing it on
purpose it's just yeah the nerves and
the excitement
and there it is queen h3 i mean he
he smells blood and you can just tell he
is not letting this game go he knows
exactly how to win this game he knows
what to do and how to do it the game is
over
a frog cut jumping away
gotcha that's right
i mean you got to be happy for go ahead
bigfoot was just wondering if instead of
queen h3 uh we could have also played
bishop f1 defending the right that way
and keep the queen looking down at f6
and here there was a really pretty move
bishop d8 kind of the same idea as
bishop h8 but much stronger because now
queen f6 as well as queen e7 are both
totally unstoppable
um and this was also
essentially winning on the spot
and but yeah the answer is yes or yeah
panko
do you think he'll
i mean how do you
how do you deal with the threat of
bishop f5 is there anything at all
you don't you resign
i mean you can take the bishop on g5 but
that doesn't actually help help the
cause
and we see andre i think he will there
he goes he has just captured on g5
i think he's gonna go queen d7 after fg
and these but still bishop takes f5
sorry fiona
yeah and maybe we can look at that
actually
so after prague recaptures queen d7
would defend upon on f5
but still bishop f5 and if queen f5 rook
f1
pins the queen
and if gf then obviously queen h5 is
just totally crushing i mean you win
everything in this mate
so
maybe bishop c8 here is is an attempt
but now there's a very pretty move g4
just breaking through on the king side i
mean
once you understand the general idea
this move is pretty obvious like you
just got to do it
bishop b7 back
and the long diagonal yeah but just she
takes f5
it's just
it's just it's one check and then it's
over and andre has indeed gone bishop's
eight so we might see this on the board
frog is the kind of guy to play g4 yeah
it would be such a flashy spectacular
way to to end the game i'm kind of
rooting for prague to go g4 and and end
the game in style
yeah i think that's going to happen by
the way let's check very quickly into
sam's game
it does seem like von forrest
might be taking a draw by repetition
here
i'm not entirely sure sam has found a
way to preserve the blockade
and what was once occupied by the knight
on d6 is now occupied by the king now
where did jordan come from
he came from c2 so he might be repeating
moves rook c7
king d6
and we might see a repetition of this
sword now white is obviously up upon but
look at the difference in piece activity
sam has a monster work on b3 he's got a
great bishop on d7 that is being
that is pressuring the pawn on g4 and i
really don't see a way for a way for
white to make long-term progress here
without giving up at least one of his
pawns my guess is that the likeliest
outcome for this game is a draw but
we'll see just wanted to quickly update
everybody on sam's game they're about to
make move 40. so this game is gonna
play about to be added let's quickly
check in with it uh and karjakin
yeah it's been a while since we've
looked at that
as vidit has they've made time control
and a miserable situation indeed for
forbidden who
yeah i mean karjakin has gotten the
ideal
type of position where the bishop
defends the pawn the pawn defends the
other plant
um
black has a long-term weakness on h6
which may not seem significant at the
moment
but if you imagine blackstroke leaving
the sixth rank uh that's not something
you wanna
you know that's not something you can
afford to be concerned with on top of
white's
extra and passive now objectively this
is lost uh no question about it i
invented has more time now but i don't
think it's gonna help him yeah so we'll
have time i think to come back to this
one let's stick now for the remainder of
at this first time control with
pragnanda against yasipanko he is not
on a g4 instead he went pregnant for
queen e3
i mean it doesn't spoil anything i think
he should play h3 i think as long as he
understands that the correct idea is to
play g4
i think i think he can play h3 here and
then essentially just
shove g4 through on the next move and
it's not like andre
uh can really do anything in the next
you know four or five moves if under it
tries to take on c3 after h3 let's say
yeah i think still bishop f5
and uh well if queen f5 there's
checkmate with grenade or c7
and if f takes if g takes f5 then queen
takes c3 ends the game
yeah so that is not an option um
h3 would be such a it's a funny move in
that
uh it's such a quiet move it looks like
you want to just crash through it uh but
you just make a little preparing move
and you say to black what are you gonna
do with that
extra ah a little bit of extra time and
there just isn't anything
and those are the biggest like power
moves because
you you make a move that doesn't hide
your intentions at all like in fact it's
a move that makes it nakedly obvious
what it is you want to do and there is
absolutely nothing your opponent can do
to stop but it's a very satisfying
feeling that you're just preparing
something and you know you're going to
execute it but prague he's taking his
time here he has to find this last touch
right he can't let this
hang on the precipice and get let andre
you know bring his knight back to b6 and
bring his bishop up to b7 because that's
exactly how you how you complicate the
the technical task you need to act
while andre is still not consolidated if
that makes sense
and in a way it makes sense because your
rook and your queen are perfectly placed
on the e file you don't really want to
move any of those pieces the bishop is
also perfectly placed looking down at
that diagonal f5 g6 so i think h3
is actually a logical
logical move
yes it is
and brought down to five and a half
minutes
but he does have five moves to make yeah
i was just gonna repeat that so five
moves indeed for prague who is jamming
away again
yeah but i think i'd be more more uh
confident in his cat jamming if he plays
h3 this is a very important moment
actually if he doesn't play h3
uh then you know then he he lets black
into the game just a little bit
yeah this is important
is this important i still keep looking
at the game and i wonder if not h3 what
could he
possibly play
could he move the like it's hard to
unless she's struggling to see any other
moves maybe bishop c2 or something but
i'm not sure what i'm accomplishing yeah
but that kind of helps the knight go
where it wants to go anyway i mean it's
possible to go bishop e2 and try to rear
out the bishop to f3 this idea occurred
to me
uh just just now
but it's just not i mean when you
compare this to
how effective it is to open up the king
side which essentially ends the game on
the spot
i i just i don't understand
what else could be that enticing he's
not doing it he's going to go bishop p2
isn't he
or is he going to make your move bishop
situ no i hope not i think bishop c2
does absolutely
absolutely nothing i think if he moves
the bishop
most likely will go to e2
you're such a bad influence on prague
he's gonna play bishop c2 because you
suggested it
what were you saying uh what has he
played
we need
ah he wants bishop takes f5
oh that's very smart actually he wants
bishop takes f5
uh and the idea being if g takes f5 this
is already familiar to us this idea of
queen takes h5 essentially the same
concept that would have happened after
g4 earlier
and if green takes a 5 there's always a
skewer or a pin rather and black still
cannot take on c3 i guess then you go
queen b2
and f6 square is going to be
accessed by white's queen decisively
yeah i mean queen e2 is actually a nice
move we didn't have it on our radar but
once again uh the the idea is the same
to chip away
at that pawn formation once uh he finds
a breakthrough the game will be over for
andre
we don't see apparently the
the clock times i don't know what his
clock time is he still has five moves to
make
i don't know what exactly is going on i
mean
he probably has in the neighborhood of
like a minute i mean he i can't imagine
him having more than
you know more than one or two minutes
i know i mean it feels like an hour ago
when we fought here three minutes right
no it's uh i i don't understand how
he's spending time
ah his pieces are in the way maybe he
just can move his night out
i think it's like one minute right
one
well let's wait will it get to zero
i guess we just have to wait and see or
is it ten minutes
so it's just dropped under a minute
and now queen a2 queen a2 is the key
uh this is i think the reason why prague
played queen e2 the other reason now a7
is undefended and white can access
black's position
through the other side of the board
queen a2
and then you're going to take on a7
and uh
start putting the finishing touches on
the game and i think probably's going to
do that quite quickly
well we have a look uh
at what happens when the queen lands on
a7
yeah i mean first of all if black tries
to restrain white bishop d7 and then
bishop c2
ends the game i mean the knight has to
move now and well after an ic3 queen a7
white doesn't even have to rush
uh first of all this knight on c3 is is
now stranded and the queen can even come
back to a1 and trap the knight
and also black and white can somehow get
the bishop maybe to b5 here
and queen a2 has been played indeed and
prague
not
well i was hoping for g4 so he hasn't
always played the move that we were
expecting
but he's never let go of his winning
advantage and now
we need to uh
coming in with near decisive
force andre
really difficult what do you do um
there isn't much hope and it's so tough
you gotta feel for
for andre who uh
losing the last round game is one of the
most brutal feelings he had a very
decent tournament but so often dania the
the taste
of the last round uh result is the one
that sticks around in your mouth the
longest
yeah i mean i think there's a
there's a term in psychology called the
recency effect
uh which basically says that you you you
remember i mean it's kind of common
sense that you remember
most vividly uh experiences that happen
toward the end
of a general set of experiences the same
goes with
uh you know with with let's say a
university class if the last couple of
lectures
were really really bad and the professor
started kind of phoning it in which i
had in some of my classes you would
really remember that as a bad class even
if the first couple of classes were
really interesting
uh and the same in the tournament like
andre i don't know if he's gaining
rating or losing rating but it really
doesn't matter even if he's gaining
rating
uh you know you just always associate a
tournament based on the last uh round
results and furthermore i've had some
absolutely disastrous tournaments
uh where i managed to win a nice game in
the last round and it almost feels
deceptively like you had a good
tournament it's this weird
sensation like yeah because you won a
single game for sure recently bias it's
also it's funny how it applies across
all levels uh of just sometimes
different people feel differently but
this one i think everyone who's
played competitive just can relate
uh to that feeling as the knight has
dropped back to b6 a7
about to fall
yeah and uh well
jordan
is also trying to nurture that advantage
against sam he's found a way to keep the
game going he has declined the
repetition but let's wait until prague
and
is the panko make time control
i i don't know what products thinking
about you just take a7 within two
seconds
it's a strange moment to be thinking two
moves to go until they make uh the time
control so two moves each and i'm also
not sure what
i i don't say this phrase often as you
know but there's nothing to think about
here you just gotta take it and you
gotta leave yourself with a little bit
of time to make move 40. you know don't
put yourself in a position where you
know
in this situation andre literally has
absolutely nothing but it's another
situation uh this is a common technique
on move 40 to make some complicated move
um and if you haven't left yourself with
quite enough time it can be hard to
adjust to that
yeah and
andre might resign here
i i agree with i mean it's just once
again if we look at the position
uh for black what do you do you have to
probably move the knight and yeah he has
actually dropped the knight back to c8
yeah i mean i guess knight c8 and
potentially
97 and the game the game kind of drags
on um but
it's obvious what the result is going to
be i mean white can choose between queen
b7
uh but i like queen a8 a little bit more
i feel like queen a8 is more uh more
clinical because it prevents the knight
from even escaping to e7 and closing
down the e file not that if that happens
like any
this is still completely winning i mean
now white is simply up in exchange and
black doesn't even have a single pawn
for it
and that's actually queen b7 is what
prague has gone for
yeah that makes sense i think andre is
going to go 97 this is his move 40.
i i think he might go 97 or he might
resign
this is just such a depressing position
yeah i think what he'll do he'll
probably go 97 get the extra 50 minutes
and then spend a little bit of that to
to see if there's really nothing left to
do as we see him make the move 97
but um yeah he's not happy at all he
looks actually
um
devastated
yeah i mean really devastated
and again it's that look of losing the
last round of a tournament
that's that's his expression right now
yeah andre uh he was on plus
one so he'll be finishing on 50 which i
think
yes he will be walking away with a
little rating plus if i'm not mistaken
uh but he doesn't care about that as we
talked about that last round is really
where it's all at
um
and danya shall we very quickly check in
with the two end games and then we'll go
on a break
sure
so
oh i think vidit has just allowed a
trade of rooks which might result in a
winning bishop and game sergey is
actually calculating that right now
um so vida has played bishop b7 this has
permitted the move rook f5
now at first glance this might not seem
like a great move because it gives black
a past h pawn but remember white has two
pawns and as they say in russian this is
the case of trousers
where it might be a situation where
black is incapable of stopping both the
same time even with the aid of the
bishop and white has the very
straightforward maneuver bishop d3
bishop before now because of the trouser
situation any pawn end game is losing
for black because you know the king will
just be unable to handle both pawns by
himself
uh so black has to keep bishops on the
board but that might also be very hard
to do and that might not help so let's
uh
let let's uh kind of develop an
impression of what might happen here
let's see king e7
uh bishop d3 king f6
c5
h5 bishop b4 now this is the critical
moment right black obviously cannot
trade bishops
uh black has to go bishop c8
and uh okay c6
you know let's say h4
uh let's imagine that white plays king
f2 just to be able to always stop the
pawn
after king e5 i think the simplest
winning approach is
to get this king around to g4
and then
to play something like a3 and this is
zugzwan
because if the king walks out to e5
there's king takes g5
h3 f6 h2 no the pawns promote at the
same time but white is winning
because of the abundance of extra pawns
this was not that easy i mean i know we
pl i played these moves very very
quickly but i'm just trying to show uh a
general i'm trying to get a general
impression of how easy it is to win the
bishop end game i can guarantee you that
sergey is going to probably spend
maybe even 30 40 minutes possibly
calculating rook five i wouldn't rule
that out
yeah because i mean if it works uh if
the bishop ending is definitely winning
then he can afford to invest
half now he can even afford to invest
more than that if he can determine for
certain uh that the bishop ending is
winning that's what he's calculating
right now we'll come back here and let's
check in with jordan who as you said
found a way to play on
yeah now jordan is very much in the
driver's seat uh he found a way here
rook c2 king d6 now i've done very
strong with rook c1
uh looks like he just blunders upon but
no he goes after the h1 rook h1 all of a
sudden black loses h6 and once black
loses h6 and g5 also becomes a major
weakness that's out of the question sam
cannot afford to lose his kingside pawn
so he goes back to b6 but that's a very
serious concession i mean the point of
rp6 is to defend laterally the pawn on
h6 taking the sting out of rook h1 here
sam will have king e5
but that's not the problem the problem
is that he's allowed the move before
jordan has built up this pawn chain
which largely eliminates black's queen
side counter play
and leaves sam with only one approach
here which is just to stay put and do
nothing and hope that his fortress is
going to hold but we all know that that
is not the you know that does not
inspire one with confidence rook c7 king
d6
and my guess is that jordan will
continue trying you know many different
types of attempts here i'm not sure that
he has a clear plan of victory i'm not
sure that his position is even winning
not sure that there is
uh
a plan that involves making progress but
jordan has a million ways that he can
try to be tricky he can go rook c1 he
can bring his king up to g3 and you know
one idea involves trying to push the
f-pawn forward to f4 in order to gain
more real estate for the king
this is a completely thankless defensive
task for mr shankland
and
at this point they must be exhausted on
top of everything else for sure and you
know that you just have to
sit and
especially here it really is a complete
passive defense you're not going to do
anything active you just have to sit
wait and see if urethane can come up
with something here we'll be spending a
lot of time to make something work we'll
come back here as well
um let's see if the let's quickly go
back to prague and then i think we'll go
on a break and leave you prague on the
camera with with his board
i guess played h4
solidifying the pawn on g5
which is a totally sensible idea because
the queen was aiming at the g5 pawn
black is simply in zugzwang i mean
there's just no moves i think that's
essentially prague's point i mean maybe
king f8 is the only thing that fly can
do here
and now the simplest way to win is to
maneuver the bishop to g1 and then to f3
and then perhaps centralize it on d5
and put the finishing touch
on the game i would not have the
patience to continue this game for black
i would resign here
and well now that his the time control
has been reached this is the first
moment where andre really has
some time so we will leave him to it we
will go on a quick break and then we
will be back with the remainder of the
action here
from the tata steel chess tournament
we'll see you soon
[Music]
the first time i came here in was 2017
where i played the c group and then 2019
i played the very good and now this is
my third time here
yeah it's a great opportunity for me
because you know i can
i can learn a lot from these games and
i'm really looking forward to this
you know to have fun and
interesting games
i started to work with engine like
pretty late
after i became an
i am and mostly seriously after i became
a junior
i sometimes think over the board and try
to you know find human ideas
and also use computer as well
i use technology and as well as you know
use books and
and see in a chess book i don't think
computer will solve just like um for now
definitely
and maybe later like they could solve
but for now i think uh
just won't be solved
i'm looking forward to play against
magnus in a classical game but also
other players like
karwana and
all the others as well
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the last round of the tata steel jazz
tournament and dania we have uh three
games remaining one of them
well actually karjakin made his decision
a lot faster than than we expected so
maybe let's jump back in
in there
yeah just feeling very confident in the
bishop end game
and you know for good reason i mean he's
just very good at evaluating these types
of positions
i mean he's very experienced in the end
game in general
uh and deciding that
he's done enough calculation
deciding against uh you know spending
too much time and trusting his instincts
which uh probably will pay off and i i
think it's winning i i wouldn't
necessarily trust the evil bar 100
uh because sometimes it isn't very good
at detecting fortresses
but if i had to venture a guess
i would say that
white must be winning here i mean these
two past pawns are too far apart and
they're too far advanced
uh and they're too hard to contain
and the h pawn is too innocuous i think
all of these factors put together should
give wine enough to
win the game yeah also i think just the
fact that uh the sergey karjakin in
these positions is such a great
calculator he's done the work for us and
i think we should just
i trust him unless vidit can prove us
otherwise he's played king f6
um
and yeah this is going down the line you
showed us uh just before the break
i mean i think that it's definitely
gonna go h5 there's nothing to lose from
this move
um and i think we're going to see
bishop
or or maybe king e5 maybe king e5 should
be thrown in private bishop e4
now by the way bishop takes d4 f takes
e4 again the pawns are unstoppable c6
and f6 is coming
so bishop c8 c6
um and there's a cute line if you go
king d6
i think you lose after f6 because if you
now go king e6 there's bishop f5 check
very nice move very cute and uh
skewering the bishop and if you take it
then you allow the pawn to promote so
one of these things is going to happen
i'm pretty sure either in the next five
moves or once sergey arranges his pieces
better
i'm just not
i i
find it extremely hard to believe that
vivid can survive this
yeah and uh well this one seems to be
winning for for sega video of course he
is going to try and find something uh
but we seem to have gone down the most
logical lines
we'll come back here see what he can
come up with but for now uh let's go
back to pragnanda
uh against siesepanko
where we are also in the very very final
stages of the game
oh yeah i mean prague his technique has
not been the most convincing i mean if
he had gone g4 the game would have been
over 15 minutes ago
um but he at the same time has not
relinquished even the shred of his
winning but he was always completely
winning
and you know that's ultimately when you
judge technique it's not just like okay
did you find the most accurate and
fastest path to victory
did you at any point relinquish your
decisive advantage and give your
opponent concrete chances and the answer
to that also has been no
um is the penguin bishop b6 attacking
the c4 pawn which he does want to take
uh and
queen a6 is the computer recommendation
which is a logical move
defending c4 and pressuring the pawn on
d6 doing two things at once
uh i like this more than playing a move
like bishop d3 which of course is also
winning
but this allows queen a5
and this is exactly how
problems
start to occur it always starts with
allowing a little bit of activity and
then
you get a headache
you know and then the knight comes out
to e5 so you certainly don't want to
allow queen a5 if possible
so queen a6 a lot of purposes defending
the pawn stopping the black queen
and
and black with every move is so
difficult let's see the queen a6
what can black
well previously panko really like all
the pieces are so passive that variation
we just saw with queen a5
uh still winning for white but at least
there's some hope at least there is some
pieces coming to life
yeah i mean here i guess queen c7 and
then bishop a4 bishop b5 is a good
maneuver to
take the load off of the queen
no but black just gets completely pushed
off the board so let's say the bishop
comes to b5
um and then you know there's even a move
like bishop e8 check at the right moment
you know one of these tactics is going
to win white the game it's very hard to
say in such situations
exactly how it's going to end the game
it's going to depend on how black
decides to go back and forth
different methods of going back and
forth
allow white to win the game in different
ways if that makes sense some of them
you might respond with rook d1 and go
after the d-pawn for example if black
decides to play knight g8 for whatever
reason you know
then okay the d6 pawn is incredibly weak
we can go after it with rook d1
so the way in which white actually
delivers the finishing blow
direct directly depends on how black
arranges his pieces but there is it
there's no question that there will be
such a blow that's not under under any
kind of doubt
yeah and prague while we've seen him
take his time i think he's not going to
rush this and also now the adrenaline
the adrenaline from the first time
control is coming down a little bit you
have time to
maybe take a quick stroll between the
the boards and just calm down sit back
at
the board and then
figure out how to convert this he's done
everything great
so far i don't think he'll let this one
go but we'll come back here let's see if
jordan van ferece has found any way to
to make
uh any progress
yeah well
not really
not really so far so he's gone before
rook c7 back to c3 no i mean that's just
not much has happened yet
oh yeah sorry i didn't didn't see that
we had the board opened yeah no i mean
basically nothing is happening we last
uh looked at this position and jordan
just
went back to c3 but apparently the
reason i say not really
is because sam has a very interesting
defensive resource here which might be
the saving grace that he needs and that
is the move a5
trying
uh to trade
as many queen side pawns
as possible b takes a five the point is
you go rook b5 and obviously the pawn
cannot be defended
uh and why is this a good trade for
black because
after for example c one rook takes a
five
uh black is already poised to take on a3
and
he will have a pass pawn of his own and
it's gonna be an outside pass but so if
white goes down the aforementioned route
of rook h1 or takes a3 uh rook takes h6
check king c5 i feel like black's past
spawn
uh should give him enough counter play
to
secure the draw but the engine actually
likes an even different move
the engine likes the rook a4
after rook takes h6 king c5 the point
is that you're attacking the g4 pawn
right
okay well what happens if white defends
it well if white defends it then and
only then do you take on a3 creating a
very very nasty pin down the third
rank so this is an even improved
even more improved version of
uh the immediate rook takes a3 very
sneaky yeah
just as i say that has played a5 just as
i say that he's got a5 good stuff by
shankland he is
very very close to holding this game but
it is clear that a lot of work is still
going to be required if jordan continues
to play in the most testing way and they
are playing quite fast so urine has
captured
uh on
on their a5 rook b5
and will the question is do we have to
go rook c1 what if the works today is on
c3 stays defending the a3 pawn is there
any other way we can try and
make progress
yeah i mean the question i guess the
question
here is like i mean where in which area
of the board are you even going to try
to make progress and to me the h6 pawn
is really the only target here i
mentioned previously the idea of trying
to go f4 but
i i don't think this is going to work
here although you can try you can go
king g3 then you can go bishop b4
and let's say sam goes b5 trying to
facilitate the trade
of these pawns then you can go f3
or even even here you can try to go f4
but the point i'm trying to make is that
even in the event of a trade
i'm not entirely sold on the fact that
this benefits white because black has
the threat of bishop takes g4 of course
sam has to tread very very carefully in
these types of positions but he's got
plenty of time to do it with
i think his chances of drawing are
higher than my chances of winning but
not by like that much i think it's
probably around 70 30.
and some really i mean in these
positions we talked about it i think
almost every day he's such a calculating
beast he's worked so hard on that
amongst others which is with his coach
jacob ragari who anush was referencing
earlier uh today
and yeah we'll see jordan rook c1
swinging that to h1
seems to be the main try
uh but we'll come back here
let's bring back the bird's eye view for
a second as you're then contemplating
what to do next
yeah i mean this is going to be a very
very long end game so buckle buckle in
maybe karayakin is where we should go
back to because that looks to be
very close to uh
that one that one is over yeah i mean
this game is going to end in the next
couple of minutes
um
yeah because again if king d6 then i've
already pointed out the winning line and
it's f6 this is this line with king e6
bishop f5 check
um so black can't do that
black can't do that because of bishop b7
and notice also the pawn on a4 is the
right color pawn so you don't even have
to worry about preserving f3
um
and also finally
bishop a6
i guess what is the winning plan here
let me think
it's not so easy like you can play king
f2
bishop c8 king g3
bishop a6
oh there's a beautiful idea here f for
check
if king takes e4 there's f6 and trousers
you promote the pawn and what about
after bishop a6 could we have gone uh
bishop c6
at the start of the well then bishop
back to c8 and then we've made f
yep
right you have to go back to e4
so up for check g takes f4
yeah king h4 and and you win i mean the
bishop is untouchable because of f6
and because of that
the pawn
is also not going to progress very far
and white just plays king h5 team g6 and
then f6 f7 i think sergey has spotted
this idea
very nice i mean this f4 is such a nice
touch and it looks like he is uh
going towards that i think we should
probably stick around here what do you
think dania
yeah i think that vidit
he's got to go with one of these back
and forth moves i mean king f6
is another possibility
but here i think white plays king before
and essentially the point is that
black okay black plays bishop a6 now
then the king is already making it to c5
h4 king b6
bishop c8 bishop b7 and white is in time
h3
bishop c8h2
bishop e6 h1c8 and obviously black can
resign here there's no perpetual to
speak of
uh but uh
for that reason black cannot allow white
to get the king to c5 and so black has
to go h4
but what is the drawback of the move h4
well it weakens the g4 square
and how can white access it well i can
simply drop the king back remember that
white is in no hurry black can't do
anything now black has to go back and
forth again
the king walks all the way around to g4
and what is this all
what is this all leading up to well it's
all leading up to the move f4
which uh severs the connection between
the two pawns king takes f4
then you're going to walk back you're
going to take the pawn on h4 and finally
now that you fully dispense with
all of the counter play you're going to
conduct the final stage of the plan
which in one way or another
involves
getting the bishop from d5 to e6
and then simply promoting
uh the pawn so this is an approximation
of how i think the game is going to what
what i think the game is going to look
like i think it's not unlikely that they
do this yeah dania do you think there's
a chance that sergey karjakin
had sort of
seen all of this when he went into the
bishop ending
yes and no i mean i think he he probably
understood intuitively that there's just
no way that black can preserve the
fortress here
and and i guess that he maybe saw the
beautiful idea of going f4 check in
order to pave
uh the path for the king toward h4 i
think that he saw
but exactly
the nitty-gritty like how is he going to
execute the king walks and when is he
going to play up for that i think maybe
he relied on his intuition
um and you know one time out of a
hundred you'll get to such an end game
and it will actually turn out to be a
fortress
but but there's too many sources of
of issues for black i mean these
positions are
you know there there literally is one
time out of a hundred that a position
like this is going to be drawn and
sergey believes in that and uh he's got
every reason
uh and and he's going to be correct i
mean his intuition is going to be proven
right
i mean so let's not forget uh back in
his day the youngest grandmaster ever
he's been around
for so long so experienced such a great
uh calculator and yeah provided
a tough tough and to the tournament he
is still trying uh of course to to find
ways but
i think i mean dania where in this game
maybe we can quickly go back once again
to the very early stages um and i'll ask
you for those uh there we still have 15
000 fears so for anyone who might have
just joined us now maybe you can
pinpoint once again the moment where you
felt it started going wrong for it yeah
i mean sergey deciding on the most
risk-free opening possible and you know
aiming for nothing but a the tiniest of
potential advantages
but this is not this is a task that it
should have been up to i mean
he missed you know the first
clear-cut draw that he missed was here i
mean this is really the moment that
started it all and i want to emphasize
that the move that he played doesn't
technically
change the evaluation i think according
to some people in the chat it's still
0.0
i don't care about that the fact of the
matter is that the move that he played
makes this task a lot harder from a
practical standpoint because it narrows
the path of the drawing this is what i
want to emphasize the computer doesn't
think of a draw
of a drawing path as being narrow or
wide right because the computer just
sees the correct move but for a human it
is important to have more of a margin
for error it is important to have a
situation where not just one move in
every position yields the draw the
computer doesn't care about that kind of
situation but humans do that kind of
situation leads to more errors and
blunders so to get to the actual
drawing move the move is bishop f5
and after rook b7 it looks like black
loses a pawn and he dies but after
bishop c2 rook takes c7
i think vivid stopped his calculation
here concluding that because of the fork
this is very very nasty but the saving
grace is the move bishop e4 which poses
white with an ultimatum either
take on a7
and yes you're going to have an extra
pawn but this is going to be a dead draw
because of the rook's ideal placement as
well as the pawns being totally and
completely damaged
so either go for that and that's a draw
or if you want to take the bishop be my
guest but now your h4 pawn is hanging
and obviously this is a dead draw
as well so that's what started it all he
had
several other chances throughout the end
game
uh which you know
i will of which i will only pinpoint one
and fiona this to me signifies just
total collapse this this to me signifies
mental collapse i mean i just feel like
vidit after yesterday's game his his
will was a little bit broken and under a
different set of circumstances i think
he would have found the drawing line
that starts with rook c6 bishop a4 rook
b6 you have to induce bishop a4
so that you could go rook before with
tempo
and then you walk your king up to d6 and
you're basically surrounding the c4 pawn
and ultimately you're going to win it
vidit went the opposite direction going
king d8 simply giving the pawn up for
nothing
and uh you know
sergey just continued improving his
position
ultimately until
well until he had a chance to trade
rooks which he correctly determined was
a winning winning end game
and that's how it happened
yeah and i think uh for all of us some
is that actually on the board
no no no
a force on the board of video continues
to burn clock here trying to find
something
i think uh really an instructive uh game
this one for all of us watching
for vidiq i mean you've mentioned it a
couple of times this collapse and i i
think even today's game very
likely wouldn't have gone the way it did
if it wasn't for yesterday's painful
blunder and forbid it well we just have
to hope that he can recover
uh in time
uh before he starts playing his next
event which is coming up in only uh four
days dania what would you recommend um
what do you think vidic should do
in these three four games uh three four
days that he has in between
the next event which is also hugely
hugely important
well i guess vinnie won't have time to
travel back home he's going to travel
straight to the tournament site but it
sounds corny
but i think you know he needs to spend
some time with his friends particularly
as chess playing friends maybe do some
light analysis maybe play some blitz
and have fun you know what i would like
what i and i've been in this situation
before now i would never presume
uh to give someone a vivid caliber
advice um he doesn't need it and he
should be the one giving me advice but
in so far as i've had experiences
playing two consecutive tournaments i
remember having the worst tournament of
my life uh the us championship in 2016.
i scored three and a half out of 11 last
place and right after that
uh part of the participants four of the
participants five sorry five of the
participants of the us championship we
were just at each other's throats we
pack our bags and we travel as a team to
armenia from st louis 24-hour journey to
play the world team championship where
we're now part of a team so not only do
we have to switch psychologically we
were just playing each other now we have
to play as a team but i just had the
worst tournament of my life and now i
have to perform for team usa
you know what did i do
you know i just tried to spend as much
time as i could with my teammates uh you
know i forced sam shanklin to play blitz
with me you know i forced sam shankly to
do some opening analysis me just to
basically my ultimate goal was to remind
myself why i'm playing chess in the
first place and
uh you know what my identity is kind of
as a chess player was to to get back to
the to the basics
uh and again just to fill myself with a
little bit more love because what can
happen when you have a tournament like
this is you just run out of passion you
run out of enthusiasm and that's what
starts the tilt train then you have
another bad tournament and and at that
point you're just playing with a
complete lack of zen and a complete lack
of passion so those kinds of things
whether it's blitz or light opening
analysis with friends or just not
looking at a chess board for two days
vidit's going to have to develop a c and
seriously think about how he wants to
plan the next couple of days and i'd be
very very interested to see whether he
is in fact successful and i think he's
got every chance to be i know him pretty
well
i think he's going to he's going to do a
great job and he's going to emerge a lot
stronger in the next tournament of
course it's uh also a hugely personal
decision but i i like what he was saying
about reigniting the flames sort of why
do why do i love this game and vidiq is
still thinking danya so i think we have
a moment to go to nintze's interview and
hear what he had to say after his draw
against duda
[Music]
neil scrandelius he just played a draw
with uh chris of duda that was quite an
enterprising game
yeah we had some more fun than some of
the others at least that's for sure
um
bishop to hd7 was it your last resort to
to keep the game going yeah to be honest
i had missed this idea he had that he
can just play f6 and let me take his
bishop on g5 and after this i thought i
should be doing quite quite badly
so it was a very easy decision to go for
bishop take g7 i thought it's like it's
interesting uh
attacking chances at least maybe he can
survive but if i don't do it then i'm
just lost i guess but then when he
thought for a long time i actually
realized that not only is it like quite
scary but it's maybe there is even no
defense uh but then he took on b two
and this was for sure a critical moment
because i have three reasonable moves
king b1 king takes b2 as i did and also
take it with the bishop and
it's such a complicated choice because
the lines like king b1 or king takes b2
it looks almost the same but 15 moves
later it makes a huge difference but
it's not clear which one is the is the
best try so finally i went for king
takes b2 after which i think what we did
was more or less forced so it was just a
draw so
yeah i have to find out after
in the analysis of king b1 or bishop
takes is anything for me but uh i have
no idea
um i think that was not your first
sicilian with well you i think you
played some with blacks and with white
um
you you're looking for for for fun
against uh these top players
yeah definitely like i'm going like
normally i also have for instance some
more calm options in my reporter i have
bishop b5 check i sometimes play the
alapin
i mean solid systems
uh but coming here i mean there it
doesn't really make any sense to me to
not go for the for the sharpest and the
most fun stuff so uh definitely open
sicilian is what i'm here to do
and how do you look back at the
tournament
well for me it's kind of a bit in two
parts yeah the first
part before the first rest day
which i scored a whole photo for which
was absolutely horrible
but then i told you i remember in the
interview that i was thinking of it as a
completely new tournament with nine
rounds the last nine and then our last
nine they are
i mean quite decent i think i scored
minus one or something i mean a fairly
normal result and also the games have
not been that bad so second how if i'm
allowed to exclude the first part
i'm it's okay it's fine that's
unfortunately that's not allowed
and um what's your plan for the for the
next months are there any tournaments
you're going to play
yeah the first one is that i'm going to
play actually a match with david howell
in london
it's going to be quite fun in about a
month and after that there is the
european championship in slovenia so
lots of chess for me as always
can you tell me more about this match
with david
it's just a match
i don't know exactly what to play we
will play classical games i think 10.
so it's quite a long match quite a
serious one it will be played in london
at the beginning of march i think no not
all details are like settled or official
yet but uh
definitely something that
that i'm looking forward to try
okay well all the best thank you very
much thank you
[Music]
sorry
might be coming to an end but chess in
february is not coming to an end to
remember that 24 of the top players in
the world
start their fight for qualification to
the 22 candidates at
this year's fide grand prix catch ding
giri nakamura and others battle for the
right to play magnus grand prix returns
february 3rd with coverage here on
chess.com
[Music]
do
hello and welcome back to the final
round of this tata steel just tournament
and we are going to return where we left
it off in this end game between sergey
karyakin and videt gujarati and danya
segay not exactly going down the path
that we had
expected no although i mean he's putting
the finishing touches and there's
multiple ways of doing that ultimately
his goal is to get the king to g4 the
question is how to do that
and he's just made a seemingly cryptic
move king h2
um you might ask why didn't he play king
h3 well the reason is that black plays
king f4 and now it's kind of like white
is the one
in in in zug song now i think sergey
forgot about a really cool resource that
he has in this position which is bishop
b7
and this does win for white because
after bishop takes b7 again you play f6
this is a familiar idea and a bishop
takes f5 the king drops back to g2 and
white promotes now this is not the only
way to win and what sergey decided to do
is go king h2
this essentially forces zugzwan
because
black has a bunch of black has two
choices either king f6 or bishop a6 if
bishop a6 then white can play king h3
and king f4 is no longer possible due to
f6 so sergey using zooxvan
in order to get
uh potentially the king to g4 but now
he's getting his bishop all the way back
to f1
so i think he's embarking on a slightly
different approach i think he's going to
put his bishop on h3 not his king on h3
then he's going to walk his king back
around
and he's going to go for f4 in a
slightly different version so
everything essentially leads to the same
target bishop takes f5 obviously
impossible because of bishop h3
this is totally resignable and uh once
again king d6 there's always going to be
f6 exquisite technical effort by
karjakin this is one of many ways to win
this game
very nice so let's actually try and go
down that line and
see what black can do if the white
bishop lands on h3 and the king starts
coming over
first of all if you play bishop b7 white
has the immediate f6 followed by bishop
h3 this ends the game on the spot again
the pawn is the right corner color
which is very important obviously so
black has to stay on f6 between f6 and
e5 with the king after bishop h3 again
you can't move your king because of f6
so now you have to move your bishop and
here comes white's king yeah here
here oh and the easiest you don't even
have to play a four you don't even have
to play four you just go king b4
king c5
and thinking b6 just got a7 b8 this
bishop is perfectly
uh holding down everything and as soon
as the king moves you go f6 yeah no
that's it that's that's the winning
construction and sergey is going down
that path very very quickly
yeah i think it will resign any second
he decided on this plan
and uh he's playing out all his moves
very quickly he knows what he's doing
the bishop has landed
and now the king starts the journey oh
and look at this this is the russian
school of chess first make sure the
bishop is on a defended score is this
necessary no
is this russian school of chess yes make
sure the bishop is defended every screw
is tightened and now
walk the king all the way to b8 that it
will resign right here and right now i
mean you can see just the way that he's
making his moves it's pro forma he
will stop the clock any second
yeah sergey not wasting a single more
sec a single second he wants to eat
it is local time it is almost five
five o'clock so it's this weird in
between of it's not really lunch it's
not really dinner but uh in just under
two hours the players are invited here
there will be some finger food being
served in the playing hall in just under
two hours before the closing ceremony
which will be uh streamed live by the
way so you'll be able to watch the
closing ceremony tonight
is going to resign right now
it's going to you're going to stop the
clock i don't know what it is that
there's nothing to think about here it's
over like the king just walks to b8
goodbye
yeah he is out of maybe inertia or
something the bishop is going back and
forth but
karjakin on his journey
uh over to the queen side
and i
i mean you can't move your king ever
because of f6 and this h pawn is just
not fast enough
so but it is
thinking here but
it's it's
over yeah and i mean i i see some
comments in the chat why is he not
resigning i think
uh
it's just
nobody can relate what it's like to be
in the player's shoes in this position
it's not just today's game which for
sure will be a disappointment uh but
visited all the previous games there
maybe the blunder from yesterday the
loss to prague that might all be playing
at the back of his mind
and for goodness sake he's a human being
i mean you know how would how would you
put yourself in
invited shoes i mean you lose three
three games out of four
um you feel terrible
yeah you're gonna play a little bit
longer than maybe you should but you
gotta feel for the guy and you know it's
not always just all about being robotic
you know sometimes you just feel
emotionally
and you react emotionally that's okay i
mean bitted is a class act he's he's not
doing this out of malice he's doing this
because he's upset
and
under a different set of circumstances
yes he would have resigned ten moves ago
that is true
and you can just see the disappointment
um
on his face this is
the worst possible way that the
tournament could end for him we talked
about ending on a loss being tough
ending on two losses
um
oh he's ending on three well he had the
draw against magnus but before the
draw against magnus he had the
incredibly disappointing loss to prague
yeah so he's ending on
two losses half out of the last
four games and hopefully as we mentioned
earlier hopefully he can regroup he has
a few days
and uh bounced back over the board which
is the best way to bounce back so
hopefully that's what um that's what he
will do
yeah and i can guarantee right now he's
not thinking about the position on the
board he's thinking about his tournament
he's thinking about
uh you know the the games that he that
he let slip maybe the game against mommy
dj
all of that is sort of coming together
in a very nasty cocktail of thoughts
and yeah at this point i'm
okay
i think he's just king you do king f7
f6
h3 oh i see what bit at once he wants uh
he wants this actually f6h3 that's kind
of a funny idea but surrogate doesn't
have to play f6 just i was just gonna
say i think he's just gonna keep walking
not allow even the slightest although
even that line was winning for white
completely peggy says i'm not interested
no thanks
nope he wants king a7 king v8 and then
c8 equals queen
and now really and there is the the
resignation yep
a tough game and result forwarded but
kudos to sergey karjakin who ends uh
his tournament on a win
with some really beautiful end game
technique
and never relinquishing the the pressure
on vidit so two games remain we're gonna
bring back the bird's eye view and see
is jordan making progress what's
happening in prague's game uh we're
spoiler spoiler dania the queens have
come up and we were not impressed with
that during the break
no i mean prague is really really over
complicating the the technical task
he is still winning
uh handily and he should be able to win
this but
he's taking a very very long time here
and and he's just not playing with a
high degree of confidence
as he
you know he ultimately accepted as he
panko's offer to trade queens
uh which
okay i mean i can understand why he did
that and again this is completely
winning still but
you know he's got to work a little bit
harder now at breaking black's
uh kind of fortress-like construction
black doesn't have an actual fortress
uh but but he yes pango has has
amazingly built something that is not
that easy to break down which is saying
a lot in the position that he had and at
this point prague should probably go
uh bishop a4
and set up the move bishop e8 against
bishop take c4 that would be one way to
start it would at least tie down black's
bishop to f7 and then maybe you could
reposition the rook to e1 and try to get
this bishop to e8 all the same one way
or another he's got to keep poking and
prodding
until yessipanko's construction kind of
collapses
and maybe we can go back a few moves
here and explain why
we are shocked that we are even in this
position with no queens on the board and
prague still having some work to do
we got here from this position where
daniel we thought it was over
yeah and i mean the move g4 would have
basically forced resignation
uh because it crashes through you can't
take with either pawn if you take with
the f pawn after queen e3 you get
checkmated you know and the only thing
you called if you i think prague was
worried about bishop descent there's
literally nothing to worry about you
just take f5
and then there's one check and then
there's no more checks in black and
resigned prague
he's done this at several points
throughout the tournament he just hasn't
demonstrated quite the the instinct
that he needs yeah we have an interview
let's go to sega
circa koryakin you just beat fitted with
the white pieces in a game that
might have been much longer than you
actually expected
yes i went to the lion where black needs
to play a few precise moves
to make a draw actually magnus already
played bishop 2 instead of rookie 5 and
i think it's
quite an easy draw but
black has to remember it and
when he mixed it up then i think he got
to some problems and later on it was
already very important for him yeah you
were playing quite fast uh phillip was
like taking his time and i said so i
feel like okay like he can at some point
you guys will just agree to a draw or
something oh well actually he offered me
a draw something like on move 10 or
something but i thought okay
if you want to draw just show the line
and okay but if you just offer it's not
so nice
um
were there any particular moments
that come to mind in this game like
um
well
rookie five is i think it's a big
inaccuracy and then later on
i believe black had
some uh
some way to
almost equalize but
actually i didn't see how he should play
how he should secure and draw and
then i think that he blundered
this idea with c4 and rook a5 and when i
won a pound uh of course it's it's very
unpleasant for him and
uh then he lost him
um on the internet i saw a lot of
comments about the quick draws that you
played in this tournament like do you
have any reaction to that
oh well actually i
when i
play a tournament i
don't even think to
to think what people say
in internet but
i i just uh
in some games i thought that i'm not in
best mood and even today i didn't feel
i'm in a good mood because yesterday i
played just
one of the worst games in my life and
i don't know how i managed to recover
after this
um
this is like a tournament for you that
helps you to get in shape for the
candidates tournaments um
how do you
look back at at this event in vacancy
and how would your chances in the
candidates
i have no ideas
first of all we don't have all the
players at the moment so we are waiting
for the grand prix to be played and
then i'll start my preparation i hope to
play to play better there than here
uh
let's see
and are you happy with with the outcome
of the tournament here i can say well
plus one is basically is not a disaster
so
it's not so bad because i i again after
yes yesterday's game i was
almost close to say i i quit chess so
i was very very upset but whiskey cola
helped me
yeah of course
otherwise i would like
is
is alcohol a good good friend in on
those days oh no not much actually
but
just to get a nice mutant
and to go here to go on
was it hard to to wake up at 12 or like
we started two hours early
oh well actually
yes
actually my wife came to me and we went
to amsterdam and
we were like walking a lot and drinking
and having some fun and then of course
it was very difficult to wake up than to
take taxi to come here and so on and so
on
but i managed
amazing
any party tonight
of course
okay i'll see you there
thank you
very good kyrie i he is ready to party
tonight and it's crazy dania i mean this
is what we were talking about how much
one game can change your mood can change
your tournament
yesterday sergey was close to quitting
chess and look at him smiling today
laughing life is good again
yeah life is great again i mean this is
such a confidence boost to end the
tournament like that and he ends on plus
one
uh and and like you said not a disaster
far from a disaster and and it's just
the tournament it should feel so much
different when you end the tournament on
a win like this against the 2700 plus
opponent
um the loss is forgotten and uh there
will be celebration
tonight for sure maybe another trip to
amsterdam
and i mean amsterdam is only 30 minutes
away right
amsterdam is 30 minutes away right yeah
it's very close uh half an hour so
i wouldn't be surprised they seem to be
have at they seem to have had a great
time in amsterdam and uh what's they're
not like one of the most beautiful
cities in the world yeah
yeah big fan of amsterdam
and
well meanwhile prague he has brought the
king to
f4
and still the question how exactly will
he break through
yeah well uh he's putting the pieces in
place
uh one by one he's gotten the king
to an optimal location
this again this really depends on how
andre chooses to
position his knight i mean probably
andre is going to keep his bishop on e6
i mean if knight b6 happens the win
comes immediately okay seven check and
rook g7
um
probably yeah sepenko should go like
king d8 and then king back to c7 and
hole try to hold the position like that
and i'm not seeing exactly where the win
is honestly i i don't see exactly where
it is what if we now go bishop a4
and
right to try to meet king c7 of the 58
yeah but now i'll take the pawn
although i guess you can try to get your
bishop you can try to sack the pawn to
get your bishop to c6 and then maybe
even get it to b7 somehow but it's a
little bit tenuous i'm not totally uh
enamored by this prospect i guess here
you can go rook b1 and try to go rook b7
that actually might be the winning plan
so
i'm thinking that that's what i should
try to do is to get the b7 is the
vulnerable square so maybe white didn't
start with rugby one
and um
if black continues with king c7
yeah maybe maybe bishop a4 now
okay so let's say bishop f7 to stop
bishop b8
yeah something like bishop b5 this this
looks like a good anchor point for the
bishop as well
in one way or another white's going to
get in there i mean white's going to go
rook a1 rook a6 or even
bishop a68
yeah you can absolutely go bishop a6 i
mean magnus doesn't believe in
fortresses and
this is really what he means i mean of
course that phrase is
is kind of over generalized and it's i
think it's over over uh overused over
quoted but but
the essential meaning of it is that in
such a situation there are so many
attempts at breaking the fortress
that with only two minor pieces
it really to me is only a question of
time before one thing or another thing
ultimately manifests itself prague i
think is going to take the full point
here even if it's going to take him a
very very long time and i'm sure in a
way when you're in this pango but
part of you feels hopeful that maybe
there will be some chances and i think
well at least if i'm in that spot part
of me feels
i wish he had just finished it off
before the the time scramble rather than
have me here suffering in a game that i
know is 99.9
uh likely
for me to lose anyway
yeah i mean suffering is the the only
way to describe it and
yeah daniel sorry we should go back to
the other
game where you're doing look at that
some big big progress has been made
[Music]
apparently a blunder by sam now let's
see he's gone rook a5 that move makes
sense to me actually
that move makes sense to me
um and the reason that it makes sense to
me if we just
if we just ignore the computer evolve
for just one second i think sam's idea
is to meet rook b8 with the move rook b5
and what sam is saying is that yes i'm
down two pawns but look at this passport
on b4 that pawn is rumbling down the
board really really quickly but i think
he's miscalculated and i think
this end game according to the engine is
actually winning for white
so bishop e4
all right well sam would probably go b3
king f3 b2
oh and the king just comes over to e3
just in time and if bishop c4
then you drop your bishop back to b1
okay so this is the important part
this end game fiona is winning for white
this is not intuitive if you think about
it this pawn on b2 is a dangerous pawn
if you ever trade bishops why i could
end up being losing but but this is
actually just a winning end game the
pawns are essentially unstoppable so for
example king e6
uh king d4
and uh actually white can combine the
threat of going king c3
with the idea of
um
with the idea of pushing the pawns at
the right moment so if bishop b2 that
white bush is the pawn
if bishop g4 white goes back to c3 and
white wins the pawn on b2 so in reality
this pawn is more we more of a weakness
than a strength now it's up to jordan to
correctly evaluate the move and he
didn't once g5 b3 he's still winning
though it looks looks like he's still
winning
does he still go behind the pawn does he
keep pushing the g pawn what's this well
according to the engine the move is g6
and the line it goes as follows b2 rook
g8
uh sorry rig b8
and i don't know no but now it's very
simple rook b5 you you just take on v5
and then you go g7 and you're completely
winning here you're just two pawns up
and black's king is in
is in huge trouble as well so this i
don't understand so g6 what does sam
want
yeah no b2
rook b8
if you cover with the bishop then
either well probably you don't want to
go g7 but here just bishop b4 followed
by g7 and jordan i think he's just
pushed to spawn no sam has sam has lost
his mind here i mean which is
understandable i mean defending this for
as long as sam has
is unbelievably difficult and
sam has miscalculated something but
whatever it is he has
hallucinated and he's going to lose this
game most likely shall we go back a
little bit and uh and see where it went
wrong try and understand where it went
wrong for some so around this moment i
actually was quite optimistic for sam's
position i mean jordan repeats moves
once but gutsy decision he goes rook 27.
sam pushes to spawn this is all correct
b5b4
okay so this is the critical moment here
he had to go b3
and the reason sam rejected it i think
is because of this position i think sam
just forgot
about a very important concept here
which is to play king not c7 not king c7
because then the rook has the b4 square
no king c5
and if white pushes g5
here you can blockade with bishop f5 and
white is a very very hard time making
progress here white just has no moves i
mean look at this position and if white
bites his time sam could anchor the
bishop to the other pawn but this can be
a hard position to evaluate correctly
uh if white doesn't play g5 then the
bishop could intercept the rook with
bishop b5
i i feel like sam probably looked at
this position and concluded that since
he cannot really push his pawn any
further he must be lost but it turns out
that after after bishop f5 white simply
cannot make any progress because all of
white's spawns are incredibly weak and
most importantly a fight pushes king g3
there's b2
giving away the last pawn and then
picking off the bishop with bishop e4
that is another incredible detail but
rather than that sam trying to
preemptively intercept the rook and it
is backfiring spectacularly they are
following this line and sam will lose
this game momentarily
and i mean as you're saying it's not a
surprise to at some point the focus
is just uh jordan i think that's so
brilliantly keeping the pressure up we
thought this might end in a repetition
hours ago but jordan just kept finding
ways uh to ask more questions try and
use that extra pawn and it is paying off
here as rook b5 is on the board
and uh well we expect heard and to
capture and then just run his own pawn
and rook b5 is on the board as well
yeah now okay i'm exaggerating not
momentarily
uh not momentarily
because after g7 b1 queen and first of
all bishop b4 here
has to be considered
but i don't think that it's good because
after king e7 it's probably a draw black
skin gets to f6 in time
no no more trousers yeah not enough pant
legs but after g7 v1 queen g8 i'm sure
i'm 100 sure this is winning for white
and the engine confirms that just
because okay white is up two pawns so
most queen trades are going to be
winning for white
on top of that black's king is in huge
trouble like queen fei check we need six
check and white can just simply push the
d pawn when given the opportunity no i
mean this is i don't see sam defending
this uh for for too long i just don't
see it happening
i mean it's a kind of uh not ironic i
don't know what the word is but we have
just seen the interview with karjakin
who yesterday he said that loss against
some was one of the worst uh games of
his life
then bouncing back today
ending the tournament on a smile
and for sam it's gonna be the the exact
opposite yesterday he was delighted i
mean
you don't get a win in in under 30 moves
against the karjakin or player of his
caliber very often
but today
is going to be tough sam is one of the
the other players one of the many
players who is playing in the grand prix
as well
but not the first leg i believe
sam just made like a werewolf he just
made like a
a face of somebody who
i feel like i missed it out of his seat
and
it was really funny i think people in
the chat noticed i i thought i i was the
only one noticed that people the chats
just someone in the chat should clip it
for me i was busy rambling
he did he made a motion with his mat
like with his
face his mouth was kind of interesting
one more thing about this position after
g7 queen queen i just realized that
black can give a check on f1 but it
turns out that this is the paper tiger
king g3 queen g1 check
and white shuts shuts the whole
operation down to bishop f bishop g2 and
if black tries bishop f1
uh this is not a bad attempt but here's
what happens queen e6 jack
queen c6 shack and notice the queen and
the bishop on the same diagonal white
pushes d6 and the queen defends
the bishop and black and design
i mean at the end of the day apart from
the the extra two pawns which are nice
as well like the black king is just so
so out of the open and the black piece
is quite far removed from being able to
either create counter play against the
opponent king or provide any kind of
shelter
yeah
was it clipped and shipped no i'm still
waiting werewolves and wait
so ah jordan now
to move
and
g7 is what we're expecting let's show
one more time maybe very briefly why
bishop e4 is not not as good
yeah bishop before king
king e7
okay and the problem is that black has
full blockade over
i mean king f6
actually seems to lose so bishop ah
bishop c4 is the key move because bishop
takes d5 as well
the pawn falls and g7 king f7 d6 is an
attempt but after bishop b5 now the
other pun falls so one of the pawns is
going to fall either through
uh the force of the king or or through
the bishop capturing it so
i mean jordan is is obviously going to
play g7 it's just a question of when
he's going to do it
i've actually lost track of
what move it's so strange dania when
every day you're used to
a certain routine even not just for the
players but for us as commentators for
me every day it's like i arrive i have
my lunch then at four there's the first
time control then at some point the
dinner comes but today i'm completely
you know out of
like i don't know what time it is what
means should i be having what's going on
how far how far into the game i barely
know where
which city you're in yeah
but in this case well i've just looked
at the move number and we're about to
hit the second and final time control
we'll move 57 which means that three
moves from now the players will get an
extra uh 15 minutes but that's not of
their none of their concerns right now
because they still have plenty of time
and yeah it's a confusing confusing day
dania
while we look at the results here so far
and magnus he won his game against
dubois by forfeit of course we uh wish
daniel
speedy i always say speedy recovery but
he was on under just24 broadcast he
seems to be doing well i think what we
should wish him is to make it to berlin
in time for the start of the grand prix
then we had a couple of very fast draws
mahmoud against carrana and rapport
against giwi
nils against yan krishna of duda that
was such an interesting
fighting draw with
duda getting the upper hand but then
missing a shot out of the blue bishop
takes g7 and sergey karjakin when we
spent a lot of time
going uh over that game in detail he got
a win against
vidit and and now let's look at the
standings dania with only
a couple of games remaining before we
get the complete final standings of this
year's event
yeah and jordan won forrest if he wins
today he is going to jump out to a plus
score that's going to be a big result
for him
and uh prague although he's near the
bottom of the tournament standings
uh if he can complete the job today
which he's
you know he's not doing the greatest job
in the world of it but it looks like
he's moving in the right direction
prague can hold his head up very very
high you know guess what
-2 in a field like this for playing for
the very first time in tata steel group
a is uh is a phenomenal result and he
stuck with it you know he had a very
rough start he had a couple of games
uh that that he's certainly you know
that are certainly going to be haunting
him after the tournament
uh but he he beat his compatriot bidded
in that marathon game he beat grindelius
and now he's on the verge of defeating
yes it panko as we see jordan run forest
indeed going upon g7 and double
promotion and a winning endgame
what is the what do you feel is the the
setup here for some where he can put up
the most resistance
probably queen f5 just prevent that
because white what is why it's actually
a threat white's biggest threat is queen
e6 check followed by d6 i mean there is
no mate threat per se you have to be
careful if you're sam of losing losing a
piece or allowing a queen trade
uh but ultimately
white's biggest idea is just to push
this bond it's largely kinguished the
pawn
yeah i guess queen f5 is
is the most resilient
and okay queen b8 shack king c5
queen c7 check you can try king b4
and you know what you're hoping for if
you're sam is that jordan pushes the
pawn at the wrong moment and allows a
perpetual check and if you're jordan
it's actually not so easy to find the
right moment to push the pawn because if
you bring your queen back
in the hopes of
sheltering your king
well bishop c4 d6 bishop e6 and guess
what black has kind of a blockade over
the d7 square work is still required
here for jordan this is not over not
entirely over just yet
and i was just i'm just looking at our
producer because did i miss something i
saw back wrote in the chat
keep your cameras ready and i was like
what's going to happen now
he's going to turn into a werewolf
ah
i missed him i have a lot of my life
okay so these small things
the small victories small victories in
life
sorry dania um no you're good
and yeah well you're then this one might
go on a while longer the position is
winning
uh and sam he's actually gone for queen
f1 check
okay well that's uh
i feel like that's going to accelerate
his i think you know my hypothesis is
he's going to go queen ju on bishop f1
and uh he's going to force jordan to
find queen e6 queen c66 which he will
uh and after d6 sam is going to resign
watch me go three for three on that all
three of those things are about to
happen
let's let's let let's just see if that
actually happens
well the king g3 move is forced mm-hmm
now part two is sam going queen g1
and bishop f1
now i can't unsee the whole werewolf
thing like
now when i look at sam
i feel like when he doesn't shave
he's got that vibe going
i still haven't seen them i can't
believe nobody clipped it for me i still
haven't seen the
[Music]
the werewolf cry
but
you can kind of see what i'm talking
about can't you yeah
even without having actually seen it you
can kind of right nobody oh
he goes swimming d3 damn it
no
my my prophecies are not coming true
today
i'm sorry it's too early in the morning
for the the prophet it is too early in
the morning that's right a prophet
just like the werewolf operates at
midnight
um but anyways let's go to the other
game let's see how frog is faring in his
seemingly interminable attempt to
convert this
exchange and guess what he is not
making any progress right now fiona he's
just not he has not made any progress in
the last 10 moves i am
this game i'm really
really shocked
um
at
the lack of
at how the game is still going i mean
i'm struggling to even find my words but
i am shocked at this game there was so
many g4 i think was
uh the most clear-cut opportunity but
then even later on this h3 g4 idea any
idea to break through on the king side
yeah he had prague had a thousand ways
to win this game um and
you know that it didn't involve the
queen to g4 here
and then okay i mean h3 and g4 is just
something you should have seen
and then you know in this position
queen takes a seven queen b7 97 already
it gets a little bit more complicated
but you know this move queen e6 won the
game essentially on the spot because it
tied down black's queen to d6 now it's
easy for me to say sitting here oh we
should have done this this and this but
i think prague himself is going to be
seriously upset with himself for even if
he wins the game
for complicating it as much as he did
and ultimately i think prague didn't
seriously believe that the queen trade
uh that the end game could be holdable
for black that black had any serious
chances of putting together a fortress
and uh right now i think he's regretting
that decision so this was move 44 43
they're now on move 54 and essentially
zero progress has been made
and i honestly like at this point yes
panko keeps improving his position he
brings his king to b7 the email is plus
five yes of course but you still have to
figure out a way to actually win the
game yeah and i think i'm gonna have to
eat my
uh i'm gonna have to eat my words about
is how
a 99 favorite to win this game wow i
mean
how could you know that that this would
happen
also and he's got five minutes i was
just gonna say and this game went with
54 so six moves
to be made but very likely prague
uh well on when will end up very soon
having only uh little time as it's
likely daniel will see it happening over
and over again once he gets his 15
minutes
uh most of the time the first 10 minutes
i burned pretty much on the spot and
guess what i mean he's got a maximum of
20 minutes on the clock that's not a lot
for figuring out a win which he so far
has failed to find in the last 50
minutes so
you can see in the asset pengui's body
language notice how he's now hunched
over the board
he knows that maybe for the first time
in the last 25 moves
he's got maybe a small chance i still
think it's a small chance i still think
frogs winning chances are
far more significant than andre's
drawing chances but he knows he has a
chance and it's reflected in the way
that he's even sitting at the board
and uh well bigfoot has a question for
you but i think at this point so his
question is is this the worst kind of
lost friend ray where you can see 30
winning moves for white he never plays
them yet you still lose i think the
question is
uh is it gonna be a loss that's the the
main question here
yeah well it's it really all depends
because if uh prague ends up winning
this okay everything is forgiven
the technique was bad but at the end of
the day he won the game that's all that
matters
if he draws that's where the devastation
would set in i mean
this that's where really you know so so
the result of the game does matter you
know at the end of the day it is about
whether you can do what it takes to win
the game now just really quickly you
know what is it that prague has to do to
win well there's a couple of things that
he's gonna have to get done as he goes
back to f4
we talked about the potential of getting
the bishop to e8 the problem is that any
time white plays bishop a4 black can
respond either with bishop f7 or with
king d8 the second approach is to try to
infiltrate down the e file again any
time white plays rook e1 though
black steps back with bishop f7 and he's
managed to cover both of the
infiltration squares of the rook
so prague might at some point have to go
have to play a move like g4 sacrificing
upon even in the end game
this might produce the desired effect
you know one idea is actually to go
bishop c2
um maybe even to sacrifice the c4 pawn
and then to go g4 i think this
is the winning approach
i think this is the winning approach
fiona and then h takes g4 h5
and this is actually a lot more sharp
than it should have been but i still
think that white should be able to win
this with this passer i mean it's funny
that even in the end game long after
those uh early chances to play g4 were
gone that might still be
the break that he's looking for we saw
prague when he played king at first sort
of gave give a a nod to himself
um but yeah so far he hasn't fun do you
think the king going back here
is the king more useful on f4
when we get to the g4 break-in
yeah the king is ideally placed on f4 i
thought that he should have stayed there
uh the king the king is perfectly placed
perfectly poised both to supervise a
potential passer on the king's side and
to pick off any of black's pawns that
end up being weak as a result of the
pawn break so
is prague already contemplating this
idea bishop c2 why is bishop c2
necessary if you don't play it if you
just go g4
then black will play f takes g4 and you
won't be able to get to this g6 pawn so
you actually need to play bishop c2 and
you also need black to move the bishop
away from f7 which is probably going to
happen because if black doesn't take on
c4
well then y goes rookie one and white
might even sacrifice himself on on f5 so
how are you gonna do that
if i if i wait i mean it's not easy to
find a waiting move but yeah let's say
king the
even bishop takes that five here is
probably winning takes takes i mean this
is overwhelming for white
because
okay i mean you can go king f6 here
and then pre-move g6 i mean just look at
this g6
and and also you know whatever blah blah
blah
i can go g4 h takes g4 h5 and
you know the word biggest enemy uh to
uh two minor pieces is connected pastors
blah blah blah
i mean as in like it doesn't matter if
like this but i can move and arrange
this pieces however he wants it it's not
going to help
you know for a second i mean it's been
so long for a second i thought that your
rook was hanging
on b2 there when you played h5 and then
i wondered even if it was hanging okay
maybe it's a bit too much but
no it's still winning yeah even if you
were able to knight c3 takes a one h6 is
still winning for white that says a lot
as andre has indeed gone bishop f7 as we
predicted
uh and
well and by the way jordan i think is
right about to win the game he has found
a way
he has found a way to offer a queen
trade but in such a way that sam can't
really refuse it that's the problem here
so let's take a a deeper dive here first
of all how did we get here we didn't
miss so much so let's just rewind a few
yeah i mean it was a bunch of checks so
queen d3 check check and queen back to
e3 now why did jordan try to get this
king to d7 because the whole point is
that queen g6 check which is sam's main
defensive resource is now met with
bishop g4 check
and this interposition with check is
totally deadly king d6 queen b6 jack the
king has to drop back to d8 and now
white can go for total domination with
queen e5 followed by
d6 also white is threatening queen bhakt
this is resignable at this point and
even this position is essentially
resignable it goes without saying
that this is
a loss on the spot with connected
passers the win
is incredibly easy white just pushes
them
and uh
jordan his perseverance really really
paying off
of course he would have loved to defend
his title here but i think objectively
speaking plus one
is a very decent
result
for him and once again that last round
danya i'm really shocked i didn't think
that we were gonna have
so much fight um yeah in the last round
and you can see sam
really
disconcerted here the annoyance written
all over so and he got off on the wrong
foot i mean anish was very critical of
the way sam handled the opening taking
on t4 and it was
it was a very poorly played opening uh
and very uncharacteristic sam is known
for i mean as he proved again yesterday
his unbelievable opening perhaps
something misfired something went wrong
in today's opening
he got off on the wrong foot and
although he found that excellent
defensive idea with the pawn sacrifice
he never truly equalized and he was on
the defensive for the entire game when
that happens i mean you get tired and
you make one
you know significant mistake at any
moment in the game and you get a lost
position this game is essentially over
and we see
some
muttering to himself he's calculating
lines but the white pieces
are going to get activated here the
bishop will come to g4 with the check if
some avoids the end game and
this game will be over very very soon do
we stay here do we go back to prague
frag has found a really nice move he's
played bishop a4
okay prague is making
progress you're making progress
um
do i need to repeat that that was a very
high level of fun he's played bishop a4
which is an excellent excellent move
played with two minutes on the clock now
the point is that if andre and he does
sacrifice on c4 so i think he finally
came up with the right idea after bishop
takes c4 bishop e8 97 guess what
check king takes it rook takes c7
and uh you transform one advantage into
another and all of black's pawns
collapse and once these pawns collapse
white it's going to get connected
passers so i mean it's also crazy that
we could end up with in a bishop and
game here we already had one in karjakin
with it and we could have one and jordan
against
uh some
yeah not the most common type of end
game and yet we might have three of them
in the same round i mean what else
you know what what didn't happen in this
tournament now andre i think he can try
to continue holding with 97 but
at the very least white can make big big
progress by repositioning the bishop to
b5 which is really the ideal square uh
from where it can contest the e8 square
as well as defend c4 now this is a
little bit too much to handle i think
knight c8 but still i mean even with the
bishop on b5
uh white has to find some way forward
because rookie one there's king d8
and uh for the time being
black still
still holding the fortress down
dania very important question from the
chat what is that sound
what is what sound
oh
that is the sound of a good move well
again i i credit that to a uh american
football uh sports anchor
called chris berman who who does that
noise um and i've i'm a big fan of his
reportage
so you know
that's where i got it from
actually can i ask you a random question
uh as a chess commentator do you
sometimes watch other sports and try to
pick up things that commentators do
there
yeah so first of all i'm a huge sports
fan in general like regardless of
commentary i mean i watch
tons of basketball and american football
uh but now that i you know i do
commentary professionally i i feel like
i'm almost partially working when i
watch games because so i do
try to pick up on phrases i pick up on
the way that professional commentators
or my i have favorite commentators and
the way that they
that they handle difficult moments
in the coverage particularly let's say
when uh one team is down by 40 right
um the way that they continue to make
things interesting
which is something that we take for
granted but i've tried to apply that for
example even today
on a day where uh you know magnus has
already won the tournament so well what
is there to play for so it seems and yet
you know we've got 15 000 viewers and
i'm really really pumped that people are
still as into
are as into the action today
as with any other round fiona and that
honestly warms my heart
and uh i'm not
saying that you know this is uh i
oh
you know to me belong the spoils i
deserve all the credit for that but this
is something that i pay especially close
attention to because i think it's it's
always easy to commentate
uh when magnus is playing a brilliant
game you know you don't even really need
a commentator then it kind of plays
itself
but those lulls in the action uh when
everybody's tired that's when i think
you know the job of a commentator is is
hardest and that's what i try to look
for in in
sports games
and the job of the producer who has
found a shot to keep us all
keep us all busy and
mesmerized i was listening dania to what
you were saying but at the same time i
was looking oh yeah and i was thinking
andre i mean this is actually really
impressive twirling
yeah it really is it's just ex
artistic expert
you name it
and out of what you said i loved how you
are watching sports now is something
where you're like yeah i'm i'm doing
work here this is working i'm where i'm
working it's it's what is it called um
research and development
r d
yes and well let's uh maybe go back to
for a second to jordan and sam
as sam has avoided the trade of queens
but now it's my turn to go
on the attack
yeah queen e6 check here it goes they
basically repeated the initial position
that they
had when they entered this end game
except now it's jordan's move
and he's taken this move to play queen
e6 check okay i mean king d8 i think
jordan can just play d6 and sam can
resign
and king c7 d6 check sam can also resign
so in summary i think sam can resign
summed it up
summed it up nicely
and yeah for sam well unfortunately
there is
not really much here i mean there's only
those two
two squares so
uh i wonder if it's more
some coming to terms it's still looking
very focused
and yeah i don't know
i don't know what's it's he's hard to
read right now actually
like completely stone-faced
yeah he is uh he is hard to read but he
is coming to terms with what's happening
is gone king d8
and jordan is almost certainly going to
go d6 in this position
d6 queen h7 and then maybe build up a
battery with bishop g4
it's all over
and uh we see that bishop is working so
well the white bishop to protect
uh the white king
there what if we try and again give that
check
but now we're not in time at all because
yeah it's like brushing it brushing it
off like a fly off your shoulder you
know like bishop g2 and then
and then it's checkmate yeah
and
it's gonna happen
after d6 that is the only
check
it's the only check you have and the
only way to defend e7 is queen h7
and now the simplest win is bishop g4
creating the threat of queen c8 again
there's only one check and this check
can be parried with f3
whereas bishop d7 the simplest is just
to trade
into an obviously winning pawn end game
something like this
yeah
and i think if jordan plays d6 it'll be
all over
yeah i think he's literally just
checking last couple of details uh and
i'm sure d6 will appear
on the board very very shortly when um
sam might just resign immediately
which do we want to watch i mean
it for us
right
he's like go away from me
go back to jordan
and jordan
jordan is not looking jordan let's go d6
come on yeah
he doesn't seem ready just yet he just
pulled the face of
no there he goes
it was me it was me prodding him on
yeah i mean there's really really
nothing to calculate here because quincy
seven is such a devastating threat
that it necessitates the queen moving
back to h7
yeah i think i think very likely that
will be the end of the game queen h7
bishop g4
and curtains
right and sam again he is very very
tough on himself he's going to be
unhappy
he's going to be unhappy that he
and you know he didn't spoil his game
against karjak and that win stands as an
amazing display of both opening
preparation and
thinking on one's feet
uh but he's not going to be happy with
the way that he ended this tournament
and yet an amazing experience for sam
uh who was by now played in his fair
share of super tournaments and with
every passing one it does seem like he's
feeling more comfortable uh facing these
top guys
and drew magnus this tournament he's got
a lot to be proud of
for sure and i i think it's always a
matter you need a little bit of time
just to
uh
get over the disappointment of a last
round loss and then
when you
either go home or you've taken some time
to disconnect from that emotional aspect
of the last round
defeat and then you look back
at your tournament i think it just needs
that a little bit of distance
before you can realize that it was
actually
a good performance overall
right for sure and uh
yeah perspective is very important in
this regard
and realizing that every you know every
win that you can score against
somebody you rate it over 2 700 is worth
its weight in gold
even if your rating is 2 700 yourself
for sure and anya actually i'm just
saying that arjun aary guys see he has
won his last round game in the
challengers
and he finishes on 10 and a half out of
13.
um by the way jordan
did not go
bishop g4 for whatever odd reason but
he's got queen f6 which is also just as
winning
so there's a couple of moves let's have
a look uh maybe start with kim wait who
did jordan who did uh eric ice
oh wow just uh for good measure beating
a gm in the last round not too bad
i mean the 10 and a half has got to be
one of the biggest scorers
here in invik
unbelievable i mean the guy is
absolutely unbelievable oh and i see
what i see with jordan's devilish idea
is after king e8 he wants to throw in a
check on h5 you can't take that bishop
because you get lobster pincered
yeah bishop g4 bishop g4 and then the
pawn runs through to d7
that's it
so bishop g4 check
king e8 and now you can pick off the
bishop with queen e5 check
although the one thing oh this is
hilarious the one thing you got to be
very careful in this position you have
to give this check first
do not take the bishop because it's
going to be a stalemate after queen h3
so
one more trick to avoid
sam going queen e8 and jordan does go
queen e5 i wonder if sam's going to go
king d8 just for good measure forcing
jordan to find queen g5 check i think so
and queen g5 has been played he didn't
even take a second on that move he's
like no no i'm gonna dash all of your
hopes resignation and a win for mr van
forest in the final round
what an excellent resilient display i
mean he just kept it going and kept it
going and sam defended so well over so
many moves but it just wasn't quite
enough
indeed congratulations to jordan on a
great finish here and that leaves us
daniel with only one
single game pragnanda against
um against the andreas sepenko as we see
jordan there
taking his time
getting the score sheet
and uh i think only prague and jesse
panko are left even in the challengers
everything is finished so this is the
last
game uh of this year's tata steel chess
tournament
it looks increasingly like it is going
to be a decisive game in prague's favor
i just
don't see andre holding this together
holding all of the avenues
of invasion together the rook is too
powerful in this position the knight is
too passive
and andre has been taking a very long
time in this position trying to figure
something out but really i think to no
avail
and the players have not react actually
reached move
60 i don't know if we will uh maybe we
can go on a very
quick break
let's do it um
well i thought it might
[Laughter]
maybe i mean we could also do that done
yeah yeah
a little break please yes but okay
i will do the we'll do a rapid uh
rapid recap now yeah is that okay
let's go
break break break break and then rapid
recap perfect great plan
we'll see you in a minute
[Music]
so
jordan von freist you just beat sam
shankland with the white pieces um
i've hardly seen you very exhausted
after a game and
this game you look very tired yeah i'm
very tired really exhausted after this
game it was
very tough and i mean
just a long long long long game i didn't
expect i would win um at all because his
position was very solid but i just kept
on trying because oh i have an extra
pawn
but yeah i didn't expect to win and i
mean it's the last round of
of the tournament it was really it has
been a long tournament
indeed
yeah you were pawn up the basically the
whole game
but you kept on pushing you tried to
create troubles for him yeah well i had
a pawn i wasn't actually sure if i
should win it because he gets very solid
like knight on d6 and then i didn't know
what to do
but i thought i should anyway just take
the pawn and then see how it goes i
thought there were several moments where
it was very close to a two draw but i
thought i should keep on trying since
i'm always on the better side
and finally late in the endgame he
probably made a mistake i'm not really
sure where but at some point dm
um
last year you won the tournament now
you're at plus one you finished the
possible one but
what a rollercoaster event so many wins
and losses yeah
it's very strange sometimes i
i have some sometimes very solid results
like i think i once made 11 draws in the
tournament and last year
i had nine draws and four wins but here
it's been
just a really topsy-turvy event um like
i think i won five games and lost four
so that makes it even more tiring
especially like losing so many games but
also winning but overall i'm of course
very satisfied i mean ending on on a
high like this is is very nice
um
do you yeah so so like nine decisive
results um
how how hard is it to actually cope with
all these emotions
i don't know
now currently i'm just quite tired so
i'm not
but in general like when i lose a game i
i just i just keep on going look forward
to the next game um and same when i win
a game so just want to fight every game
um you don't always get to but i i try
to and uh it leads to interesting games
that's for sure yeah well you also like
in this tournament there are also like a
lot of games that were not
apologies for cutting out of the
interview but we had a result
in pragnanda against his panco uh with
yes panko resigning and we are back just
in time to see the absolute devastation
of andreas panko
indeed and you know he could have lasted
for maybe a couple more moves he could
have made move 60 but at the end of the
day uh the result was no longer in
question once prague put his bishop on
b5 we identified that as the x factor if
prague had managed to do that we said
the game would be over the strain on
black's position would be too heavy and
andre he brought on the defeat even
faster bishop e6 allowing bishop ba he
just forgot about that move and he
resigned here because after 97
the simplifying operation wins the game
rook a7 check and now rook takes e7 and
white just vacuums up all of the king
side pawns boom
boom and then these connected passers
are easily going to decide the game d5
bishop comes back to g6 you can also
take this one for good measure but
essentially the age fund is unstoppable
there's nothing more to play for and
andre as you can see very upset losing
the last game of the tournament
i mean this is such a tough image to
look at
we see andre hasn't even got up from
from the table yet
and yeah just utter devastation and
disappointment all over his face written
all over his face um
i think once again it will also be a
case with uh some distance
and some um
some perspective
he can reflect on the tournament
differently but of course today
a devastating loss and i mean bigfoot
was asking you earlier dania is this uh
some of the worst kind of loss when you
know you had been lost for so long but
then you're given some whisker of hope
and it's dashed
yeah that's the worst feeling because
you get that excitement and you lose all
over again because in your mind
uh by the time prague won the exchange
andre had already resigned in his mind
and then all of a sudden after the queen
trade maybe i can build a fortress maybe
he won't find a way to break through you
got that excitement and that is dash
that's what makes this so painful it's
the fact that you essentially you lose
the game again but it is what it is an
excellent game overall by prague it
wasn't smooth by any means there were
mistakes in the technical conversion
phase but by and large pragnanda with
the final round victory he beats fit it
he beats green dallas and he beats
histopanko three wins in tata steel
notched by the indian youngster and a
performance that he can definitely hang
his hat on for sure what a debut for the
young indian prague by the way is
getting ready for his interview so we'll
be hearing from him uh in just a second
but as you said i mean first well he is
ready so let's go there
pragananda he just beat uh um essie
panko with uh with the white pieces
um
that was like a very very good game it
seemed
yeah i think i played a very tall move
40 and then i think my technique wasn't
that good i think i should have finished
much earlier
but i went to this end game and after
going to the same game i wasn't sure
whether it was
completely winning or not because he
could he could set up some fortress yeah
but um i think i when i got this bishop
a4 i was sure i would win that
um most of the game you run exchange up
um what was like this moment when
when he allowed knight f6
yeah but i think already
that is
very bad for black and because if king
jisan i think maybe there is 97 his king
is just very weak
so but i didn't expect uh he'll be
giving uh exchange sag but okay anyway
it's lost i think
um you scored five and a half out of 13
in your very first super tournament
how was how was your experience here
uh first of all i have to thank uh the
organizers for giving me this invitation
because
it's a great experience for me i learned
a lot
i think i could have scored uh
better than this
uh combining the questions i got in the
tournament
but uh
i think i lost uh
four games
uh
out of five in the middle which was bad
i think there i could have scored like
at least one point more and uh
yeah it's still good that i scored fair
enough
and
yeah final game was definitely
uh
definitely i'm happy about it
you won your last two games here did the
tournament finish too early shouldn't we
play another 10 rounds ah okay the
the penultimate round was a walkout so i
can't really it's true yeah i can't
really take that as a win but
um
yeah the last game was good so
maybe if there are more runs maybe i
could score more points
do you still feel very energized
like do you feel yourself a lot of
energy
i don't think so i'm tired like yeah
yeah i can play
like a few more games but
like i don't think the quality will be
so good
um what's next for you after this
tournament i don't have anything planned
uh you know over the board tournaments
but i have this melt water coming
so it'll be
yeah another great tournament uh
so yeah looking forward to that okay oh
i wish you all the best thank you
similar story between jordan and prague
both of them of course very happy with
that last round win uh but also you can
sort of see the exhaustion on the faces
after what is one of the longest
tournaments on the tour but anya what a
what an event it's been
what an absolutely incredible event and
uh i'm sad to say that this is going to
be the final one of these but
still i'm looking forward to it because
this is
time for your round 13 rapid recap fiona
the game that we chose today
is the battle between sergey karjakin
and uh
vidit
which um and there were many battles
this this uh
game this final round the players didn't
just come out just to make quick draws
uh we had a lot of amazing fights and
this was one of them this started off as
a four nights scotch
quite a rare guess at the top level we
were thinking on move three what is it
going to be an italian game a re-lopez
but no we were happy to see and not a
real
fortnite scotch with which leads to
fresher positions and
um you're the sorry not here it invited
striking in the center with d5 and here
karjakin sprung the first surprise
yeah i hear magnus magnus surprised
mahmoud yaroff and grendelius here did
have a novelty against dubov
uh in the tournament sponsored by
kuryakyn i remember pragnando had had
this in one of his games
um i gotta have a little bit of fun now
here the main move is e takes d5
uh and after c takes d5 castles this is
the old school line but sergey going for
something quite rare bishop d2 uh this
has been played a couple of times in
recent years
and the point is that this essentially
uh well this isn't for simplifications
but it invites a bunch of
simplifications right into an end game
where white is absolutely not risking
and sergey made it clear in the
interview that he did not plan on taking
any risk this game he was more or less
fine with the draw but fiona he wanted
to test fit it just a little bit and
that is why he declined to draw right
around the tampo if he wanted vinnette
to prove that he could actually fully
equalize so here we go the
simplification
the start of the simplifications here
bishop takes f6 queen takes we see in
exchange on e4
and takes on b2 takes on c6 takes takes
takes 6. rook b8 and
queens and rook get traded off as well
and we ended up in this position
where we thought uh we're probably just
headed for a quick draw here
yeah i mean this looks basically totally
symmetrical maybe a tiny bit of an edge
for white because of the superior
placement of the bishop and the fact
that white has a tempo sergey brings the
bishop back in order to defend the d1
square but
it did everything right he brought his
king in got his rook to e8 threatening
checkmate and after h4 this is the
moment when things started veering off
course just a little bit forbidden the
the simplest path to a draw was the move
bishop f5 now the reason he rejected it
was probably because of rook b7 and well
after bishop c2 rook c7 it looks like he
loses a pawn and he does but the move he
might have underestimated is bishop b4
if white takes the bishop then after
rook takes before the h4 pawn is hanging
and that's an immediate draw if rook
takes a7 then after bishop takes f3 g
takes f3 the thing is with this pawn
structure being as incredibly damaged as
it is white has zero winning chances
this is well known and vinid certainly
knows that but there was something in
this line that he didn't like or he was
attracted by the uh look of bishop a6
but whatever it was things started
getting just a smidge more complicated
for it right about here and you're
really emphasizing the importance of you
have to be precise from at the get-go
it's easy to underestimate that kind of
decision you're only on move you know 18
equal materials symmetrical pawn
structure
but as you say once he vetted played
bishop a6 immediately sergey putting on
the pressure and starting to ask some
questions how are you going to defend
the pawn on c7 then filing up the
pressure on the a file
and on the rook he's asking a lot of
questions that you don't have easy
answers sergey activating his pieces
doing a good job
of deflecting all of the attacks but
after bishop b3 it's a very
uncomfortable position all of a sudden
forbidden who can move his bishop the
bishop on a6 is paralyzed because behind
the bishop sits a very weak pawn on a7
avida does his best he goes c5 trying to
shut down white's bishop sergey says no
no no no you're not going c4 uh he
prevents that and now we have a quieter
stage of the game where both players try
to improve the position of their pieces
sergey going f3 preparing to bring his
king out after rook d6 a very impressive
decision anishkari was in the studio at
the time and he was impressed with c4
this looks like a very committal move
fiona closes the bishop but
it fixes the weak pawn on c5 which
enables white to attack it with the rook
in the future you can't really do this
immediately because of course you allow
c4 and this is exactly what sergey does
after king a7 he plays rook a5
and this was really the most important
moment of the whole game and fiona we
talked about how vidic's losses in the
previous rounds perhaps uh you know
really discouraged him and in another
set of circumstances he might have found
the drawing path which started with the
move rook c6 you have to defend that
pawn
yeah at this really a crucial moment
here we talked about it plenty rube c6
the only way uh to defend the pawn uh
and here well we looked at the line
after rook b6
the rook has to keep defending the
bishop
and rook
b4
b4 this is a very important move
attacking the bishop in the pawn the
bishop drops back to b3 and now up comes
the king king d6 the rook has to give a
check otherwise you lose c4
um and if you go rook a5 here
then after bishop takes c4 it's very
important to point out this is a really
cool line rook takes a7 rook takes h4
rook takes f7 this is not an easy draw
under normal circumstances but black is
the brilliant rook a4 and now not rook
takes a2 because you lose the second
pawn to his crew but first you go king
e6 the pawn on a2 is defenseless and
this is a very easy draw two on one on
one side of the board so this was
the drawing line after rook d5 check
instead of rook a5 king moves to the
side to c6 and white will not be able to
sustain the c4 upon the long run so this
really was the last moment which fit it
had a very clear-cut path toward a drop
but oop and let me just fast forward
here
sorry go ahead
no i was just gonna say that he
and king d8 really is a sign of
frustration he just you just sort of
abandoned hopes in this position
yeah it's not clear of course so as what
he
missed in the other line there must be
something down the line it was a long
variation but i think as you pointed out
the results from the last couple of
games yesterday is a very tough loss
against shakhmaria
surely had something
to do with it
and well now sergey karjakin picking up
a pawn
and bringing out the king
starting to activate all the pieces and
his technique dania was a sight to
behold
exquisite and it started with h5 this is
a great move it provokes further
weaknesses if you go g5 you're going to
have a massive weakness on h6 which
white can attack with rook c6 bid it
didn't do that
but the pawn trade really softens up it
softens up black's king's side pawns now
sergey getting his king a lot closer to
the center and getting it right into the
center he plays g4 in order to fix
black's pawns in place the pawn on f3 is
a little bit of a weakness but it's easy
to defend it can be defended with the
bishop with the king and it really was
not a problem and here it's a healthy
pawn up sergey moves his work aside in
order to pave the way for the pawn
and the next critical moment he goes
bishop d1 there's that move to defend f3
rook d6 jack by the way does not win the
bishop because of rook d5 with a winning
bishop end game and vidit maybe he could
have defended more resiliently but fiona
he ends up playing bishop b7 and this
accelerates his demise sergey
immediately pounces bishop b7
relinquishes the control of the square
on f5 and the problem is that after rook
f5 which is the move that sergey played
you cannot avoid
the rook trade of course sergey had to
evaluate this bishop ending with the
extra pawn is it enough but dania the
trousers came into full force
indeed that's a russian chess term for
basically two pawns on either side of
the board that cannot be stopped
that overwhelm the opposing forces
usually it means
it's referred to an upon end game but
even though black has a bishop that
bishop does not constitute a sufficient
force black's only pass pawn is very
easily restrained by white's king and
that's exactly what happens first sergey
brings his bishop to e4 forcing black's
bishop back here comes the c pawn here
comes the c pawn the point is that after
king d6 f6 this is the classic trousers
these pawns are too overwhelming and if
you play bishop e6 bishop oh no sorry
not bishop f5 my bad that's a different
line you go f7 bishop f7 c8 queen if
king e6 then it's time for bishop f5
check distracting the king if you take
the pawn then you lose the bishop and
white makes another queen so that's not
possible
vidid basically has to tread water and
all that sergey had to do was to figure
out the right configuration of pieces
that would allow him to restrain the
h-pawn and then walk the king all the
way toward the bishop at first he of
course had to figure out a way to
restrain his h-bond and that meant
re-maneuvering his bishop from e4 fiona
yeah we thought that he was going to go
for a plan with f4 but
here he decided he'd had a change of
height he brought the bishop around to
d3 to f1 and finally to h3 from where
the bishop is now defending the pawn on
f5 there is nothing left for vivid to do
here he can only wait and that gives
sergey karjakin enough time to simply
walk his king all the way over to the
queen side
indeed one more attempt to complicate
matters by vivid king f7 attempting
sergey into f6 then black had the idea
of going h3 and h2 white is still
completely winning here after bishop b6
but uh there is no need for these
complications sergey just going king b6
and bit it resigned
the king's march to b8 followed by
promotion is
simply unstoppable and what an exquisite
technical effort by sergey who and who
would have guessed that the game would
not have ended in a draw after the
opening yet that is the nature of these
players they are able to squeeze
uh blood from a stone they can make
something out of nothing time and time
again and this was a great example of it
a very painful tournament and a very
painful ending for vetted but a great
recovery for sam for sergey who himself
had a painful loss yesterday against sam
shanklin absolutely kudos to sergey
koryakin exquisite technique indeed this
was your rapid recap of round 13. hope
you enjoyed that and dania
uh well last look at our la final round
uh results which was a lot more bloody
than i had anticipated
indeed we had a lot of players coming
out ready to play mamidyar of carowan
and not among them they made a quick
draw report and geary made a quick draw
it was great having anish in the studio
credelius duda but everybody else
including grindelius duda which happened
to end in a draw but what a draw it was
they were out there in order to play
jordan scoring a win prague scoring a
last round win against andre yes pango
who was devastated but what uh comeback
by prague what resilience of course
magnus winning by forfeit he wins the
tournament and uh kuryakyn as we just
described defeating indeed and there we
see the final standings magnus carlsen
winner of the 2022 tata steel chess
with a great score of nine and a half
out of 13.
in a shared second and third place we
find shahriar mahmoud and richard report
both of whom had really
tremendous performances here then behind
that anish on seven and a half karjakin
with his last round win as well as
jordan finishing
on plus one fabiano not been his
tournament yes panko is also going to
struggle with his last round uh loss
then duda also not the tournament he was
hoping for vidit probably one of the
biggest disappointments for him it will
have been after the early lead
and uh so on and so forth i wasn't
planning to read out every single name
on that list
daniel and some
yeah well all of the play you know i
think no you're right all the players
had their own arcs you know they had
their own tournament experiences and and
even though they didn't all score nine
and a half out of 13
uh you know they all had a fantastic run
and we congratulate very heartily the
world champion magnus carlson for
winning the masters and of course our
generic ic for winning the tata steel
challenges we expect great things from
him
in the future and we expect great things
uh from the chess calendar in the near
future and that will be heralded by the
chess.com rapid chess championship which
is a brand new world-class online event
series for the top 100 players top 10
women and top 10 juniors in the world
watch is the very best compete for their
share of 20k each week culminating with
a 150 000
prize final if you're experiencing
already a little bit of chess withdrawal
as the tata steel comes to an end well
don't because it all starts at 9am
pacific so very soon saturday february
the 12th right here on chess.com and
every weekend thereafter this is a very
exciting new event and for more
information on it head on over to
go.chess.com
r c c the rapid chess championship
coming your way early in february so
much chess section to look forward to no
rest for the wicked the grand prix gets
on the way in just a few days then the
rapid chess championship but for us it
is time now to wrap up this 2022 tata
steel uh chess tournament coverage
dania first
first of all a huge
thank you to you it's been an absolute
pleasure commentating alongside you big
shout out of course to our producer uh
big running the the ship here behind the
scenes a huge thank you
to all of you guys watching us at home
keeping us company big shout out to the
team here of course difficult uh
circumstances to win a tournament in
in the middle of a pandemic so huge
shout out to everyone who made this
tournament possible so many people
working so hard
behind the scenes
and yeah that is it for me dania i'll
let you finish the show
well i echo everything you just said i'm
so very grateful that i get to do what i
love i get to wake up maybe a little bit
earlier than i would have liked but i
get to do what i would have done anyway
but i'm even more grateful that i can do
it with such an amazing supporting cast
including
an amazing co-commentator it's been such
a pleasure covering tata steel with you
fiona this is a marathon event we did it
and uh i just hope that everybody
enjoyed the coverage and everybody
enjoyed the magical atmosphere of this
one of a kind tournament i'm sad it's
over but
uh i'm gonna get some sleep tomorrow and
on to so many other exciting tournaments
thank you fiona thank you to everybody
for watching and to bigfoot for the
absolute heroic camera work and
production work as well absolutely thank
you dania shout out as well to robert
house who was here for the first part of
the tournament that concludes our
coverage hope you guys enjoyed it thank
you so much for watching have a good one
and we'll see you soon
but in comes f5 and white's queen is
actually basically trapped and if white
takes on b6 well this doesn't work out
because after f4
the queen takes b2 with check heading
for h4
neil's stopping that well queen goes to
the other side
queen going to h4 back to g3 and as soon
as white skin goes to c5 whoop king
comes back to d7 king goes back to d4
king goes back to e6 and there's
literally nothing that i can do so make
no mistake this is not an easy win and
the evaluation could change in a single
half
[Music]
you